Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wir sitzen vor dem Salon.
Und wir haben eine turbulente Woche hinter uns. Die Zölle gehen rauf, dann werden sie wieder ausgesetzt, dann aber gegen China doch erhöht. China hält dagegen. Die Börsenkurse sind volatil, wie man es lange, lange nicht gesehen hat.
Hast du gekauft, als Trump dir schrieb, extra für dich die Nachricht, best time to buy oder was er geschrieben hat?
Leider nein, leider nein. Aber natürlich hat die Börse dann einen Satz nach oben gemacht, ging aber dann auch schon wieder runter. Wir wissen ja gar nicht, was jetzt gerade der Fall ist. Vielleicht ist schon alles zusammengebrochen, während wir hier noch in Ruhe sitzen. Es läuft nicht so nach Plan.
Richtig langsam zusammen.
Langsamer, ja, genau.
Ja, es läuft wirklich nicht nach Plan. Wir haben heute Textgrundlagen, die ich am Mittwoch vorbereitet habe.
Ja.
Das Ganze geschah ja am Donnerstag. Am Mittwoch habe ich mir gedacht, okay, die Leute reden jetzt immer darüber, was Trump hier so schreibt und so weiter. Man hängt sich so an kleinen, spontanen Sprechakten auf, aber es gibt ja Textgrundlage. Ja. Wir haben diesen Mar-a-Lago-Akkord, der vorherige Doktrine, wie man Weltwirtschaftspolitik macht. Amerika sieht sich ja zu Recht als Hegemon. Wie man das neu organisiert. Wir hatten vom heutigen Finanzminister zusammen mit dem heutigen Chief Economic Advisor von Trump, also zwei Posten, die durch den Senat bestätigt werden müssten, also wirklich hoch aufgehangen und wichtig. Eine Art Playbook, das ist im November 24, 30 Seiten, PDF und so. Und ich habe das alles mal in sozusagen eine Textgrundlage heute gebracht, die wir auch im Salon nachher in Gänze verlinken und so. Und es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie sehr man alles, was in den Nachrichten dazu gesagt wird, hört, wenn man das einmal kennt. Weil es gibt ja durchaus einen Plan, also es folgte ja einem Plan. Und es gab eben zwei Zäsuren. Also China hat sofort die Gegenzölle gemacht, ganz wichtige Zäsur und diese Treasury Bonds. Also nicht irgendwie Europa haut sich auf die Brust und sagt, wir sind auch stark oder so, spielt alles keine Rolle, sondern es waren einfach die, funktioniert der Dollar noch.
Ganz genau. Wir sind ja hier in einer Situation, die wir schon kennen, nämlich als Liz Truss, manche haben schon vergessen, kurz Premierministerin war, da hatte sie die Idee, um die britische Wirtschaft anzukurbeln, müsse man nur wieder den Superreichen noch mehr Steuerlasten abnehmen und darauf haben ja auch die Märkte genau so reagiert, nämlich die Staatsanleihen plötzlich sind nicht mehr so beliebt. Man muss also eine Risikoprämie aufschlagen, das heißt, die Zinsen für die britische Staatsanlage steigen. Das bedeutet, die Verschuldung der Briten wird teurer dadurch, da die diese Zinsen ja auch dann bedienen müssen, und bedeutet vor allem, dass man das also nicht mehr als einen sicheren Hafen betrachtet, britische Staatsanleihen zu haben. Genau das haben wir jetzt in Amerika wieder, dass nun Trump mit seiner verrückten Zollpolitik dafür sorgt, dass plötzlich die Märkte sagen, wir brauchen da mal so eine Idiotenprämie, das müsste ein bisschen teurer sein, denn so sicher ist dieser Hafen, amerikanische Staatsanleihen, plötzlich uns nicht mehr. Und dann geschieht genau das und plötzlich muss Trump darauf reagieren. Und da sieht man wieder, wie sehr dann jemand, der eigentlich glaubt, er sei jetzt der Präsident, er kann machen, was er will, die Hände gebunden werden durch die Macht des Marktes.
Absolut. Also, dass Trump diese Zölle plötzlich alle zurücknahm, bis auf China, war eine totale Panikreaktion.
Ja.
Also, das wusste er selber nicht vorher. Dann haben ihm nicht nur seine eigenen Leute, sondern dann haben auch die Banken angerufen und haben gesagt, das sind die Kennziffern. Du kannst so und so viel von der Fett fordern. Und wir haben sozusagen zwei Leitzinsen. Das eine ist eher politisch gemachte. John Powell sagt irgendwas. Und das andere ist eben der, der am Markt entsteht. Und dann haben vorher alle gedacht, naja, der Warren Buffett wird sich ja wohl nicht so geirrt haben, wenn er da nur noch in T-Bonds geht und so. Er hat ja irgendwie 250 Milliarden Cash angehäuft und alle so, der vertraut den Aktien nicht, der geht in die Staatsanleihe. Und dann, als es drauf ankam, nee, doch nicht. Die Strategie hat sich für ihn ausgezahlt, weil er sozusagen vor dem Börsencrash alles umgelagert hatte. Aber darin liegt keine Losung. Und diese Staatsanleihen Amerikas, also der Preis für die gesteuert, oder Folge der Nachfrage nach ihnen, steuert halt extrem viel. Also da hängen einfach so viele andere Zinsentscheidungen dran und so, dass das, also als Trump da so steigend und meinte, ja, hier haben so manche Leute kalte Füße gekriegt und so, hat er von sich selbst geredet. Ja, ja, um das, hat ihn selbst überrascht, dass er das hat.
Um das auch mal runterzubrechen für die Leute, die jetzt da nicht so tief drin sind, es ist ja ganz einfach zu verstehen. Also Zinsen sind ja quasi eine Risikoprämie. Das heißt, wenn man irgendetwas mit hoch, mit hohen Zinsen hat, dann ist das Risiko auch relativ hoch. Also man kann natürlich auch in Staatsanleihen von Schwellenländern zum Beispiel sein Geld investieren. Da kann man sehr gute Zinsen bekommen, aber es ist das Risiko auch sehr hoch, dass damit dann plötzlich das Geld futsch ist, dass das kein sicherer Hafen ist. Und genau das ist eben hier der Fall, wenn man eine solche sehr freidrehende Politik hat, dass dann das nicht mehr als ein solch sicherer Hafen angesehen wird. Und ich habe in diesen Tagen aber auch nochmal viel über Elon Musk nachgedacht, der ja auch außer sich ist und diese Zollpolitik und so weiter nicht gut findet. Wenn man sich ja mal ansieht, was Joe Biden gemacht hat, dann war das ja ein Inflation Reduction Act, in Klammern, für Elon Musk.
Ja, absolut.
Das war ein Akt, der die E-Mobilität vorantreiben würde, die die amerikanische Wirtschaft stärken würde, die die Konsumenten stärkt mit höheren Löhnen. Das heißt, die können sich auf meinen Tesla leisten. Und es ist generell eine Richtung, die sagt, wir müssen mehr auf E-Mobilität gehen. Das ist ganz klar die Richtung gewesen. Plus, er ist als ein doch politischer Falke immer wieder zu erkennen gewesen, dann Biden, der ja sagt, wir brauchen eine Absicherung gegen China, wir brauchen mehr Rüstung. Er war jemand, der sagte, auch die Satelliten sind vor uns wahnsinnig, auch da müssen wir hegomonial bleiben. Also all das, was Elon Musk auch noch bedient. Und reine Ideologie, anders kann man es sich ja nicht erklären, hat Elon Musk ins falsche Lager getrieben. Genau. Denn, wenn man jetzt ökonomisch rational denken würde, dann hätte man als Elon Musk gesagt, mir ist völlig egal, was die Demokraten für eine Voke-Politik machen oder einfordern. Wenn die wollen, dass ich ab morgen die Leute mit Kuckuck und die IA begrüße, mache ich auch das. Denn meinem Unternehmen, meinen vielen Unternehmen nutzt es, dass diese Politik von beiden betrieben wird. Und stattdessen ist jetzt so Trump gelaufen, der genau das alles jetzt gerade zerschlägt. Das kann sich natürlich auf Dauer nochmal ändern, aber momentan sieht es eher gruselig aus.
Also gerade Tesla, ich habe das hier mal markiert mit Farben. Der Tesla-Cos in der Trump und in der Biden-Zeit.
Ah ja.
Unter Trump, der Tesla-Cos liegt irgendwo so bei knapp über 50 oder 40 oder so. Trump kommt ins Amt 2016. Trump geht aus dem Amt und der Tesla-Cos liegt so bei 50 oder 60. Kannst gar nicht so genau erkennen, es ist so knapp über der Null-Linie. Dann kommt Biden und das Ding geht zehnfach nach oben. Also unter Joe Biden, und zwar schon nach anderthalb Jahren, Tesla-Cos 400 Dollar pro Aktie. Das ist einfach eine Verzehnfachung seines Vermögens. Damit wurde Elon Musk zum reichsten Menschen des Planeten und in der Geschichte so wahrscheinlich. So, dann bleibt er da oben und dann wird Donald Trump Präsident und das ganze Ding stürzt wieder in sich zusammen. Ja. So, die Pointe ist einfach, und es geht ja nicht nur für Tesla, hätten die Superreichen in Amerika, gesagt, wir wollen, dass weiter ein Demokrat regiert und wir sind sogar bereit, 20 Prozent pauschale Vermögenssteuer auf unsere Vermögen zu zahlen, hätte sich das für alle ausgezahlt. Die wären reicher als heute unter Trump. Und die Gesellschaft hätte auch noch was davon, von dieser Vermögensabschätzung. Stattdessen sind die ärmer geworden, das Geld wurde einfach vernichtet, Buchwerde, die weggeflogen sind und es wird ja jetzt wieder weiter runtergehen. Das war ja nur so ein, bis alle gesehen haben, ach so auf China bleibt's, sorry. Also 10 Billionen plus ist doch sinnlos. Und jetzt ist es blöd für alle. Wir haben heute einen Culture Bar. Wir haben die Ärmsten der Gesellschaft nicht durchfinanziert und die Reichen sind trotzdem ärmer. Das ist ja absurd. Also die Realität ist so dumm, dass ich mittlerweile denke, Demokratie, schön und gut, aber wenn wir es auslosen würden, wer die Mandate bekommt, wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher, dass dort kluge Leute sitzen. Also durch diesen demokratischen Prozess, wie wir ihn jetzt haben, mit diesem Wahlkampf, wie wir ihn hatten, ist einer der dümmst möglichen Optionen Präsident geworden.
Ja, das muss man ja auch noch mal sehen. Trump ist ja damals mit einer Administration in seiner ersten Amtszeit gestartet, die sich durchaus sehen lassen konnte. Nicht durch die Bank, aber da waren ja durchaus erfahrene Leute dabei und die wussten auch ein bisschen, wie zum Beispiel Kapitalmärkte funktionieren. Und warum Zölle nicht grundsätzlich gut sein können.
Die haben schon morgens mal Bescheid gesagt und nicht erst 5 vor 12, mitten in der Nacht.
Und die wussten das auch, die haben es auch verstanden. Nun hat Trump gesehen, dass die ihm aber mit unter die Hände gebunden haben, weil sie ihm dann immer darauf verwiesen, na das geht so nicht, Mr. President. Davon wollte er sich jetzt losmachen und hat jetzt diese Knallchargen an seiner Seite, die mal heute dies, morgen das sagen, aber dort ist es nicht mehr so durchdacht. Bis dann irgendwann wieder jemand von der FED kommen muss und sagen muss, es geht doch nicht so. Wir müssen da jetzt mit dieser Zollpolitik mal kurzfristig zumindest aufhören. Das ist ja interessant, dass es also die verbliebenen Experten sind, also einfach die Funktionäre in einem technokratischen System, die noch nicht ausgetauscht werden konnten, die jetzt gerade Trump noch mal den Arsch gerettet haben. Das ist eine wirklich gruselige Situation.
Also wir kommen halt auf die Textgrundlage zu sprechen, um zumindest die inhärente Logik dessen, was da geplant war, mal zu würdigen. Also man kann es schon würdigen. Ich habe einen Text von Yannis Varoufakis dabei, der meinte, das ist schon riskant, das zu machen, aber es ist auch nicht völlig blöde aus so einer amerikanischen Sicht, dass man so einen Hegemon neu aufstellen möchte, weil man sieht, es ging ja einiges flöten, warum werden alle iPhones in China hergestellt und so. Aber gut.
Genau, darüber müssen wir unbedingt mal diskutieren, denn es ist vielleicht nicht nur irrational, sondern es gibt noch mal eine ganz andere Idee davon. Aber die ist auch sehr langfristig dann nur zu verstehen. Und das ist interessant, dass ein so uralter Präsident ein dann so langfristiges Projekt verfolgen könnte.
Ja, aber das ist genau der Punkt. Das politische Ziel ist ohne Frage richtig. Nur die Zeit, die man dafür braucht. Und ich möchte daran erinnern, wir haben in Deutschland einen Wirtschaftsminister gehabt, dem wir unterstellen, dass er einerseits klug ist und auf der anderen Seite sich beraten lassen und so weiter und so fort. Und trotzdem gab es das auch bei Robert Habeck an diesem Heizungsgesetz, dass er sah, wir haben einen Krieg durch Putin, ab jetzt weniger Gas in Deutschland, wir müssen sofort alle Heizungen austauschen. Und dann hat man ihm gesagt, nee, du kannst nicht in den nächsten drei Jahren alle Heizungen austauschen. Das wäre ein 50 Jahre Projekt. Diese Verwirrung kommt immer wieder, weil man in charge nicht genau abschätzen können, wie groß das Reich ist, das sie regieren. Dass es eben nicht nur Washington DC oder die Berliner Blase ist, sondern ganz Deutschland, ganz Amerika, die ganze Welt. Und das habe ich auf Neuwerke gesagt, man unterschätzt das, wie groß das immer ist. Wie viel das, man fährt stundenlang Zug, man fliegt tagelang mit dem Flugzeug, und man hat trotzdem noch nicht alles erreicht. Man unterschätzt immer wieder, wie groß diese Gesellschaft ist und wie träge und überhaupt. Und das ist jetzt Trump-basiert, das ist Robert Habeck-basiert. Es scheint so ein Ding zu sein, dass man, wie sollte man auch regieren, wenn man es wirklich abschätzen kann? Welche Reichweite das so ist. Schwierig.
Lass uns noch über die Schulden reden. Das ist ja ein Problem für Trump. Er will geringere Staatsschulden eigentlich haben. Das soll ja auch ein Grund sein für seine Zollpolitik. Nun sind wir ja im Podcast, in dem immer wieder gesagt wird, naja, ein Staat ist ja nicht wie ein Privathaushalt. Der kann sich ja immer weiter verschulden. Und das stimmt natürlich erst einmal deshalb, weil der Staat so einen Ewigkeitsversprechen hat, ja, der Staat geht immer weiter. Und es ist nicht wie unser Leben, das endlich ist, sondern eigentlich kann der Staat da auf eine unendliche Perspektive hinauslaufen. Und zugleich ist es ja auch so, dass Investitionen durch mehr Schulden möglich sind. Das heißt, die Vermögensberge wachsen, nicht nur die Schuldenberge wachsen. Bei der Aufrüstung ist das anders. Und ich glaube, dass das gerade in der Öffentlichkeit sehr vermixed wird. Und das sorgt für eigentlich ein falsches Denken, nämlich das, was jetzt im Zuge der Aufrüstungsdebatte und der Schuldenregeländerungen passiert, ist nicht in dem Sinne MMT, wie das mal gedacht wurde. Nämlich da ging es ja schon auch darum, dass diese Staatsausgaben wiederum mehr Wirtschaftswachstum generieren. Und ich habe einen Podcast gehört von der Böckler Stiftung System Relevant von Sebastian Dulin. Und Sebastian Dulin ist ja ein sehr anerkanter Ökonom. Und der spricht, ich empfehle das komplett zu hören, aber der spricht nicht nur über die Wirtschaftsprognose für Deutschland. Es sieht nicht so toll aus erst einmal im nächsten Jahr, vielleicht besser. Aber er spricht auch über die Aufrüstung und sagt Folgendes.
Auch zum Teil über Kosten. Ja, klar. Man muss sich ganz klar machen, dass diese geopolitische Entwicklung, die wir haben, auch wenn jetzt das Wirtschaftswachstum anzieht, aber dass die einfach uns Wohlstand kosten wird. Weil einerseits geben wir mehr für Verteidigung aus und Verteidigungsausgaben sind nun mal, das ist verlorenes Geld in dem Sinne. Wenn wir eine Welt hätten, wo keiner Verteidigungsausgaben oder Rüstungsausgaben machen würde, dann ging es uns allen besser.
Verlorenes Geld, sagt er da. Das finde ich sehr interessant. Weiter sagt er über die Entglobalisierung, die droht.
Bestimmte Vorteile der Globalisierung, jetzt zurückdrehen, weil wir eben eigene Lieferketten haben möchten, die resilienter sind. Und in der Summe werden wir dadurch ärmer. Und insbesondere in einem Land wie Deutschland wird er dadurch ein bisschen ärmer, weil wir so stark auch auf die Globalisierung gesetzt hatten.
Diese ganze Rede von der resilienten Lieferkette bedeutet natürlich auch, dass das eine Lieferkette ist, die, um resilienter zu sein, teurer ist. Das heißt, das sind einfach zusätzliche Kosten, die aufkommen. Das wäre so, wenn man sagt, ich muss eigentlich immer noch diesen Weg von A nach B gehen, um meine Ware zu exportieren. Aber plötzlich ist dieser Weg dreimal so teuer geworden, weil der ja noch eine besondere Sicherheitsvorkehrung hat.
Ja, also die Verteidigungskosten, also das Argument pauschal ist richtig. Ich unterstütze das total. Ich halte es auch für eine große Geldverschwendung. Aber so, wie wir es jetzt in Deutschland konzipieren, dass der Verteidigungsbegriff auch so diese Katastrophenvorsorge und so weiter, also so zivile Einrichtungen. Und wir haben ja aus, du hast ja damals diese Bunker gespielt, dass da in Skandinavien die Bunker unterirdisch auch als Turnhallen genutzt werden. Also wir haben es durchaus mit Infrastruktur zu tun oder könnten es zu tun haben, die sich auch zivil nutzen lässt und auszahlt. Plus im Koalitionsvertrag wird ja sehr darauf abgestellt, dass das nicht nur Investitionen in Socken für Soldaten ist, sondern auch Technik. Und das israelische Modell, das ganz nah an die Universitäten ranrückt, ganz nah an diese Forschungsdinger und so weiter, da ist dann auch schon ein volkswirtschaftliches Win-Win drin, dass es ohne diesen Treiber, wir dort ja eine konkrete Landesverteidigung organisieren, wir brauchen also diese Art von Fortschritt und er lässt sich aber auch anders nutzen. Mal gucken, was da passiert.
Israelische Vorbild bedeutet aber, dass man wahnsinnig viel exportiert. Also Israel macht das ja nicht nur für sich, sondern man müsste dann sehr viel mehr Waffen exportieren.
Ja, aber wir sind ja auch auf Platz fünf.
Ja, ja, ja, nur man fragt sich, man müsste es sehr deutlich steigern, wenn man jetzt die Rüstungsausgaben verdoppelt, müsste man ja den Export mehr als verdoppeln, um das reinzubekommen. Und man fragt sich, an wen will man da eigentlich Waffen liefern? Also wir können ja jetzt schlecht sagen, wir liefern in Russen Waffen.
Ja, genau, aber wir haben ja auch viel Dual Use Technik, also das Starlink.
Ja, okay, Starlink. Aber Panzer und all diese ganzen Sachen.
Deswegen ja, ich habe ja schon von Anfang an gesagt, seit drei Jahren, dass wir als Sehgewohnheit bei Kriegen wieder die Panzerschlacht sehen, ist ja total daneben.
Naja, man macht viel mit Drohnen jetzt, aber auch das sind keine Investitionen.
Das sieht man aber nicht ganz so in den Zahlen zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt, weil zum Beispiel, wenn wir mehr Panzer kaufen und mehr Soldaten in der Kaserne haben, per se ist das ja alles Bruttoinlandsprodukt. Das sind ja Staatsausgaben, das ist aber Bruttoinlandsprodukt, was eben den direkten Wohlstand nicht erhöhen.
Ja, das bedeutet also, BIP-Steigerung bedeutet ja nicht Wohlstandssteigerung. Das hat man ja im Zuge der Debatten um Klima und Investitionen schon gehabt. Und hier zeigt sich das natürlich in aller Deutlichkeit, dass das ja nicht unseren Wohlstand erhöht, aber das BIP möglicherweise erhöhen kann. Und dann kann man das als ein tolles Erfolgserlebnis feiern, ist aber keins.
Ja, deswegen, ich habe gestern Karlsruher auch wieder damit gescherzt, wir können natürlich jetzt immer größere Autos bauen, die wir in mehr Unfälle verwickeln. Das ist mehr BIP. Oder halt einfach alle Dienstleistungen, die in Familien so stattfindet, wird ins BIP eingerechnet, aber auch mehr. Da können wir locker von 4 auf 5 Billionen gehen im Jahr.
Ich meine, langfristig, wenn wir dauerhaft jetzt mehr Geld für Rüstung ausgeben wollen, wenn das die Entscheidung ist oder wir das für notwendig erachten, dann muss das von irgendjemandem bezahlt werden. Man kann natürlich sagen, im Moment können wir sowohl mehr Kredite aufnehmen für ein bisschen mehr Verteidigung und für mehr Investitionen. Das geht alles von der Schuldentragfähigkeit her. Aber am Ende hätte man ja vielleicht dann doch auch mehr für Investitionen machen können, weniger für Rüstung.
Das bedeutet, wenn jetzt stärker investiert wird in die Rüstung, dann ist das keine Investition. Man kann das jetzt mal kursfristig so machen und die Kapitalmärkte sind uns ja nicht böse. Gegenteil, Staatsanleihen sind beliebt. Wenn wir jetzt aber signalisieren, dass das auf Dauer so laufen soll, dass das über Schulden läuft, werden die Kapitalmärkte dann nicht mitspielen und sie werden Deutschland abstrafen dafür. Weil sie sagen, ihr mögt damit vielleicht noch günstig das BIP erhöhen. Aber das sind ja alles Dinge, die ihr produziert, die ihr im besten Fall gar nie einsetzen werdet. Im schlechtesten Fall gibt es einen Krieg. Es gibt ja eigentlich nur diese beiden Optionen und ein bisschen kann man noch exportieren. Und da sind wir dann schon an einem Punkt, wo also die Überschuldung ein Problem werden kann und wo uns auch eine MMT nicht mehr hilft.
Es sei denn, man sieht diese Aufrüstung nur als ein Baustein in der neuen hegemonialen Weltpolitik, in der man die benutzt, um handelsfähige Wege freizuschießen und gleichzeitig noch den Euro anstelle des Dollar als neue Reservewährung installiert. Diese eine Pointe, die kann ich ja mal wegziehen, weil die auch aus meinem Kopf nicht mehr rausgeht. Dieser Chief Economic Advisor steht einfach im weißen Haushalt zu einer Rede und sagt dann, das Bild ist ja ganz klar, wir haben auf der Welt sehr gute wirtschaftliche Beziehung zwischen Brasilien und China. Wie ist das eigentlich möglich? Und dann erklärt er, die einen zahlen das Geld an die anderen. Welches Geld? Dollar. Die Brasilianer trauen den Chinesen nicht über den Weg, die nicht den. Also sagen sie einfach neutraler Grund im Boden, wir nehmen den Dollar. So, die Ware ist bezahlt, jetzt muss sie transportiert werden. Was macht Amerika? Schießt den Suezkanal frei. Ja, bombt die Huttis zurück in die Steinzeit, damit im Suezkanal der Container einfach durch transportiert werden kann. Das heißt, wenn man diese grandiose Verschuldung macht, noch schafft das Europa nicht. Aber Amerika hat das eben geschafft, indem sie gesagt haben, naja, aber die ganze Welt ist ja darauf angewiesen, dass wir so verschuldet sind, weil wir eben diese zwei großen Dienstleistungen, eine Währung, auf die sich alle einigen können und freigeschossene Seewege zur Verfügung stellen. Und dann kann man so eine Verschuldung machen.
Genau, aber du knuckst ja jetzt nicht ernsthaft und wünscht es dir nicht, dass Europa zu einem Imperium wird, dass jetzt in dieser Weise imperialistisch dann wirklich die Welt sich strukturiert.
Es ist eben, dass die Chinesen sagen, sorry Amerika, wir können unsere Seewege selber freischießen. Dann wird die Verschuldung Amerikas plötzlich ein Problem, weil sie nicht mehr gerechtfertigt ist.
Aber dass Europa jetzt an die Stelle von Amerika gesetzt wird, davon gehst du ja nicht aus. Na ja, aber entschuldigung mal. Guck dich mal bitte unsere Volkswirtschaften an.
Ja, aber du hast ja Lage der Nation gehört. Irgendwer wird die Huttis in der Steinzeit zurückbomben wollen.
Das sind die Großmachs-Fantasien von verrückten Europäern. Jaja, nur glaube ich, dass das auch dauert, sich auszahlt. Jaja, es beginnt immer mit einer Fantasie. Das ist ja, deswegen spiele ich diese Clips hier oben nochmal eindeutig zu wahren. So einfacher ist das nicht. So, wir nehmen mal mehr Schulden auf und so. Und zur Not bomben wir uns alles frei. Hier nochmal, Du Lin?
Genau, das ist der Punkt, wenn man die jetzt wirklich tatsächlich auf einem Niveau von drei, dreieinhalb Prozent des Bruttoinlandsproduktes hochziehen wollen würde und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob wir das brauchen oder wollen oder wie auch immer, das ist jetzt eine rein makroökonomische Aussage, dann wird das nicht einfach durch mehr Verschuldung funktionieren, sondern dann muss man sich fragen, wer das am Ende bezahlt.
Ja, Du Lin sagt dann, man könnte ja die Reichen besteuern, aber da wissen wir ja alle, ha ha ha, das wird nicht passieren, sondern das wird irgendwie anders passieren. Und ich hörte dann einen Bericht von, ich glaube ARD war das, in dem Kiesewetter zu Wort kam und der macht da schon eine interessante Verbindung. Also einmal Thema Urlaubstage und Thema Flugzeugträger. Wie passt das zusammen? Und wir haben jetzt noch Du Lin im Kopf.
Du, der Flugzeugträger.
Nein, wir haben jetzt noch Du Lin im Kopf, der sagt, ja, das muss dann schon irgendwie bezahlt werden.
Wir sagen uns auch sehr deutlich, in Amerika haben die Arbeiter im Schnitt zwölf Tage Urlaub, bei uns 30. Die Amerikaner finanzieren elf Flugzeugträger, die Europäer haben, glaube ich, die Franzosen ein und die Briten ein. Also es sind gar keine Relationen. Die Amerikaner erwarten von uns deutlich mehr Engagement.
Wie geht das zusammen? Also was er uns da eigentlich sagt ist, wenn wir jetzt auf Urlaubstage verzichten würden, und das war ja auch wieder bei linksliberalen Journalisten wie Bernd Ulrich schon zu lesen, wir müssen Feiertage opfern, dann, wenn wir also mehr arbeiten, dann steigern wir tatsächlich unseren Wohlstand, mit dem wir dann mehr Flugzeugträger finanzieren können. Das heißt also, die Aufrüstung, die hier vorgeschlagen wird, findet natürlich auf dem Rücken der arbeitenden Bevölkerung statt. Die soll nämlich die zusätzliche Verschuldung irgendwie wieder reinarbeiten, damit die Kapitalmärkte sehen, ah, okay, die rüsten nicht nur auf, sondern die arbeiten jetzt auch mehr. Die Ausbeutung nimmt also zu, dann können wir beruhigt sein, da müssen wir auch nicht höhere Zinsen auf europäische Staatsanleihen verlangen.
Also den Kiesewetter kann man jetzt ganz einfach auskontern, mit der Erfahrung dieser Woche, indem man irgendwie sagt, ja ja, Herr Kiesewetter, Sie haben recht, die Amerikaner sagen seit 20 Jahren, wir sollen mehr für uns die Verteidigung zahlen. Nur, das wollen die Amerikaner nicht wirklich, denn eine militärische Hoheit zu behalten, ist denen schon ganz wichtig. Die gehen ja auch nicht nach China und sagen, könnt ihr bitte mal zehn Flugzeugträger kaufen.
Ja.
So, was die Amerikaner eigentlich wollen, ist selber diese Flugzeugträger kaufen, betreiben und so weiter, egal was es kostet. Aber dafür, liebe Europäer, akzeptiert ihr bitte diesen Zoll. Der ist nämlich reziprog von Amerika ausgedacht. Nicht die Vergeltung, dass wir Gegenzölle machen, ist reziprog auf Augenhöhe, sondern die Amerikaner fühlen sich bisher verkauft. Sie kriegen alles, was wir liefern umsonst und dann deindustrialisieren sie uns noch. Deswegen diese Zölle, die von vornherein als reziprog, das ist jetzt das Preisschild für, wir haben diese Flugzeugträger. Und da könnte man Kiesewetter jetzt fragen, Herr Kiesewetter, wenn ihnen diese Partnerschaft mit Amerika so wichtig ist und die Verteidigung und so weiter, dass sie hier so westlicher Hegemon bleiben, dann müssen sie diesen Zoll akzeptieren. Aber was wir gesehen haben, ist, dass die Europäer, die Chinesen haben es natürlich sehr clever gemacht. Das war sozusagen ein Gegenschlag wie bei der Atomwaffe. Es wird registriert, sie ist oben, zack, Gegenzolle hoch. Also wurde nicht mal intern darüber geredet. Die Europäer haben noch fünf Tage gebraucht, bis sie gesagt haben, okay, wir machen das auch. Dann haben sie ausgesetzt und die Europäer so, wir setzen sie für 90 Tage aus. Also wenn Kiesewetter einen Beitrag leisten möchte, der den Amerikanern total entgegenkommt, dann sagt er von allein, bitte nicht Gegenzolle machen, sondern den Preisaufschlag Amerikas jetzt akzeptieren. Dann wird er aber nicht bereit.
Geschehen wird, das glauben wir eher mal nicht. Jetzt sag noch kurz, ich hatte bei Instagram gesehen, dass du im Schauspielhaus warst. Wir gehen ja immer nur in die Oper. Wir waren einmal im Schauspielhaus und sind dann gegangen, waren ganz erzürnt, das ist doch nicht Shakespeare. Du hast dir einen Klassiker vorgenommen, Faust. Wie war es?
Ich hatte keinen Ansinn, noch mal ins Theater zu gehen. Ich wollte ihm eigentlich keine Chance geben. Dann war ich ja in Hamburg in diesem The Circle und es war spektakulär. Also habe ich gedacht, und zwar auch spektakulär, weil es quasi fast ohne Kulisse, nur Text und so. Und die Textgrundlage von Dave Eggers ist ja gut, sehr gut. Zehn Jahre alt, also auch gut abgehangen. Die Realität hat sie eingeholt. Also es war sozusagen ein perfektes Theater. Also habe ich mir gedacht, Faust läuft. Ich habe Faust noch nie im Theater gesehen. Ich kenne natürlich Gründkönig bei YouTube und so, aber ich wollte es sehen. Ich wollte es vor allem hören. Und ich dachte, die werden doch wohl jetzt nicht bei Goethe für Lefantz machen, oder? Die können doch mal wie in der Oper, teksttreue, musiktreue die Inszenierung spielt woanders und so weiter. Also gehe ich ins Theater. Faust 1 und 2. So, Faust 1.
Wie lange sollte das dann gehen?
Vier und halb Stunden. Vier und halb Stunden. Faust 1 wurde in 25 Minuten abgehandelt. Das Best of der Zitate, einfach durchgenudelt. Keine Zuordnung von Sprecher und Schauspieler, sondern irgendwer hat irgendwas gesagt. Das Ding wurde hauptsächlich hinter der Kulisse in so einer Geisterbahn aufgeführt. Man war also nur über Video beteiligt. Und nach 25 Minuten hieß es Pause. Wir so, ja mir ist noch nicht so nach Pause. Ich kann hier sitzen bleiben. Plötzlich, bitte verlassen sie alle den Saal. Also mussten wir alle raus. Ich habe schon gedacht. Nee, das war jetzt Faust 1. Ich wollte eigentlich wirklich mal alles sehen. Und ich kann es nicht akzeptieren, dass zum Beispiel der Gott und Mephisto am Anfang in Personalunion gesprochen wird. Also das ein Schauspiel auf der Bühne ist der beides Spiel. Das geht nicht. Also das ist nicht die Idee. Die Idee war der große Gott mit seinen Engeln und unten der kleine Mephisto, der versucht da so ein bisschen mitzuspielen. Aber das kann man nicht in Personalunion machen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht. So, okay, Pause. Dann Faust 2 in zwei Teilen. Den ersten Teil habe ich gesehen, dann bin ich rausgegangen. Faust 2 beginnt damit, dass man in Reihe 3, also ich in Reihe 3, vor einer riesigen Leinwand, die ganze Bühnenfront war mit einer Leinwand zugehangen, wie so ein Bett lagen, auf dem in voller Größe ein Film projiziert wurde für eine Viertelstunde oder so. Dieser Film spielte mit den Schauspielern vor dem Theater auf dem Willy-Brandt-Platz an der Bahnhaltestelle.
Kriegt toll.
Noch mit Fischauge gefilmt. Und ich saß unten rechts in der Ecke, Platz 33 oder so. Also ich habe Kopfschmerzen gekriegt. Und ich dachte auch, ich bin ja nicht im Kino. Ich wollte Theater, ich wollte Text und so weiter. Dass das Wort Ficken, Arschloch und Frankfurt in dem Goethe vorkommen soll, keine Ahnung. Das alles totaler Schrott. Dass dann außerhalb des Ersemblemitglieds plötzlich nackt über die Bühne rennen muss. Standard bei voller Beleuchtung. Dass Faust von eigentlich niemandem gespielt wird, sondern so eine Puppe darstellt mit relativ wenig Text. Und wenn Text irgendeinen Schauspieler klemmt gerade hinter der Puppe und spricht in diesen Styroporkopf rein, man versteht nichts. Es wird andauernd rumgebrüllt. Helena ist plötzlich gar kein antikes Mysterium mehr, sondern ein Roboter an Seiburg. Also die Liste wäre unendlich weiter zu viel. Es war nicht zu vertragen. Wirklich nicht zu vertragen. Also ich hätte alles vertragen, wenn die Text treuer geblieben wäre. Aber es war so schlimm. So, dann gehen wir raus. Und zeitgleich läuft die letzte Vorführung Le Postillon, Dingster Bums. Wir gehen also aus dem Theater raus und hören Monika. Wird ja immer nach draußen übertragen.
Man muss sagen, das ist eine Sängerin aus dem Ensemble.
Monika Bumkopka, die beste Sängerin der Welt. Also das ist wirklich die Beste. So, wir gehen also aus dem Theater raus, stehen vor diesem blechernen Lautsprecher der Oper und lassen noch eine Band fahren, weil es gerade so schön ist. Ja, so das ist meine Schauspielerlebnis jetzt wieder gewesen. Und ich möchte eine Zäsur markieren, denn ich habe ja auch Adolescence gesehen. Und in diesem Monat hat das Fernsehen das Theater überholt. Ja, also was Wahrhaftigkeit und überhaupt angeht und so, kriegt man im Fernsehen mehr geboten. Wir sagen ja immer, wir gehen in die Oper, weil dort Medien unvermittelt der Ton, wie aus den Instrumenten kommt, da wird in den Saal reingesungen, ohne Mikrofon und so weiter und so fort. Also Adolescence kam näher ran als Faust. Also dieser Faust hier in Frankreich. Wirklich beeindruckend, muss man sagen.
Wir bleiben bei der Kultur, nämlich wir sprechen jetzt im Salon über ein hochinteressantes Buch über Spotify. Sehr viele, die uns hier hören, hören uns über Spotify. Die meisten Leute hören Musik über Spotify. Und generell ist die Spotifyisierung, wenn man es mal so sagen möchte, weit fortgeschritten. Also auch die, die nicht bei Spotify sind, sind die ganze Zeit von Spotify in irgendeiner Weise doch beherrscht. Denn Spotify hat die Musik verändert. Und jetzt haben natürlich alle schon mal gehört, ja, da wird ja mit Algorithmen, mit Daten und so weiter gearbeitet. Hier gehen wir einmal ganz tief rein, wie weitreichend das ist. Es hat mich schockiert, muss ich sagen. Ich hätte es nicht gedacht, auch wenn ich schon vieles angenommen habe. Aber das ist doch noch mal eine Dimension, die mir so nicht klar war. Das Buch heißt Mood Machine, The Rise of Spotify and the Cost of the Perfect Playlist von Liz Pelly. Sie hat sich zehn Jahre lang mit Spotify auseinandergesetzt. Und das Resultat ist jetzt dieses Buch, über das wir sprechen werden.
Ja, es ist so. Das Buch arbeitet auch ein bisschen gegen mich, denn diese Playlist, ist mir aufgefallen, ja. Ich habe nur eine Playlist. Und das ist die von Liedern, die ich selbst zusammengestellt habe. Und ich fange eigentlich immer nur die ersten zehn anzuhören. Und das ist dann so eine Dauerschleife. Und dann kommt alle drei Monate mal eins dazu, so ungefähr. Aber ich scheine da nicht Hauptlastträger des Erfolgs von Spotify zu sein, sondern die Leute hören anders. Find ich ganz erstaunlich. Wir haben ein ganz tolles Kapitel am Ende über die Bibliotheken. Das hätte ich gerne früher gehabt, wie auch immer. Also wirklich sehr beeindruckend. Und wir haben wieder mit einem Thema hier zu tun, bei dem man sich jetzt fragt, aber ist nicht gerade Zoll und Trump und Koalitionsvertrag? Wieso reden die jetzt im Salon zwei Stunden über Spotify? Und ich möchte jeden, der diesen Podcast jetzt hört, noch mal dran erinnern, an das eigene Nutzungsverhalten. Selbst in der höchsten, krassesten Nachrichtenlage, in der wir hören, irgendwelche Milliardäre haben durch Insider-Trading 10 Billionen Dollar verdient oder sowas. Also zwei Corona-Lockdowns innerhalb von fünf Minuten eingecashed einfach. Ein Koalitionsvertrag ist fertig, ein neuer Kanzler wird gewählt. Selbst an solchen Nachrichtentagen verbringen wir mehr Zeit mit Musik und Spotify als mit Nachrichtenkonsum. Das ist meine Vermutung. Bei mir ist es auf jeden Fall so. Ich höre immer eine Stunde mehr Musik am Tag wahrscheinlich als irgendwelche Podcasts und so. Wo ich sehr viel Podcasts höre, aber dann hört man, wie viel Musik ich höre.
Wir sagten, das ist nicht mein Vibe oder der sagt, ich bin gerade irgendwie in einem anderen Mood und und und ist schon von Spotify beeinflusst. Also der Vibe ist ein Begriff, der von Spotify stark gemacht wird, nämlich wenn es um diese Playlisten geht. Also das heißt, alles, was uns eigentlich so durchdringt, ist permanent da mit Spotify, mit Netflix. Da kann man auch einige Parallelen natürlich ziehen. Also man erfährt sehr viel über die Kulturindustrie heute und wir etappen uns eben genau dabei, dass wir ja auch plötzlich merken, ach ja, das war so ein Sound, der ist mir damals aufgefallen. Der hat mir auch eigentlich gefallen, aber wo kommt das dann her? Also was hat dazu geführt, dass dieser Sound produziert wurde? Und das können wir hier sehen. Und das geht dann auch bis hin zu Künstlern wie Billie Eilish, wo ja auch immer so das Märchen erzählt wird, die sich da mit ihrem Bruder zusammengeschlossen hat, um ganz andere Musik zu machen. Und plötzlich merkt man, wie plattformgetrieben das alles war. Also wirklich ein Buch, über das wir jetzt ausführlich diskutieren müssen. Des Weiteren stelle ich vor, den neuen Roman von Christian Kracht, Air. Das ist ja ein Autor, an dem man, wenn man sich mit deutscher Literatur oder Gegenwart beschäftigt, nicht vorbeikommt. Der hat gar kein Name drauf? Doch, doch.
Hat der kein Name?
Doch, Christian Kracht, Air.
Ach, Air.
Wir müssen auch schon klären, was überhaupt mit diesem Titel gemeint ist. Dann hat Thomas Wagner ein Buch vorgelegt, das trägt den Titel Abenteuer der Moderne, die großen Jahre der Soziologie. Was ist das? Welche Zeitraub ist da gemeint? 1949 bis 1969. Also, um das deutlich zu sagen, vor Luhmann. Die Luhmann-Zeit beginnt danach. Ich kann dir sagen, Luhmann kommt auch noch kurz vor. Werde dir eine schöne Anekdote vorlegen. Hier geht es aber um eigentlich zwei Antipoten, nämlich Arnold Gehlen und Theodor W. Adorno. Und wie diese schwierige Beziehung dann zu einer freundschaftlichen Beziehung wird. Und es ist zugleich auch die Geschichte der Soziologie und der jungen Bundesrepublik. Ein ganz, ganz erstaunliches Buch. Dann dein großes Thema, wir brauchen Atombomben. Nein, sagt Olaf M. Müller, ein Philosoph der analytischen Schule. Er hat ein Buch geschrieben, Atomkrieg, eine Warnung, dass ich vorstellen werde.
Ich bin ja nicht für Atomkrieg, ich bin nur für Atomwaffen.
Genau, Stefan will einen Atomkrieg. Nein, das wollen wir natürlich nicht. Dann, du bist ein Freund von Smart-Homes, du würdest am liebsten alles mit dem Smartphone speuern. Die Superreichen sagen jetzt nein, lieber nicht. Werd ich einen Artikel vorstellen.
Haben wir schon jemals gesagt, dass die Superreichen gute Ideen haben, ihr Leben so führen, wie man's leben sollte? Nein.
Und dann zum Schluss noch ein Musiktipp, Fatma Said, eine großartige Supranistin.
Sehr gut gesungen. Sehr, werde ich natürlich folgen, diese Empfehlung dann. Trumps Zollpolitik, also wir lesen mehrere Sachen. Steven Myron, der neue CEA, hat eine Rede gehalten am 7. April, also genau zur richtigen Zeit. Janos Varoufakis hat diesen Maralago-Akkord eingeschätzt und in der Zeit tauchten zwei Texte von Heike Buchneiste, glaube ich, auf, die nochmal so Willkür-Fragezeichen, ist das wirklich oder gibt es da eigentlich einen Plan und so. Und danach machen wir was ganz Interessantes. Humann, unser Kumpel Humann, hat ein Instagram-Post gemacht über eine Hartebaffersendung. Aha. Und das war der bei ihm erfolgreichste Instagram, äh, LinkedIn-Post bislang, mit 45.000 Impressions und 400 Reaktionen. Und er hat mithilfe von KI eine Auswertung der Argumente, die dort, und da ich ja auch sehr viel Fernsehen gucke und im Podcast darüber rede, dachte ich mir, das ist ein interessanter Workflow. Vielleicht lässt sich die KI-Hilfe, die man da hat, noch nicht zu verwechseln mit Automatisierung, denn man muss relativ viel zusammenbrumpten und arbeiten, doch nochmal so automatisieren, dass wir dem erfolgreichsten journalistischen Genre, das wir haben, nämlich die Nachtkritik, also nachts wird geschrieben, was bei Karamioska gesagt wird, damit die Leute, die es gesehen haben, nochmal sich rückversichern, was habe ich da gestern eigentlich gesehen, und die, die es nicht gesehen haben, nachlesen, was sie verpasst haben, und es hat dann immer 100.000 Klicks und so. Das könnte man ja mal automatisieren. Also nehmen wir uns dieses Beispiel. Dann, wie angekündigt, die Zeit hat diesen Text über höhere Geschwindigkeit beim Konsum von Inhalten aller Art, auch Vorlesungen und so. Ah ja. Und am Ende trage ich dir, also diejenigen, die uns das jetzt hören, sehen natürlich schon in der Liste, um wen es hier geht, aber ich trage dir Zitate aus einem Buch vor und du sagst mir dann, ob dich das interessieren würde. Du bist ja ein großer Marx-Fan. Ich bin ja jetzt nicht unbedingt ein zentraler Marx-Fan, aber ich finde es ja auch alles ganz gut. Und lässt sich Marx eigentlich noch mal in die Gegenwart holen, um mal so richtig ein politisches Sachbuch und so weiter. Und da bin ich gespannt, wie die Reaktionen dann ausfallen.
Ich bin auch gespannt.
Und dann sage ich dir, wer es geschrieben hat und so. Das ist jetzt nicht so. Also es sind keine Marx-Zitate, sondern es sind Zitate aus einem Buch von einer Hardcore-Marxistin, von der ich großer Fan bin. Und in dem Fall glaube ich, so sollte man das anwenden. Und deswegen lassen wir zuerst die Inhalte gewähren und sagen danach, wer das gemacht hat. Sozusagen einfach eine Buchempfehlung über Bande.
Wunderbar. Dann freuen wir uns, über Spotify zu diskutieren. Ich habe ja gar keinen Spotify.
Oh, das diskutieren wir gleich aus.
Also, bis gleich.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du hast keinen Spotify-Account.
Nein, braucht man doch nicht. Ich hab CDs.
Wie funktioniert das? Also du hast spontan eine Musikempfehlung bekommen. Du gibst ja gerne Musikempfehlung. Kriegst du auch Musikempfehlung?
Ja.
Was machst du dann?
Dann bestelle ich mir entweder sofort die CD oder ich gehe zu YouTube und höre mir das da mal an und sag mir, ja, das wäre etwas. Und hin und wieder höre ich irgendeinen Schlager, den ich jetzt nicht auf CD brauche, bei YouTube. Aber ich höre ja fast nur klassische Musik. Von daher ist jetzt meine Lust auch nicht so groß, da irgendwelche Bands rauf und runter zu entdecken, sondern ich höre mir eine neue Einspielung von zum Beispiel Liedern an. Und dann denke ich bei YouTube, das klingt sehr gut. Das möchte ich jetzt auf meiner richtigen Stereoanlage hören. Dann bestelle ich mir die CD und freue mich dann, wenn sie in zwei Tagen da ist.
Okay, da kann ich mir gar nicht darüber reden, aber ich will es kurz anmerken, weil ich es interessant finde. Spotify ist ja nicht alternativlos, Amazon und Apple haben ja auch solche Angebote. Und Apple kam vor ein, zwei Jahren auf diese Idee, sie lagern klassische Musik aus, weil man ein anderes User-Interface braucht. Also man macht die App auf, und dann sind da erst mal Instrumente aufgeführt und so, und man kann halt darüber dann reingehen. Das finde ich hochinteressant, weil man gezielt auf Entdeckungsreise gehen kann und weiß, hier kriegt man jetzt nur echte Musik. Also ganz viel von dem, was Liz Pelly aufgeschrieben hat, droht da gar nicht, weil es einfach diese synthetische KI-Seite gar nicht geben kann.
Richtig.
Also alles, was in dieser App passiert bei Apple, ist sozusagen handgemachte Musik, die halt mikrofoniert wurde, aber sonst nichts. Und das ist jetzt ein neues Bollwerk, wie wir gelernt haben.
Ich finde auch, denn das ist das Interessante, klassische Musik kommt an keiner Stelle des Buchs vor.
Podcasts auch nur in einem Satz?
Ja, das ist okay, denn sie will sich ja mit Musik auseinandersetzen. Ich finde auch interessant, dass klassische Musik nicht vorkommt. Es soll kein Vorwurf sein an Liz Pelly, sondern beschreibt genau das, was du jetzt gerade gesagt hast. Das ist das Bollwerk gegen diese, ja, wie könnte man das nennen, Homogenisierung von Musik, die Anpassung der Musik an Playlists, an KI-Optimierung und so weiter. Und ich würde, wenn ich dann doch irgendwann mal ein bisschen von der CD abrücken würde, mir auf jeden Fall so einen Spezialdienst nehmen für klassische Musik, wo das dann auch nochmal in besserer Qualität kommt. Und es ist tatsächlich so, ich habe es auch schon bei Freunden natürlich erlebt bei Spotify, dass es schwierig oft zu suchen ist, klassische Musik. Also wenn ich jetzt hier klar eine Sängerin empfehle, mit ihrem neuen Album, findet man das. Aber wenn man doch so ein bisschen tiefer reingehen will, vielleicht verschiedene Einspielungen vergleichen will oder sowas, dann ist eigentlich diese So-Funktion bei Spotify nicht so optimal, wie das bei anderen Klassikanbietern der Fall ist. Was ist das eigentlich für ein Buch? Es ist ja eins, das nicht nur journalistisch ist, sondern wirklich so eine tiefe Recherche ist. Man würde ja fast von der akademischen Arbeit zum Teil sprechen, ja?
Ja, oder man über die andere Richtung, so wie man bei uns schon feststellt. Man hat so einen gewissen Leidenschaftsanteil, weil es geht ja um Musik, die soll einem gefallen. Also folgt man einer Sache, die einem gefällt. Anders als beim Nachrichtenkonsum, wo man mehr so in die Richtung sich einfach darüber informiert. Was Schreckliches droht, möchte man bei Spotify gerne unterhalten werden. Und sie ist ja auch so leidenschaftsgetrieben. Also sie beginnt ja gleich am Anfang, nach einem Jahrzehnt als freie Musikjournalistin, angebunden an einen Do-it-yourself-Musikclub da in Brooklyn, da hat sie halt erstmals über Spotify geschrieben und dann gab es halt gleich so emotionale Resonanz. Jeder Labelchefs, Anti-Industrie-Punks hatte was dazu zu sagen und dann ist sie einfach bei dem Thema geblieben. Und das Buch ist sozusagen mündet einfach. Es ist so eine Art Lebensabschnittsthema, das sie jetzt mal so zusammengebunden hat. Es ist ja auch so, mein Eindruck war jedenfalls, man liest so dieses Buch und es will einfach nicht enden. Es kommt immer noch mal hier und da und so. Also man kriegt eine sehr tiefen scharfe Analyse von dem, was uns den Tag etwas schöner machen soll. Musik über den primären Dienst, über den wir dann ansteuern, Spotify.
Und interessanterweise taucht im Titel das Wort Musik nicht auf. Da steht Mood Machine, The Rise of Spotify and the Cost of the Perfect Playlist. Das bedeutet also, dass die Musik vielleicht gar nicht im Vordergrund steht, sondern die Stimmung, die erzeugt wird, und zwar maschinell. Das ist also die große These dieses Buchs. Es geht weniger um die Musik, die stand nämlich bei der Gründung von Spotify gar nicht im Mittelpunkt. Die Gründer, Daniel Eck und Laurenzen, sind Leute gewesen, die wollten eine Plattform für Werbeoptimierung kreieren. Die waren aus dem Advertisement-Business und überlegten, wie kann man dieses größer machen, wie kann man das skalieren. Die Musik bot ihnen nur eine Möglichkeit, die nahezu perfekt für sie war, da die Musik ja in der Zeit in eine Krise geraten ist bzw. die Musikindustrie. Man hatte diese ganzen Piratenseiten, auf denen kostenlos Alben hochgeladen wurden. Das war zwar illegal oder an manchen Ländern auch nur halb illegal, aber das sorgte für enorme Einnahmenverluste. Zugleich hatte man dann schon so Ideen, dass man eben einzelne Lieder im Netz kaufen kann. Aber noch besser wäre es ja wirklich, wenn man so einen Anbieter hätte, wo man alles hören kann für einen bestimmten Betrag. Und der Launch in Europa war dann 2008, um diese Kennzahl mal kurz zu nennen. 2011 wurde Spotify in den USA erfolgreich rausgebracht. Und dann kam es 2018 zum IPO. Und jetzt beschäftigt sich Liz Pelly mit diesem Unternehmen nicht in der Form, dass sie jetzt sagt, wie so Daniel Egg ist und lebt. Und was er macht, sondern es geht vor allem darum, wie verändert sich die Plattform über die Jahre hinweg. Denn zunächst einmal versucht man eben diese Labels davon zu überzeugen, dass sie auf Spotify stattfinden müssen. Und dann bleibt es aber nicht bei dieser einfachen Ansammlung von Musik. Und jeder kann sich dann da was zurecht suchen, sondern sehr bald merkt man, man muss diese Musik auch kuratieren. Und dann sind wir sehr schnell bei dem Thema Playlist angekommen.
Genau. Und sie schreibt es aber so, dass es auch eine persönliche Geschichte für jeden von uns ist. Also ich kann mich jedenfalls an diese Zeit erinnern, denn du hast jetzt 2008 gesagt. 2008 war eben der europäische Start vor 2011, dem amerikanischen. Aber Spotify gab es ja schon 2006. Und diese zwei Jahre, 2006 bis 2008, beschreibt sie dann, nachdem sie 2016 erstmals über Spotify so schrieb, dass das ja ein faszinierendes Jahr war, um mal auf dieses Jahrzehnt zurückzuschauen. Denn Spotify ist eine der großen techgetriebenen Unternehmen aus Europa und nicht ohne Grund aus Schweden. Denn Schweden war dieser Ort, wo die Musik so ein bisschen anders verankert ist, durch diese öffentliche Förderung, die ja auch Avarok-Set und so weiter. Also wir hatten aus Schweden immer musikalische Exporte in die Welt und dann plötzlich Spotify. Aber Spotify, nicht getrieben von den Gründern, sondern von dem Publikum, das sie über Umwege, das sie eigentlich Werbung machen wollten, gefunden haben in Schweden. Denn Pirate Bay und so, das ist eben diese Zeit, Kaza, dieses Tauschbörsending, da war sozusagen Schweden der Ort, aus dem alles kam. The Pirate Bay, Peter Sunde, die dann einfach sagen, wir wollen freie Musik und frei, diskutiert sie dann so ein bisschen mit, was hat das mit gratis zu tun und so.
Die Piratenpartei.
Genau, die Piratenzeit später. Wichtig, aber nicht ganz so eng angebunden, wie man glaubt. Also es ist dann schon noch ein eigenes Ding. Und in diesem Jahrzehnt oder dieses Jahrzehnt, dass sie dann da so beobachtet, begann eben damit, dass wir auf der einen Seite dieses Major Label Oligopol hatten, Universal, Sony, Warner, die einfach 70 Prozent der ganzen Musik der Welt kontrollieren. Also eine totale Zentralisierung des Angebots. Und die Nachfrage war aber plötzlich so Internet, jeder mit jeden. Wir kaufen nicht zentral, wir teilen es uns gegenseitig, wir machen eine Software auf, wo erstmal Verbindung zu tausend anderen Computer hergestellt wird. Und dann sammelt man sich das Musikstück so zusammen. Also es war sozusagen aus beiden Richtungen Druck auf dem Kessel. Also weder die Oligopols hatten Zukunft noch dieses jeder tauscht ja mit jedem einfach Musik und es spielt gar keine Rolle, weil so kann man auch nichts herstellen. Und da platzierte sich Spotify und weder wollte man die Musik retten, noch wollte man Filesharing betreiben, sondern man wollte einfach nur, man brauchte Inhalte für seinen Dienst. Diese Web 2.0 Ära und so weiter, Blockosphäre, der ganze Kram. Das hat man einfach, das beschreibt sie sehr gut. Ich glaube, jeder, der das so liest und so in unserem Alter ist und damals vielleicht auch schon Computer hatte, weiß so, um was es hier geht. Also wir kriegen so eine schöne retrospective Geschichte aufgezählt.
Sie schreibt, die Geschichte von Spotify ist die Geschichte einer angeschlagenen Musikindustrie, die verzweifelt versucht, nach der Ära des digitalen Leasings weiter zu bestehen. Von Werbetechnologieführungskräften, die die Logik ihrer Branche auf neue Weise auf die Musik übertragen. Von einer bereits stark konsolidierten Branche, die immer stärker konsolidiert wird. Es ist die Geschichte der übereifrigen und opportunistischen Technologie-Lösungsanbieter des 21. Jahrhunderts, der Milliardäre und ihrer überhalbten Maschinen, die sich nach Problemen umsehen, die es zu lösen gilt und dabei die sozialen Probleme, die sie hinterlassen, arrogant ignorieren. Es ist eine Geschichte von Zuhörern, denen Musik eher als Gebrauchsgegenstand, denn als Kunstform verkauft wird und von Musikern, die sich selbst eher als Content-Ersteller, denn als Künstler sehen. Es ist eine Geschichte von Präkarität, Hyperkommerzialisierung, Individualismus und all dem, was unter dem Begriff Vibes verschleiert wird.
Genau. Und die Musik lief ja immer zweigleisig.
Ja.
Also wir haben diese große Oligopol. Alles, was so passiert, wird von diesen Labels aufgefressen. Wer einen Plattenvertrag hat, hat sozusagen ausgedient und kann das so als Schmuck auf seine Biografie kleben. Und dann diese freie Indie-Szene. Und eigentlich hat das gut funktioniert, bis plötzlich Spotify kam und es den Nutzer so angenehm gemacht hat. Die Indie-Musik wurde quasi aufgefressen. Und das ist noch lange bevor dann diese Algorithmisierung und Playlist und so weiter schreibt sie von dieser Ästhetik-Gelättung, dem Flattening in der Musik. Unabhängige Musik hatte historisch gesehen immer eigene Wirtschaftskreisläufe. Und ab jetzt nicht mehr. Denn jetzt musste man, also damals war halt die Hürde, habe ich jetzt einen Plattenvertrag oder nicht? Und wenn nicht, bin ich halt weiter Indie. Und heute ist einfach, ja klar bin ich auf Spotify. Also es gibt gar keine Hürde, sondern wir sind alle auf Spotify und wir konkurrieren mit irgendwelchen Algo-Kreationen und so weiter und so fort.
Und das bedeutet eigentlich ja erst mal und das ist ja, was sie dann auch später zitiert, die Möglichkeit wird viel größer entdeckt zu werden. Also für Indie-Musiker ist das doch eigentlich ein tolles Terrain. Früher musste man in Kulturfabriken auftreten, musste auf sich aufmerksam machen, hoffen, dass man noch 20 CDs danach verkauft. Und jetzt kann einen eigentlich die gesamte Welt hören. Und das ist auch ein Versprechen, das natürlich viele anzieht. Das Problem ist aber, du hast es jetzt gerade schon angedeutet, man konkurriert plötzlich mit ganz anderen Größen. Und hinzu kommt, dass Spotify ja eine bestimmte Form der Auszahlung hat. Nämlich, es ist ja so, dass jedes Spotify-Abo zu 70 Prozent an die Musikindustrie fließt, inklusive dann der rechte Inhaber an den Aufnahmen und an den Kompositionen. Und 30 Prozent behält Spotify ein. Es ist eigentlich so ein Apple-Deal, könnte man sagen. Apple behält ja auch mal 30 Prozent ein. Das Problem ist nun aber, es gibt also eine Summe von Geld, die zu verteilen ist, die aus diesen Abonnenten entsteht, die nun jetzt monatlich 10 oder 12 oder 14 Euro zahlen. Und die Sache ist aber die, dass natürlich diejenigen, die mehr gehört werden, wesentlich mehr ausgezahlt bekommen. Jetzt könnte man sagen, naja, aber das war ja früher auch so. Die einen haben eine Million CDs verkauft, die anderen nur 1000. Die Sache ist nun aber, dass wenn es so eine Pool-Lösung gibt, die, die kleiner sind, immer stärker abgewertet werden und es eine Zuspitzung gibt auf diese Big Player. Also wenn nun eben Hardcore-Fans laufend das eine Lied hören und hören und hören und jeder Stream wird bezahlt, dann bedeutet das natürlich, dass plötzlich allein die Quantität darüber entscheidet, wie viel Geld jemand verdient als Musiker. Während früher man eine CD gekauft hat und dann hatte man sie gekauft, egal wie oft sie gehört wurde dann. Und jetzt wird man sagen, na ja, aber das ist doch jetzt eigentlich ein faires System. Und ich sage nochmal ganz deutlich, ist es nicht. Ich empfehle ja heute hier eine CD. Die habe ich gekauft und die finde ich ausgesprochen gut. Und das werde ich nachher nochmal deutlich sagen. Aber ich kann jetzt garantieren, dass sich diese CD, vielleicht in diesem Jahr fünfmal, vielleicht wenn es gut wird, zehnmal hören werde. Das heißt, würde ich die über Spotify streamen, würde die Künstlerin wahnsinnig wenig Geld von mir bekommen. Die bekommt von mir dreieinhalb Cent. Ich mag die sehr, werde die weiterempfehlen. Aber ich höre nicht jeden Tag Schubert-Lieder und Mendelssohn-Lieder. Das ist Musik, die hört man nicht rauf und runter. Und viele Leute werden gute Alben jetzt gerade kennen, auch nicht aus der klassischen Musik von Frank Zappa oder wem auch immer. Und werden sagen, das ist ein herausragendes Album. Ich höre das nicht jeden Tag. Aber manche werden sagen, ich höre jeden Tag mal irgendwie so ein Song, irgendwas, Taylor Swift, Tina Turner, irgendein Schlager. Und da würde ich auch sagen, ja, ich höre wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Schlager oder irgendein Frank Sinatra-Lied viel häufiger. Ich habe das im Auto, spiele ich immer wieder ab. Ja, höre ich viel häufiger als die Schubert-Lieder eingesungen. Von Fatma Said. Das Problem ist nur jetzt, ich habe da mal eine CD, ich habe da mal eine CD. Wenn ich jetzt bei Spotify bin, dann ist jedes Mal, wenn ich My Way von Sinatra streame, geht das Geld dahin. Aber es geht nur einmal an Fatma Said, wenn ich einmal ihr Schubert-Lied ankriege. Und damit hat man schon ein fundamentales Ungleichgewicht, weil man plötzlich die Quantität über alles stellt und dann ist die Qualität eines Songs nicht mehr relevant und die Qualität eines Songs bedeutet ja auch oft, dass man ihn nicht so oft hört. Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen widersprüchlich, aber ich will einen, und dann schließe ich mit meinem langen Monolog, ich will ein Beispiel geben. Ich war in der Kölner Philharmonie am Montag und dort war das Kürzenich-Orchester und es gab das fünfte Klavierkonzert von Beethoven, gespielt von Elisabeth Leonz-Kaja. Sie hat das herausragend gemacht. Es war ein ganz, ganz großer Abend. Und ich muss sagen, das war so erschütternd gut, dass ich schon fast nicht mehr den zweiten Teil des Konzerts brauchte. Es gab dann noch eine Symphonie von Shostakovich, ich habe mir die dann auch angehört, das war auch toll. Aber man war eigentlich nach diesem Werk satt, weil man sagte, das war jetzt so ein großes Erlebnis, es reicht. Und das ist eben sehr oft bei sehr guter Musik, dass man nicht sagt, ich dudel die jetzt siebenmal am Tag, sondern man hört sie einmal und dann hört man sie vielleicht in ein, zwei Wochen wieder. Und genau das ist ein Problem, wenn man Künstler aus Spotify ist.
Ja, und da steigen wir jetzt hier ein in den Horror der Realität, denn du bist mal wieder die Orchidee und Spotify macht nicht für dich ein Angebot, sondern es funktioniert ja anders. Also früher war ja so, der angesprochene Plattenvertrag, und es war völlig klar, der ist für dich individuell. Und dann heißt es irgendwie 100 Millionen D-Mark für die nächsten fünf Alben in 20 Jahren oder so was. Und damit war klar, der Künstler hat jetzt frei, er kann einfach seine Musik machen, er wird bezahlt, ist schon bezahlt worden, wie auch immer. So, und diese Individualität des Vertrags, den gibt es bei Spotify auch. Während wir immer denken, naja, man springt halt die Hürde bei Spotify, und dann ist man einfach im Pool, und je nachdem wie gehört wird, aber nein, nicht nachdem wie gehört wird, sondern hat den Vertrag ein Major-Label aussatiert, ist man in so einem großen Katalog drin, profitiert man sowieso schon davon. Oder hat man sich da gerade so, ich habe nur mal abgeloadet und gesagt, ich stimme dem Partnervertrag zu, dann macht man noch ein zweites Häkchen bei, ich lasse mich gerne durch den Algorithmus bevorzugen, akzeptiere aber dadurch weniger Tantiem, weil ich bin ja dann künstlich mehr gespielt usw. Also alle Verträge sind individuell. Das fand ich auch erstaunlich. Und dann, und das ist dieser Horror, die zentrale Kennziffer bei Spotify ist Programmed Stream Share. Und zum einen gibt es aus dieser Zeit damals, also Pirate Bay und so 2006, diese Idee von, okay, alle Welt der Musik steht zur Verfügung. Ich mache diese Software auf, sage, suche etwas, dann kriege ich das angezeigt, ist verfügbar, dann klicke ich da drauf und dann sehe ich so, der Download beginnt zu rattern, ich stelle so 35 Computern in der Verbindung her und irgendwann ist es fertig und dann kann ich auf Play drücken. Und Spotify sagte sich, nee, wir wollen, dass du direkt auf Play drücken kannst, dass innerhalb der ersten Viertelsekunde das Ding einfach beginnt zu spielen. So. Und das habe ich gedacht, ja, das war damals auch an meiner Erinnerung der große Vorteil, für den man bereit ist, 10 Euro zu bezahlen. Weil bevor ich jetzt immer wissen muss, was ich höre und dann die Geduld erst mal runterladen und dann habe ich es lokal und dann kann ich es spielen. Das dauert mir zu lange, das ist zu umständlich. Ich bezahle eigentlich für Convenience. Die Verfügbarkeit habe ich schon. Ich bezahle eigentlich für Convenience. So, aber dabei ist es nicht geblieben, sondern Spotify sagte sich, nee, wir wollen, dass die Leute wirklich nur auf den Play-Button drücken und dann akzeptieren, was wir ihnen spielen. Ja.
Und dann entsteht die Playlist.
Genau.
Und in verschiedener Art und Weise dann.
Und das bedeutet aber, wir brauchen einen Hörer, dem es eigentlich ein bisschen egal ist. Der hat eigentlich gerade mit Kochen zu tun, der sitzt im Auto, wie auch immer. Da schaltet einfach das Radio an. Da fängt man auch nicht an, plötzlich da anzurufen, sich ein Lied zu wünschen oder so. Man hört halt, was gespielt wird. So, also wollen sie da nicht auffallen, also sie wollen den Ausschaltimpuls sozusagen ausmerzen. Und darüber kam und dann eben für die ganze Musikbranche, dieses Flattening rein, dieses bloß nicht auffallen, bloß keine Besonderheiten, bloß nichts, dass das Gehirn, also das Bewusstsein aktiviert mit, gefällt mir das eigentlich gerade, was ich höre, was war denn das? So, sondern nein, es soll so ganz ruhig durchspielen. Und das zieht ja wohl durch die ganze Spotify-Geschichte in einem Ausmaß, wie ich es auch unterschätzt habe, ehrlich gesagt. Und ich sehe ja, wie meine Töchter Spotify benutzen bei uns im Familien-Account. Also fünf Leute hören für 15 Euro alle Musik der Welt. Da kann Spotify sich natürlich austoben, weil der Preis ist so no-brainer, dass die Erwartung von Spotify, ja, wir wollen, dass alles hier no-brainer ist. Das Gehirn bitte ausschalten. Ja, und jetzt haben wir diese zweigeteilte Welt, in der wir Spotify haben für alles und dann wirklich nur noch Konzertbesuche. Also Zeit, Geld muss investiert werden. Man wirft sich in eine Klamotte, man fährt dahin, man setzt sich dahin und so weiter. Und dazwischen ist aber kaum noch was. Also bis zum Parkhaus hörst du quasi Spotify, dann gehst du in das Konzert und danach ist wieder Spotify.
Und wenn du in einem Pop-Konzert bist, dann hörst du Musik, die angepasst ist an Spotify. Das kommt ja auch hinzu. Also das ist ja das Interessante, dass die Musik verändert wird, genauso wie du es jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, dass man nicht mehr auffällt. Ich habe mich ja lange Zeit gewundert, wo sind eigentlich die Ohrwürmer hin? Die Melodien, die man sofort mitsingen kann. Ich habe mich gewundert, warum kann das keiner mehr komponieren? Wahrscheinlich können das noch Leute komponieren, aber ich habe heute eine Antwort bekommen mit diesem Buch. Ja, das ist jetzt gar nicht gewollt, weil der Ohrwurm dich natürlich auch sehr daran erinnert, dass du gerade Musik hörst. Wenn das aber einfach so smooth ist, ein Begriff, der sehr häufig hier fällt, wenn das einfach so smooth durchgeht, wenn einfach auf einen Song der nächste folgt und noch wieder einer und wieder einer und das alles irgendwie so klingt wie so eine Komfortzone, dann brauche ich nicht mehr oder darf ich nicht mehr eine solche Melodie haben, die herausragt. Ich kann jetzt nicht, um mal was aus dem Schlagerbereich zu bringen, nicht sowas wie Katja Epstein, Wunder gibt es immer wieder haben, wo das Orchester groß einsetzt und dann Wunder gibt es noch mal eine Steigerung, dann wird es wieder leise. Das erinnert uns viel zu sehr daran, dass es wirklich sich um Musik handelt. Und wir könnten vielleicht auf die Idee kommen, aufzuhören, jetzt gerade Musik zu hören und was anderes zu tun. Nein, es soll einfach als Dauerberiesung weitergehen. Und sie beschreibt ja dann mit Mood Machine so wunderbar auch, es geht darum, dass es wirklich so eine Maschinizierung von Musikproduktion wird und auch eine Maschinizierung von Gefühlen. Denn was ja stattfindet ist, dass Spotify dazu übergeht, Mikro-Genres zu erstellen. Im Übrigen kann man das auch nachlesen. Ich habe das Buch mal vor langer Zeit im Salon von Amanda Lotz über Netflix, dass Netflix auch so Mikro-Genres hat. Dass da dann irgendwie steht, also die intern auch solche Mikro-Genres noch mal haben. Für Geschiedene mit zwei Kindern plus Urlaubssensucht. Und man erzählt, was soll denn das sein? Und dann kommt man an irgendeine Serie. Schußt dann die einen zu, weil sie erkannt haben, dass es so ein Muster gibt. Und im Prinzip gibt es jetzt auch solche Mikro-Genres bei Spotify, dass das also Lieder sind für ein etwas Loneliness, aber auch das Gefühl von Omas zu Hause, Grandmas Home wird eine Playlist. Also man hat plötzlich tausende Mikro-Genres und dort soll jeder seine Komfortzone bekommen. Und das wird dann häufig auch noch angereichert mit so einem therapeutischen oder sagen wir lieber pseudotherapeutischen Impetus. Ja, wenn du dich allein fühlst, wenn du gestresst bist, wenn du dies und das bist, nicht schlafen kannst, dann habe ich hier die perfekten Lieder für dich. Und da werden ja auch hin und wieder dann Psychiater zitiert, die sagen, ja, das ist natürlich völlig Quatsch. Also nur weil jemand aggressive Musik hört, ist er nicht aggressiv. Oder umgekehrt macht Musik, die aggressiv ist, einen nicht aggressiv. Es kann ja eher so sein, auch zum Beispiel, dass gerade diese wohltemperierte Wohlfühlmusik einen dazu bringt, dass man eher gereizt ist. Also ich stelle das immer fest. Wenn ich mal bei der Kosmetika bin, da kommt so Plätschermusik, so ätherische Klänge, macht mich wahnsinnig aggressiv. Da bin ich wirklich kurz vorm Amoklauf, wenn ich da eine Stunde drin bin.
Genau, das ist dann einfach das falsche Genre für dich. Es war ja eine kleine Überraschung. Also sie hat ja so einen Kapitel über Surveillance, also Überwachung, in dem sie diese Frapped-Kampagne, die am Jahresende immer wurde, jeder postet auf Instagram, was er so gehört hat. Da war ja 2024 erstmals auch dieses Microgenre-großes Thema, weil plötzlich eine Story nach der anderen generiert wurde, in denen einfach irgendwelche ganz hanebüchenen Microgenres auch benannt wurden. Einfach so mit drei, vier Worten, drei davon Adjektive, wie auch immer. Und die Leute haben sich sehr gewundert, ich mich auch. Was ist denn das? Das war so ein KI-Scherz irgendwie. Aber so filigran gehen die anscheinend intern tatsächlich vor, dass es da so eine Aufschlussung gibt. Ich finde, hier kann man noch mal interessante Zahlen vom Anfang nennen. Also 2006 wird Spotify gegründet und trifft auf eine Bevölkerung, die nicht mehr bereit ist, auf die Verfügbarkeit von Musik zu verzichten. Piraterie in Schweden ist so groß, dass 1,2 Millionen von 9 Millionen Schweden, die es gibt, Filesharing benutzen. Also auf Pirate Bay abhängen, später Casa und so. Napster kommt natürlich auch oder kam 2000. Und Thomas Mittelhoff damals, als Eigner dieser ganzen Kataloge über Chef Bertelsmann und so, hat dann schon diesen 60 Millionen Dollar Deal mit Napster gemacht. Bei dem dann die Musiker feststellten, noch lange vor Spotify und so, also wir zählen hier gar nichts. Der Typ macht einfach ein Deal und plötzlich wird meine Musik auch gestreamt. Also der hat einfach mit gar keinem gesprochen. Also noch lange vor Spotify ist sozusagen der Künstler da einfach völlig unter die Räder gekommen. Und dann hieß es einfach, ja wir vertreiben dich jetzt über einen Abo-Dienst, friss oder stirb. Hier gibt es pauschale Raten irgendwie. Damals allerdings noch ein Cent pro Stream, also bis zu. Da hatte man wahrscheinlich diese jeden Tag hörende 10 Stunden Musik noch gar nicht drin. Also dass man dann auf so einen Pauschalpreis pro Monat von 100 Euro käme oder so.
Heute sind wir bei 0,0035 Cent.
Allein durch die Frechheit von Spotify, aber auch durch die Masse an Content, der durchgenudelt wird. Was ich auch nicht schlecht finde. Also das kulturelle Archiv der Musik, die bisher geschrieben wurde, produziert wurde, steht ja nun zur Verfügung und ist offenbar aufgeschlüsselt, auch wenn für aktuelle Künstler zu Nachteile. Aber es hat trotzdem erstmal Vorteile, dass man das alles hören kann.
Wenn die Backlist natürlich so unendlich lang ist, dann werden die Leute immer auch auf Altes zurückgreifen. Darunter leiden noch lebende Künstler. Das ist logisch. Aber es geht ja dann eben noch weiter. Dazu kommen wir noch, wie dann diese Musik verändert wird. Ja, also wie jetzt man auch sagt, die Backlist schön und gut. Aber wir müssten die auch mal durch die KI jagen, damit sie ein bisschen glatter klingt.
Sie erinnert daran, 2000er, also 2003 gab es in Amerika schon einen Vorschlag vom US Center for Economic and Policy Research, die gesagt haben, lasst uns doch einen Artistic Freedom Voucher einführen. Also ein Abrechnungsmodell, das digital und auf die Nutzung Bezug nimmt. Aber jeder bekommt einfach 100 Dollar zweckgebunden. Also so ein Kulturgutschein haben wir heute auch immer wieder in Diskussion. Was eben auf ein Fonds in Höhe von 20 Milliarden Dollar hinausläuft, beispielsweise in Amerika. Also solche Sachen wurden schon immer diskutiert. Die Frage ist halt immer, wo kommt das Geld her? Sollte man jetzt, also wie kann man rechtfertigen, dass der staatliche Eingriff so groß ist, dass vielleicht sogar die Geldquelle nicht das eigene Einkommen ist? Also kriege ich jetzt wirklich vom Staat den Voucher? Oder sagt einfach mein Arbeitgeber, ja, hast du eine Sachleistung im Sinne von Auto? Oder du nimmst ein E-Fahrrad, was staatlicherseits, und dann als drittes wird auch noch übers Einkommen verrechnet irgendwie 100 Euro zweckgebunden für Kunst. Du musst ins Theater, ins Museum oder halt zu einer Bibliothek um deinen Streamingdienst und so. Also alle solche Sachen, solche politischen Diskussionen von 2000. Ja, das haben wir 25 Jahre lang quasi nicht in der Ernsthaftigkeit diskutiert. Ist schon erstaunlich. Stattdessen nahm die Entwicklung eine andere große Polizei Razzia bei Pirate Bay und so weiter. Und Spotify sagte sich eben, wir klären das hier über den nicht technischen, sondern den juristischen Weg. Wir machen einfach diese Verträge. Ja, und so wie die Major Labels am Anfang noch Fress oder Störb an die Künstler ran gingen, ging halt Spotify an die Labels und sagte Fress oder Störb. Spotify gibt es schon in Europa zum Beispiel, lieber Amerikaner, seid ihr dabei oder nicht? Und dann hat man denen halt dieses Geld dahingehalten und gesagt Fress oder Störb. Ja, weil Apple und so, die haben ja damals immer noch Alben verkauft einfach. Also da gab es dieses Streaming-Verfügbarkeit gar nicht. Da war einfach der iTunes Store halt ein digitales CD-Geschäft. So und da stoß man auf offene Ohren und konnte eben schon so ein bisschen europäisches Geschäftsmodell vorweisen.
Ja, man hatte ja gegründet, man hat auch Spotify Technology SA in Luxemburg angemeldet zur Steueroptimierung, wie man so schön sagt. Und es war eigentlich mal so anfangs die Idee, man macht so ein Video Streaming-Dienst. Das hatte man sich mal kurz überlegt und dann hat man gesehen, die Musik ist eigentlich viel interessanter. Fred Davis, der Sohn von Clive Davis, spielt dann auch eine Rolle bei dem Ganzen. Clive Davis ist der Produzent z. B von Whitney Houston gewesen. Also wir haben es halt mit Leuten zu tun, die ordentlich mit Geld ausgestattet sind und sehen, dass das eigentlich noch ein ungehobener Schatz ist. Nämlich, dass man zwar jetzt digital Alben verkaufen kann, wie Apple das tut. Und der iPod ist ja im Prinzip dann tot, wenn Spotify sich etabliert. Ja, also der iPod ist auch dann durch, dass das Smartphone natürlich das alles kann, nicht mehr so wichtig. Aber eigentlich war der iPod so dieser Weg, der der Musikindustrie zeigt, hier, das ist der neue Discman, den man jetzt haben kann. Und genau das wird jetzt unterminiert durch Spotify. Und eigentlich läuft das dann auch deshalb so gut, weil diese Labels, die ja auch gar nicht mit ihren Künstlern das groß absprechen müssen, sich darauf einigen, auf diese 70-30-Lösung. Die ist natürlich für Spotify nicht so ideal. Man könnte ja vielleicht mehr bekommen. Und das muss man sich jetzt im Hinterkopf behalten. Diese 70-30-Lösung, die kann man ja vielleicht auch anders ankratzen. Also vielleicht muss man da andere Wege finden, wie man vielleicht doch mehr für sich als Plattform rausholen kann. Und das geschieht dann über die Jahre mit sehr verschiedenen neuen Tools.
Das sind ja die Entscheidungen, die jeder Unternehmer irgendwann treffen kann. Gehe ich hier in ein Mensch oder in eine Maschine und die Maschine kriegt halt keinen Monatsgehalt.
Zum Beispiel.
Nur eine Anfangsinvestition und da kann man dann anders skalieren als mit Menschen.
Oder ich kann natürlich auch sagen, lieber Künstler, also wir könnten deinen Song ein bisschen besser platzieren und könnten ihn auch schon mal in eine Playlist nehmen. Wenn du bereit bist, auf deinen 70 30 Anteil zu verzichten, oder zumindest auf Teile, drehen wir es doch lieber um. Wir bekommen 70 und du 30. Dafür aber bringen wir dich groß raus.
Genau.
Oder du kannst Werbung bei uns buchen für deinen Song. Und dann wird dein Song auch mehr geklickt und das lohnt sich dann für dich sowieso.
Das ist wie bei Talia auf den ersten Tisch liegen.
Ganz richtig. Ja. Und ich glaube, das Interessante ist, weil manche werden jetzt sagen, na ja, aber es gab doch immer genau so was wie bei Talia. Wie kommt man da vorne in den Ausstellungsbereich? Oder ja, es gab doch auch, darauf geht sie auch ein, Payola, also dass man Radiomoderatoren besticht, dafür, dass sie mal den Song spielen. All diese Dinge gab es. Nur müssen wir jetzt hier bei allem, was wir an Alten darin sehen, auch bereit sein, das neu zu erkennen. Ich finde, das macht das Buch sehr gut. In dieser gebündelten Form, dass wir hier einen proprietären Markt haben, auf dem dann alles einfach geschieht, weil Musik plötzlich synonym ist mit Spotify. Das ist das Nobum plus die technischen Möglichkeiten, diese Ausbeutung der Künstler in einer Weise voranzutreiben und ihnen Konkurrenz zu machen durch KI, wie es vorher so nie dagewesen ist.
Genau, und das ist nämlich der große Punkt. Sie macht es sehr gut, dass sie immer wieder diese Spotify-Tricks, die du jetzt auch aufgelistet hast, beschreibt und dann aber einfach 100 Jahre zurückgeht in der Geschichte und sagt, ja, war schon mal so. Also die Ideen sind alle nicht neu, aber jetzt ist eben alles in so einem technischen Silo, das als neue Gefahr da einfach lauert, weil das so eine Vereinheitlichung, ist ja mehr als monopol diesmal, ist ja wirklich ein ganzer Marktplatz gestaltet. Und sie beschreibt es auch nochmal, wie auf der einen Seite das Publikum so, wir wollen alle Musik haben, wir gehen auf Pirate Bay, wir wissen, das ist illegal. Manchmal kommt auch die Polizei, aber wir machen es trotzdem. Daniel Eck auf der anderen Seite als Gründer von Spotify und eben dieser Martin Lorenzo, die sind ja aus der ganz anderen Richtung. Die haben einfach, das ist ja beschrieben, Technik gesehen und wollten dann irgendwas mit ihr machen. Eck hat sich bei Google beworben mit 16, erfolglos, hat dann in der Schule schon Webseiten gebaut für irgendwelche Leute mehrere 1000 Dollar pro Monat verdient. Da hatte er eine Firma, die gut lief, die hat er verkauft an so einen Werbetreiber, also war quasi mit 23 bereit, in Rente zu gehen, wie er sagte. Er hat sich Ferraris gekauft und hing in Nachtclubs rum. Also diese Leute waren, was das angeht, schon saturiert. Dann gab es jetzt nicht die Künstler, die Musik und so weiter, sondern die haben halt Spotify AB als Werbefirma gegründet, dann gab es Spotify Sweden AB, Spotify Technology SA, das eine war in Luxemburg, das andere in Zypern. Also die haben das Spiel schon komplett verstanden und trafen dann plötzlich auf diese Leidenschaftsindustrie Musik und dieser Clash.
Und das musste man dann rhetorisch nur zusammenbringen. Und deswegen ist die ganze Zeit in diesen Verkündigungen von Spotify die Rede davon, dass man den Künstler empowern will, dass man die Musik demokratisieren will. All diese Slogans werden auch immer wieder von Liz Pelly aufgegriffen und gesagt, es geht immer nur um eine Profitoptimierung. Und diese Typen muss man sich so vorstellen, wie du hast vielleicht auch die zweite Staffel von The White Lotus gesehen.
Nee, noch nicht. The White Lotus muss ich noch sehen.
Ah, okay, wie diese beiden Typen da, wo man auch nicht so genau weiß. Die machen irgendwas mit digitalen, kennen Jack Dorsey. Sie sind reich. Vielleicht haben sie auch einen Streaming-Service. Ich weiß es nicht so genau, aber sie leben so den Lifestyle, in dem eigentlich Kultur keine Rolle spielt. Und genau so können wir das hier auch sehen. In Kapitel 3 ist da...
Ja, sie schreibt das ja ganz eindrucksvoll, dass sie zum einen sagt, der erste offizielle Mitarbeiter damals, ZTO, also der technische Leiter Andreas Ehn, sagt, damals war noch gar nicht klar, dass wir Musik machen würden, geschweige denn, dass Musik im Mittelpunkt steht. So, und dann haben sie aber einfach entdeckt, damals hörten bereits 98, nee, also Leute hörten Musik online zu 98 Prozent Raub kopiert. Also da lag einfach sozusagen ein Geschäftsmodell auf der Straße, es musste nur jemand neben diesen, okay, die Technik ist geklärt, wir haben Lust auf diese Technik, wir wollen was mit dieser Technik machen und dann diesen juristischen Apparat daneben stellen und sagen, dass mit diesem Raub kopieren ist das Problem. Wir sagen jetzt einfach den Labels, komm, 0,00035 Cent, also am Ende, ja, darauf lässt man sich nach, aber man macht einfach diese Verträge mit so Thomas Mittelhoff und so, der einfach auch nur Geld will.
In der Serie Die Cum-Ex-Affäre.
Die hab ich gesehen, die ist sehr gut.
Da sagt ja der Jurist, was ist eigentlich unsere Aufgabe? Wasser ist für alle da, aber wir müssen die Flasche kreieren, dass wir Wasser verkaufen können. Und was die hier bei Spotify machen, ist eine Flasche kreieren, dass man diese Musik, die überall frei flottiert, plötzlich doch verkaufen kann an Leute.
Dann haben sie alles um diesen Playbutton drumherum gebaut. Soweit, dass sogar am Ende Ludwig Striegeus, der Entwickler von U-Torrent oder My-Torrent, das ist auch eine Software, die ich damals sehr viel benutzt habe, dass der dann bei Spotify anheuerte. Also da haben sich sozusagen aus beiden Welten die Technik-Treiber gefunden. So eine natürlich selbst nicht, da ist so Ideologe geblieben, aber so diese ganzen Leute, die dann halt so dieses Betorrent-Zeug und so entwickelt haben. Und es ist ja auch, muss man ja wirklich sagen, manchmal sitzt man ja im Zug und will Podcasts hören und der Podcast-Player, den man eigentlich benutzt, der geht da nicht, weil der will ja erstmal die Datei runterladen und so. Und dann wechselt man einfach auf Spotify, drückt auf Play und es geht. Also es ist halt wirklich technisch erstaunlich, wie leicht verfügbar es so ist. Also in der Ansicht finde ich, ist ja der Ansatz gar nicht verkehrt. Allerdings gehöre ich ja auch in die Riege, die sagt, zum Glück gibt es jetzt auch Clot für 200 Euro im Monat. Und ich weiß, das ist einfach zu viel grundsätzlich. Also Spotify für 200, 300 Euro im Monat zu verkaufen, was immer noch unter Wert wäre, wäre halt nicht praktikabel. Aber dieser technische Teil, der denen da so wichtig war, denen sie als das zentrale Ding hingestellt werden, würde ich auch sagen, das ist und bleibt weiterhin das Ding, um das es geht.
Kapitel 3 ist überschrieben mit Leanback Listening. Und da nähern wir uns jetzt also den Hörgewohnheiten, die sich ändern durch Spotify. Spotify hat 2012 schon feststellen können, das funktioniert richtig gut für User, die wissen, was sie hören wollen. Die geben das nämlich ins Suchfeld ein und dann bekommen sie das. Aber das funktionierte nicht so gut für die Leute, die sich einfach zurücklehnen wollen und gar nicht laufende Entscheidungen treffen, jetzt der Song, der oder der, sondern sie versprechen dann Music for Every Moment. Und dann führen sie Moody Images ein. Da heißt es, Ende des Jahres wurde die Website von Spotify zum ersten Mal grundlegend neu gestaltet. Wo sich zuvor auf Slogans wie Soforteinfach und kostenlos konzentriert wurde, wurde im Dezember eine neue Identität enthüllt. Musik für jeden Moment. Die Startseite wurde von einem ganzzeitigen Video eingenommen, das eine Reihe stimmungsvoller Bilder zeigte, die direkt von einem Tumblr- oder Pinterest-Board stammen könnten. Sonnenflächen, die sich in einem Fenster auf einer Stadtautobahn spiegeln, eine Hängematte, die sich langsam hin und her schaukelt, ein unkonventioneller Anhalter, der am Straßenrand entlangläuft, untermalt von einer generisch-sentimentalen Akustik-Volkmelodie, die automatisch im Hintergrund abgespielt wird. Wie Stock-Fotos in einem noch nicht verwendeten Bilderrahmen, die darauf warteten, durch das echte Leben ersetzt zu werden, schien es bei der Montage weniger darum zu gehen, den Nutzern die Technologie zu erklären, als vielmehr darum, die Nutzer dazu zu bringen, sich als Spotify-Kunden vorzustellen. Und da sagt man dann, wir haben jetzt für deine Stimmung, für die jeweilige Musik bzw. willst du dir nicht selbst Playlists kreieren? Das ist dann ab 2013 möglich für deine verschiedenen Stimmungen. Und zugleich bieten wir, die Spotify-Redaktion, das Editorial-Team, wir bieten auch Playlists für dich an. Und auf diesen Playlists, also die angeboten wurden, ist man genauso vorgegangen im Prinzip wie Facebook. Bei Facebook haben wir ja auch dann später rausgefunden, die haben mit Posts immer wieder AB-Tests gemacht. Also man spielt nach einer kleinen Gruppe was aus, guckt, wie das funktioniert und dann geht das dann breit raus. Und genau das hat man auch mit Songs gemacht. Man hat also immer wieder irgendwelche Gruppen sich ausgesucht, an Kunden geschaut, welcher Song funktioniert da, wo wird weggeklickt. Und dann hat man solche optimierten Playlists erstellt. Dabei hat Spotify natürlich selbst immer betont, wir sind nicht die Gatekeeper. Wir haben ja nur den Publikumsgeschmack abgefragt.
Genau. Und hier scheint auch mal so richtig eine Leidenschaft einer Autorin durch. Diese Playlists sind ja erst später zu Spotify gekommen, weil denen war ja eigentlich die Nutzung der Plattform so ein bisschen egal, Hauptsache der User hat auf Play gedrückt und so. Und dann kam seine Musik. Aber dafür musste man ja wissen, was man hört. Und über diesen Weg, wir lizenzieren einfach die Musik der Welt und schaffen darüber schon mal ein gleiches Spielfeld für alle, in dem es für den Nutzer ja egal ist, ob das jetzt gerade Major, Label, Top-Künstler ist oder jemand, den man gerade gestern bei einem Konzert lokal entdeckt hat und den man jetzt einfach, den hätte ich gerne auch in meiner Verfügbarkeit. Ich möchte auch da einfach auf Play drücken. Und ganz interessant fand ich, dass die Majors immer groß organisiert waren natürlich, weil die haben ja dieses mega Business, 45 Milliarden oder welche Zahl sie da nennt, 34 Milliarden Jahresumsatz und so auf drei, vier große Akteure. Okay. Aber diese darunter liegende Indie-Label-Linie, die auch einen Kontakt zu Spotify brauchte, musste sich überhaupt erstmal organisieren. Und sie nennt dann dieses Merlin Network, dass sich mit einem Marktanteil von 15 Prozent, tausende Labels in 68 Ländern, also es gab sozusagen eine richtig große Bemühung, da so ein quasi Minor-Label, Major-Label zu machen, irgendwie so. Und dann stellt sich aber ein Text heraus, dass dieses Merlin Network überhaupt erst in diesem Moment entstand. Also das hatte gar keine Jahrzehnte Geschichte mit Rod Stewart im Central Garden oder was auch immer und so. Also da diese großen Shows, sondern die haben sich überhaupt erst gefunden und gesagt, okay, wir müssen jetzt uns hier auch mal organisieren, denn wenn wir auf diese Plattform wollen, ist das Nadelöhr recht eng. Und die haben aber quasi alle Verhandlungen verbockt. Also weder bei MySpace Music noch bei Nogia Comes with Music. Sie schreibt dann auch in Klammern, so hieß das wirklich. Also es war einfach, da sieht man schon, das Handy sollte damit vermarktet werden. Kam es dann dazu, dass man bei Spotify einfach gesagt hat, okay, okay, wir machen jetzt mal hier einen Vertrag, damit es mal überhaupt zu irgendetwas kommt. Also man hat sozusagen eine freie Künstlerszene in sehr verwundbarer Situation vorgefunden, die dann da reingebracht und dann plötzlich, als diese Deals alle unter Dach und Frach waren und man auch eine gewisse Nutzerbasis hatten, also klar, Spotify 2009 in Europa schon gestartet, aber trotzdem 26,5 Millionen Dollar Verlust, aber mit dieser großen Erwartung der Investoren, das wird schon irgendwie, kam dann auch bei Spotify überraschend, dieses ach so, die suchen gar nicht einfach nur ein Wissen, was sie wollen, sondern die lagern dann so an Last FM oder was auch immer, sie nennt dann so verschiedene Sachen, die es hier gibt, auch eine App vom Rolling Stone zum Beispiel, wo einfach Playlists und das kannst du ja mal hören und so weiter, also diese Art von ihrer eigenen Herkunft, nämlich do-it-yourself Musikbranche, Musikjournalismus, was sich plötzlich auch technisch niederschlug. Also das ist sozusagen diese Einflugschneise für sie, für ihr Interesse, aber auch für Spotify's großen Erfolg, erst im Nachgang diese Verplaylistung zu machen. Leute suchen nicht ein Album und dann läuft das 45 Minuten und dann ist wieder Stille, sondern es muss ja dann weitergehen.
Also dieses 35 Millionen abonnieren zum Beispiel Today's Top Hits. Today's Top Hits kann alles sein.
Da sitzen dann einfach drei Leute da und bauen das so zusammen und stehen halt wieder vor diesem, sagen wir mal in Anführungszeichen, Problem, dass natürlich die Lobbyisten da Schlange stehen und auch diese Playlist wollen.
Und dann ging es immer wieder darum, dass ja die Menschen Musik hören wollen, aber gar nicht besondere Aufmerksamkeit darauf legen möchten. Und dann bietet man solche Musik an, die nebenher einfach gut läuft. Pletra Musik oder so könnte man sagen. Und dann geht es auch darum, dass man eigentlich etwas als Konkurrenz anerkennt, was erst einmal nicht so direkt einem einfällt. Also Daniel Eck wird gefragt, wer ist dann eigentlich der Konkurrent? Und er sagt dann in so einer, ich glaube, Mitarbeiterkonferenz, also wir brauchen uns jetzt nicht so sehr mit Apple und so weiter zu beschäftigen, sondern er sagt, our only competitor is silence.
So, als du das gelesen hast, du kommst ja aus dieser Filmrichtung.
Da habe ich sofort an den Netflix-Chef gebracht. Der wurde dann nämlich auch mal gefragt, was ist die Konkurrenz? Und er sagte dann seinen Mitarbeitern, es ist nicht Disney Plus und nicht Amazon Prime. Unsere Konkurrenz ist der Schlaf.
Und das steht ja hier quasi wortwörtlich auch als Daniel Egg-Zitat drin. Und das ist ja, finde ich auch, eine Geschichte der unternehmerischen Semantik beim Investors Call. Also solche Sätze. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass ich Daniel Egg in Stille, die er dann auch mal hatte, sehr viel bei Retestings abgeschaut habe. Weil der Netflix-Chef hat ja damals auch schon, wir haben es ja auch einmal im Salon gelesen, wie macht man Management, wie macht man Projektbezogene, wie baut man einen Film, wie lässt man Hierarchie auch mal links liegen, damit es was wird, der kreative Prozess und so weiter. Also ich glaube, Daniel Egg war damals sehr interessiert an dieser Art Kultur.
Ganz richtig. Und es war ja auch so erstaunlich, als der Spotify-IPO war, gab es viele Kommentare, die hatten folgenden Tenor. Ja, die Spotify-Aktie könnte etwas für sie sein, wenn sie daran glauben, dass Spotify das nächste Netflix ist.
Ja, genau.
Also das war immer, es lief so parallel, also Netflix ein bisschen früher, Spotify dann hinterher. Nur hat jetzt Daniel Egg einen entscheidenden Vorteil. Wenn man schläft, muss man ja die Augen geschlossen halten. Das heißt, es lohnt sich nicht, Netflix anzuhaben.
Man kann den Schlaf tatsächlich unterbauen mit Musik.
Genau.
Moby hat ein 8-Stunden-Album gemacht, einfach nur zum Schlafen, für die Zeit des Schlafens.
Oder der Richter, Max Richter. Genau. Auch dieser Max-Richter-Vibe, möchte ich mal sagen. Der kommt ja auch nicht von ungefähr, sondern das ist genau das, was hier eigentlich gewollt ist, dass die Leute weiter konsumieren, dass sie dabei bleiben.
Genau. Der Schlaf ist das eine. Und die Arbeit ist das andere, spielt ja auch noch ein großes Thema. Ich habe im sogenannten Gegenwart-Podcast gehört, dass es für die Apple-Serie, die hier im Büro spielt, sehr, sehr, sehr, wie heißt sie? Wo sie ihr Gehirn noch mal ausschalten im Fahrstuhl?
Severance.
Severance. Dass es eine Severance-Playlist gibt, die genau acht Stunden gibt, für einen Arbeitstag.
Naja.
Also lauter solche Scherze kann man hier machen. Was ich wirklich interessant finde im Buch ist, wie sie darstellt, wie Spotify diese Playlistung fast übersehen hat. Und sie macht das über diese schöne Recherchearbeit, einfach aufzustüsseln, was es damals alles gab. Also erst 2012 bei einer Presseveranstaltung in New York kündigt Daniel Egg an, ja es wird große Veränderungen geben. Bei der Ablehnung von Kurationen bin ich zu dogmatisch gewesen. Also mir geht es nicht nur darum, mit möglichst vielen Verträgen, möglichst viel Musik auf die Plattform, da kann man sich was raussuchen, sondern nein, die Musik ist jetzt da, wir kuratieren, also wir denken es jetzt sozusagen vom Nutzer her, nachdem man den Playbutton gedrückt hat. Und die Landschaft sah damals schon so aus. Die Major Labels waren schon groß investiert und hatten entweder relativ viele Playlist-Firmen aufgebaut oder gekauft. Sony hatte zum Beispiel Filter, also ohne E, wie Flickr und so damals, dieser coole Web 2.0-Sprech. Universal hatte Dicstar. Warner hatte Share My Playlist gekauft, das später weiterentwickelt und als Topsy vermarktet. Last FM und so weiter. Es war eine Wildwest-Phase des Playlistings, wie sie schrieb, und Spotify war da gar nicht präsent. Also für die war das dann wirklich erst, ach so, ja, hm, sollten wir mal machen. Und plötzlich gab es dann die große Spotify-Strategie, Musik für jeden Moment. Und dann kamen auch diese Kuratoren. Dann hat man diese Redaktion aufgebaut und es fällt ja auch zeitgleich mit Apple zum Beispiel oder vielen anderen, Google, die dann einfach sahen, ach so, wir stellen nicht nur in der Suche den Katalog des Weltwissens bereit, sondern die Leute wollen bei uns auch News anklicken. Und plötzlich haben die so eigene Redaktion aufgebaut. Und die ganzen Zeitungen in Deutschland, die haben immer noch nicht gewusst, was da eigentlich passiert. Also, dass sie da wirklich Konkurrenz bekommen aus dieser Richtung. Und so war das hier auch. Also, die ganzen großen Major Labels als Musikhersteller hatten ihre eigenen Playlist-Firmen im Anschlag. Und dann hat Daniel Eggt das einfach alles auf die Plattform geholt. Also mal so einen richtigen Power-Move von diesen Technikleuten, wie so viele damals, dass sie einfach sagen, bei uns kann man doch auch eine Reise buchen. Ja, und plötzlich gab es Google, was weiß ich, Travel und der ganze Kram, irgendwie sowas. Und erst zehn Jahre später, nee, da müssten wir jetzt doch mal drauf gucken, ob das kartellrechtlich so in Ordnung ist, dass man einfach eine Marktmacht auf einem Gebiet so transferiert auf die nächste. Also Spotify hat sich diese Playlists einfach unter den Nagel gerissen. Mit allen Technikvorteilen, die sie halt hatten, weil man musste halt nicht erst in einem Link folgen, eine andere App oder wie auch immer den Katalog per irgendeine API zur Verfügung stellen für irgendeine App, sondern nein, das fand alles bei Spotify plötzlich statt.
Das vierte Kapitel heißt The Conquest of Chill. Es geht dann sehr bald nicht mehr nur um Music, sondern auch um Musak. Manche werden diesen Begriff nicht kennen, also M-U-Z-A-K. Damit ist Musik gemeint, die so nebenbei daher plätschert. Das ist Musik, die nicht weiter stört, die so präsent ist, dass wir sie oft gar nicht wahrnehmen. Wir sitzen irgendwo und merken erst dann nach langer Zeit, ach ja, hier läuft ja irgendetwas im Café, am Musik. Also ich nehme diese Musik leider sehr wahr und für mich ist das der Horror. Also für mich ist das alles immer überall zu laut und zu aufgetreten und ich wünschte mir sehr viele stille Räume. Aber das ist eine Musik, die natürlich überall da ist. Und das ist etwas, was eigentlich das Streben dann von Spotify wird, nämlich so ein reibungsloses Nutzer-Erlebnis zu schaffen mit reibungsloser Musik. Und da spricht man dann von funktionaler Musik, von easy listening und von ambiente Musik. Natürlich werden viele Brian Enno kennen, der Musik gemacht hat für den Flughafen, Musik gemacht hat für gewisse Ambiente.
Wo ich eben in der Musik auch hingehört.
Und hier am Flughafen. Ja. Wegen mir kann der Flughafenmusiker sagen, ich flieg so selten. Aber das ist eben dann Musik, die nicht mal so für bestimmte Orte kurz saß, sondern wir haben dann eigentlich eine Flut von dieser reibungslosen Musik, weil Netflix erkennt, damit kann man die Leute lange dabei halten. Und man kann vor allem auch dafür sorgen, dass sie sich so wohlfühlen, dass sie auf Dauer dabei bleiben. Also es geht zum Beispiel um Low-Fi-Beats, also Low-Fidelity. Das ist so ein Musikstil mit so reduzierter Klangqualität, so eine nostalgische Atmosphäre wird geschaffen. Und da sind die Leute dann ja in so einer Lean-Back-Situation, dass sie sagen, endlich nach Hause kommen, der stressige Tag ist vorbei, Spotify schafft mir jetzt wieder Beruhigung.
Und das ist ja sehr interessant, weil hier wird das Buch so, also wirklich interessant und klug einfach. Man lernt so viel, nämlich nicht nur über Spotify, sondern auch über uns. Denn zum einen, ja, sie beschreibt natürlich, wie es so ist, sich auf einer Spotify Playlist einzukaufen, dann ein Angebot gegen den Schlaf zu machen. Hier Spotify, ich habe ein Angebot für euch gegen den Schlaf, ja und dann teilen wir uns die Rendite, wie auch immer. Und dann kommt sie aber in diesem vierten Kapitel plötzlich auf Musak. Ja. So spricht man es, glaube ich, auszusprechen. Musak, wie auch immer, Musak, also M-U-Z-A-K. 1921 gibt es also Technologien, um Töne zu übertragen. Es gibt ja Phonografen, also auch Hörerinnen, und der Erfinder Edison denkt sich so, hm, wäre doch cool irgendwie. Und dann entsteht so ein Business, Klänge mittels Drähten statt Funkwellen zu übertragen. Man kann sich dann zu Hause so ein Gerät hinstellen, aus dem einfach Musik kommt. Wir sind hier im Jahr 1934 und so. Damals wird die Fahrstuhlmusik erfunden. Wir wissen ja heute, im Fahrstuhl ist der Lautsprecher fest verbaut. Wir tragen ja alles mit Kopfhörern mit uns. Also wir können quasi überall Fahrstuhlmusik. Und dieses Konzept ist aber sozusagen Jahrzehnte alt. Also Musak eröffnet dann in New York ein Tonstudio, wo extra so Originalstücke produziert werden. Sie schreibt dann gleich, das ist eine interessante Parallele zu Spotify's Ghost Artists heute. Also ich werde einfach ein Jahrhundert überspannt mit sowas. 1940 kommt dann ein Boom universitärer Forschung dazu. Diese ganze Idee von Arbeitsproduktivität und Musiktherapie kommt in die Welt. Und Radioprogramme Music While You Work. BBC-Radioprogramm von damals nennt sie dann alles. Und das finde ich schon interessant. Also diese Firmen hat es ja dann auch recht lange gegeben. Ende der 80er hat Music 80 Millionen Kunden, also die diese Musik einfach hören. Und bis 2011 überlebte diese Firma unter dem Namen Mood Media. Was für eine tolle Technik ist das?
Weil natürlich diese ganzen, zum Beispiel Kosmetikstudios, irgendwelche Einkaufscenter darauf immer wieder zurückgegriffen haben, dass es billiger ist als richtige Musik zu spielen. Und es ist auch vielleicht dann verkaufsfördernd, wenn man solche Dudelmusik die ganze Zeit spielt. Und das Problem ist jetzt aber, weil wir eben schon über diese Pool-Lösungen bei der Auszahlung von Künstlern gesprochen haben, dass das, was ja häufig wiederholt wird, eben besser bezahlt wird. Das heißt also, jeder normale Künstler leidet natürlich darunter, dass die einzelnen Streams zählen und sonst nichts. Das heißt, diese Music, die dort in Endlosschleife abgespielt wird, produziert natürlich unendlich viele Streams und damit Auszahlungen, während der, der den guten Indie-Song komponiert hat, einmal am Tag gehört wird und dann sagt man, ja, vielleicht höre ich den Morgen noch mal, aber nicht in Dauerschleife.
Genau, also das stehen einfach drei Minuten gegen 30 Stunden.
Ja.
Wir haben ja demnächst einen gemeinsamen Termin, einer der wenigen öffentlichen Termine gemeinsam in Hamburg.
Und ich habe dir ja schon ein Hotel vorgeschlagen.
Ich glaube allerdings, wir dürfen das hier nicht in dieses Land kündigen, dass alle kommen können, weil das ist glaube ich eine interne Sache.
Also ein Säbio öffentliches.
Also sollte es öffentlich sein, dann sagen wir das natürlich Bescheid. Aber es ist so ein ein Kongress über Social Media und Marketing und ich glaube, weiß nicht, ob das, also wenn es für alle öffentlich ist, mir geht es auch mehr darum, dass ich dir schon ein Hotel vorgeschlagen habe, von dem ich weiß, der hat so einen Spa-Bereich, wo man die Tür aufmacht und sofort hört, hier ist man jetzt im Otherworlds. Okay, da ist Ambiente.
Ja, da wird genau Music so gespielt. Dafür war das da ein Kabel zu legen bis dahin, um da einfach auf Play zu drücken und dann läuft das den ganzen Tag. Sowas muss ich da denken. Das ist Fahrstuhlmusik, die da stattfindet. Genau, und jetzt braucht man halt Content dafür. Also heißt es hier Ghost Artists for Hire.
Zum Beispiel Low Girl. Es gibt eine, ja, soll ich sagen, Künstlerin, die produziert diese Musik oder unter diesem Namen wird Musik veröffentlicht, die solche ambiente Klänge bietet und tatsächlich kommentieren dann auch Leute unter jedem Upload. Danke Low Girl, ich liebe deine Musik. Und da sagt der Produzent, sie denken wirklich, dass Low Girl die Künstlerin ist. Und das ist es, was Low Girl will, wie jedes andere große Low Label auch. So weit sind wir jetzt. So etwas wie eine Low Künstlerin gibt es aber nicht. Es gibt nur eine Person, die Teil der Low Maschine ist. Das heißt, die maschinelle Produktion solcher Klänge ist natürlich für Firmen plötzlich hoch interessant, beziehungsweise wird für Spotify selbst natürlich hoch interessant, weil man die ja möglicherweise nicht so bezahlen muss wie normale Künstler.
Also ihr Text steckt dazu, finde ich super, denn sie fragt sich dann wirklich, wie kam es dazu? Ja, das fragen sich vielleicht Künstlerinnen und Hingebungsvolle, wie du, die nachts wach liegen, doch Spotifys Frage war andere, warum zahlen wir eigentlich Tandem zum Vollpreis, wenn die Leute doch nur mit halbem Ohr zuhören?
Ja.
So, und darum muss ich ehrlich sagen, als eigene Erinnerung an eine Zeit vor Spotify, wenn man so ein Popalbum gekauft hat für teuer Geld, teuer Taschengeld, 10 Mark für 10 Liter oder sowas, dann waren da eigentlich zwei Hits dabei. Und die anderen acht waren Filler. Und so ist das halt heute auch.
Kommt auf den Künstler an, ja. Also bei Taylor Swift stimmt das natürlich.
Dachte ich es mehr so an Britney Spears oder so.
Ja.
Also hat man nun, da Spotify dieses Problem als für sich erkannt hat, die Leute hören ja nur mit halbem Ohr zu, aber dafür fünfmal so lange. Also das ist ja so die Kalkulation. Man hat PFC, Perfect Fit Content, was ja schon bedeutet, ab jetzt ist egal woher und wie. Hauptsache die Rechnung geht auf mit halbem Ohr, aber mehr als doppelt so lange hinhören, also dass die Gleichung stimmt.
Und wie hat man das dann gemacht? Nun, man hat Studiumusiker genommen und die haben am Fließband irgendwas eingespielt und denen hat man ein Buyout gemacht. Also die mussten da einen Vertrag unterschreiben, dass sie für die Session bezahlt werden. Und die, die das in Anführungszeichen komponiert haben, die haben natürlich einen schlechteren Deal als den 70-30-Deal bekommen. Und dann hat man das ja nicht mehr so wie bei einem Lied, dass man sagt, das ist der Textdichter, das ist der Komponist, sondern man hat einfach das Label eigentlich, das dann daran verdient. Und so ist es ja auch dann gekommen, dass sich viele dachten, wir faken jetzt einfach Artists, die es gar nicht gibt. Also das war dann auch bald aufzufinden bei Spotify, dass dort Künstler aufgeführt waren, die sogar eine Vita vorweisen konnten, die aber völlig fingiert war. Aber man wollte doch noch den Hörern so den Eindruck vermitteln, dass sie hier echte Musik erleben, von einem Kopfe erdacht. Aber das stimmte dann gar nicht. Und so stellte sich dann bald heraus zum Beispiel, dass 20 Songwriter in einem Fall für 500 Künstler zuständig waren, beziehungsweise die 500 Künstler bestanden aus eigentlich nur 20 Songwriter.
Ja, und das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, weil hier bericht jetzt mit meinen eigenen, also hier bin ich wahrscheinlich einfach nicht im richtigen Alter. Spotify ist ja wie bei jedem Markt, die neuen Kunden sind junge Kunden und die haben andere Hörgewohnheiten. Denn als ich das so las, dachte ich so, okay, Perfect Fit Content. Ich höre auch relativ viel Musik, bei dem ich so mit halbem Ohr hinhöre. Meistens mache ich mal einfach auf YouTube so ein DJ-Set oder sowas an und dann läuft das halt so nebenher. Aber für Spotify bedeutet ja das hier wirklich eine echte Zäsur, weil die sind eingestiegen mit, okay, wir sehen, die Leute wollen Musik haben und sie wissen genau, was sie wollen, denn sie müssen bei Pirate Bay oder bei Kazaar oben die Suchleiste eintragen, das will ich. So, dann hat Spotify festgestellt, okay, denen das einfach nur zu geben, ist schon ganz cool und damit haben wir auch Kunden. Aber noch cooler wäre es ja, wenn wir jetzt da einen Hebel ansetzen und sagen, hört doch einfach länger, wir spielen euch schon was vor und dann kommt diese Playlist. Und dann plötzlich kommen hier diese PFCs, Perfect Fit Content Material, bei dem völlig klar ist, das kann niemand gezielt gesucht haben. Also hier gibt es nichts.
Du hast einfach die Mood-Playlist angeklickt und klickst das gespielt.
Dann im vierten Schritt sagen sie aber, wir machen jetzt Zitat Search Result Overrides. Also Leute wissen, was sie suchen, kriegen das dann aufgelistet. Aber Platz 1, 2 und 7 in dieser Liste sind PFCs. Also nicht das, was gesucht wurde, sondern so Alternativen dazu, irgendwelche Duplikate.
Das nennt Korydoktorov and Shitification.
Genau, das ist Shitification. Und da muss ich ehrlich sagen, alle diese Phänomene sind mir relativ fremd, weil ich immer genau weiß, was ich hören will. Also ich höre dann wirklich Hans Zimmer oder Genesis und ich will dann keinen Abklatsch davon. Und mir fällt schon auf, dass irgendwelche Melodien von wem auch immer, ich denke jetzt hier so an diese britischen neuen Künstler, was weiß ich, wer ist er denn, Ed Sheeran oder so. Diese Melodien, die er singt, kann man mit Gitarre nachspielen. Ja. So. Und relativ häufig höre ich schon so eine nachgespielte Musik. Man denkt sich so, ich kenne das Lied doch irgendwie. Ah ja stimmt, es ist Ed Sheeran.
Und das wird ja richtig dann in Auftrag gegeben.
Genau, das wird dann forciert. Und die Leute sagen sich, mir reicht eigentlich die Melodie zu hören. Also statt dass Ed Sheeran dann eins Tantiemen bekommt, bekommt dann dieser Klavierkünstler oder der Computer oder was auch immer, wer das gemacht hat, sozusagen fast nichts. Und Ed Sheeran kriegt nochmal so 0,2. Und Spotify weiß dann, okay, wir haben jetzt dieselbe Melodie zu demselben Publikum gespielt, aber es kostet nicht mehr eine Tantieme, sondern 0,3 oder sowas. Also das ist ja das Prinzip. Nur wenn ich eine Playlist höre, meine Playlist, also wirklich meine, ich habe Lieblingssongs markiert, Playlist. Und dann wird mir ein Hans Zimmerstück ausgetauscht aus Pearl Harbor gegen dasselbe Klavier, macht mich das sofort wütend. Also das ist einfach, ich würde sofort gerne bei Spotify anrufen und sagen, sorry, aber das habe ich nicht bestellt. Und das passiert. Also es passiert in meiner Playlist. Manchmal ist natürlich einfach, okay, irgendwelche Major Label Deals, wie bei Netflix auch, etwas rutscht aus dem Katalog draus. Und dann möchte Spotify, aber okay, wir haben so Alternativen, die setzen wir mal da rein. Hoffentlich merkt er es nicht. Aber meine Lieblingsliederliste hat jetzt 1300 Einträge. Und wenn da was drin vorkommt, also wenn da plötzlich was gespielt wird, was ich da nie reingemacht habe, höre ich das sofort. Und ich finde es auch nicht okay. Aber es scheint jetzt ein neues Spotify Publikum zu geben, dem das einfach egal ist. Die wissen, was sie eigentlich wollen, also die eine Search machen und dann mit dem Override zufrieden sind. Und da würde ich sagen, oder die den heißen Song nicht mehr kennen. Geht das wirklich zu weit?
Denn die gehen ja in die Backlist. Jetzt wird Ed Sheeran als aktueller Künstler noch relativ präsent sein. Aber mir sagte jetzt gerade ein Bekannter, dass bei irgendeiner Show das Lied von Wigili Andros, Ich Liebe das Leben von Nina Schuba gesungen wurde. Und den meisten in dem Kommentarbereich der jungen Leute war ja gar nicht klar, dass das ein Lied von Wigili Andros ist.
Ja, die wissen das ja nicht und wollen es halt trotzdem Nina Schuba hören.
Okay, dann wollen sie Nina Schuba hören. Ja, aber ich glaube, der nächste Schritt ist schon der, dass man eben diese bekannten Melodien oder halbbekannten Melodien nimmt und man sie nochmal remixt, um sie dann besser verwerten zu können, also besser für Spotify verwerten zu können. Jetzt kann man sagen, aber das gab es doch auch schon mal. Ich musste gleich, als das beschrieben wurde, an James Last denken. James Last hat ja wenige Eigenkompositionen gehabt, sondern das Entscheidende war, dass er bekannte Lieder nahm und sie dann mit diesen Streicherklängen und ein bisschen Saxophon zudeckte, dass man ja etwas sehr Smoothes bekommen hat. Das war ja das Geschäftsmodell von James Last. Und ja, das war auch damals erfolgreich. Nur da musste man sich schon immer noch bewusst entscheiden, ich gehe jetzt in den Plattenladen und kaufe mir eine Platte von James Last. Das haben Millionen Menschen getan, ja, aber es war immer noch eine bewusste Entscheidung. Hier aber, wie du das gerade beschreibst, wird das den Leuten ja untergejubelt und sorgt eben dafür, dass die eigentlich originellen Künstler ausgebremst werden, weil man sagt, wir spielen das jetzt mit einer schönen Akustikgitarre nochmal nachlegen, noch irgendeine Streicherklangfläche drüber.
Das war ein Riesestandal bei den Klingeltönen damals, als das so gemacht wurde.
Und das wird aber jetzt gern so angenommen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch das Besondere an diesem Buch, dass man hier und ich muss da kulturpessimistisch werden, dass man hier erlebt, wie diese Plattform die Hörgewohnheiten so radikal ändert, dass die Leute plötzlich glauben, das ist jetzt Musik und es gibt gar keinen Unterschied mehr. Es gibt schon irgendwo bei Adorno mal so eine Stelle zu lesen, wo er sagt, es gibt gewisse Akkorde, die gar nicht mehr gehört werden können. Durch die Kulturindustrie. Und hier kann man es wirklich in aller Deutlichkeit erleben, dass hier eigentlich die Musik völlig entkernt wird und nur noch so eine funktionale Seite haben soll. Und dass man ja auch selbst zum Teil in der Branche davon spricht, man komponiert Musik, die Epidemic ist, also die epidemisch ist.
Ja, ich hätte mich gefreut, wenn sich hier Podcast nochmal, da ist jetzt ein sehr particularistisches Interesse, weil wir selber Podcasts machen und so und viel Podcasts hören, aber wir haben ja bei Podcast diesen Shift festgestellt, dass Netflix originale wollte.
Ja.
Also nicht mehr Kataloge kaufen für teuer Geld, sondern wir stellen jetzt selber her. Wir bei Netflix auch oder bei Amazon damals, also die ersten Serien selber hergestellt wurden. Und wir wissen ja, was Spotify das wert war. Also Joe Rogan für 100 Millionen oder sowas. Weil wahrscheinlich hätte man ein Argument machen können, mir gegenüber, indem man so schreibt, du hörst so nicht Musik, aber es ist trotzdem ein Problem für die nachziehenden Generationen, dem man, wie sie schreibt, Jazz nicht mehr erklären kann, wenn man einfach Jazz nur aus der Soft Jazz in the Background Playlist kennt. Aber so wichtig, wie es Spotify war, für 100 Millionen einen YouTuber, einen Podcaster zu kaufen, so wichtig ist denen auch der Shift in der Musik. Also da gab es die gleichen Investitionen, in diesem Maße so einen eigenen Katalog herzustellen. Wie nennt sie es? Playlist, Streambait zu machen. Also nicht Clickbait im Journalismus, sondern Streambait, also dieses Wort da zu benutzen. Oder eben so einen radikalen Playlist-First-Ansatz zu fahren. Es geht hier um die Playlist Adaptability, also die Passgenauigkeit in die Playlist. Man hat schon eine Playlist und man braucht eine Musik, die da passt und alles muss dem untergeordnet werden.
Um das mal gerade zu sagen, weil ich kürzlich mit einer Dame da ein Gespräch zu hatten, war ganz verwundert, dass sie das nicht wusste, aber wahrscheinlich ist das gar nicht so weit hin bekannt. Podcaster, wenn sie nicht einen Exklusivvertrag von Spotify haben, erhalten natürlich von der Plattform gar nichts. Manche hatten nämlich gedacht, es war in diesem Gespräch so, es waren Hörer unseres Podcasts, sie sagten, ja und was bekommt ihr von Spotify? Ich sagte, ja von Spotify bekommen wir gar nichts. Das heißt, diesen Deal hat es nie gegeben. Also man hat dadurch, dass die Podcast alle vereinzelt waren, natürlich nicht fünf Labels gehabt, die sagen, also wenn ihr hier Podcast spielen wollt, da brauchen wir aber 70 Prozent von. Nein, das hat es nicht gegeben und deswegen sind alle Podcasts bei Spotify, die man hört, frei und niemand bekommt da Geld, außer die Leute, die exklusiv bei Spotify unter Vertrag sind, jetzt wie Böhmermann zum Beispiel, der bekommt natürlich sofort von Spotify Geld, aber nicht von den Hörern.
Genau und das Kalkül ist einfach, die Leute wollen Böhmermann hören, also schalten sie da ein und Spotify ist das was wert und dann hören sie halt auch alles andere darüber. Also dieser Algo-Trade, der da gemacht wird mit wir bevorzugen dich auf unserer Plattform und zahlen dir dafür weniger Tadjim ist für die Podcaster einfach, du kannst überhaupt bei uns präsent sein und wir zahlen dir dafür gar nichts. So, aber es trifft eben auf eine Welt, in der die Hälfte aller Podcasts über Spotify gehört haben. Also wer damit nicht einverstanden ist und ich bin ja der Meinung, okay, wir geben unsere Podcasts ja eh kostenlos raus. Also ist der Player so ein bisschen egal. Ja, ja, das wird natürlich dann ausgenutzt von Spotify, um die Plattform kontraktiv zu machen.
Ob so ein Schritt auch möglich wäre irgendwann in Zukunft, dass Spotify sagt, wir sind so wichtig als Podcast-Plattform. Das kostet 100 Euro, wenn ihr bei uns den Podcast spielen wollt.
Na ja, solange man eine Paywall betreibt, also um bei Apple Geld einsammeln zu können, muss man auch in dieses Creator-Programm, das kostet Geld. Also wir zahlen Apple 20 Euro im Jahr oder so, um überhaupt dort eine Paywall betreiben zu können.
Für die sie ja dann auch nochmal 30 Prozent bekommen, für jedes Abo, das da abgeschmissen ist.
Das Business ist schon ganz gut ausgetüftelt von denen, aber Spotify macht es bislang noch nicht.
Wir wollen sie aber auch nicht auf für den bringen.
Spotify wirbt sehr damit, hostet doch bei uns, so dass sie alles unter Dach und Fach haben. Es gibt einen Podcaster, Tim Brittlaff, hier aus unserer deutschen Community, der zum Beispiel seine Podcast nicht bei Spotify vertreibt. Um Tim Brittlaffs Podcast zu hören, muss man in der freien Welt RSS-Feeds, was ja unbedingt zu bevorzugen und auch immer wieder zu Lobreisen ist, dann eine andere App nutzen. Aber ohne weiter darüber nachzudenken, ich will nur auf Play drücken und dann höre ich da meine Musik und auch meine Podcasts, da ist man natürlich sofort im Spotify-Silo und betrifft eben 50 Prozent der Hörerschaft. Also wir sind jetzt auch nicht frei und sagen, wir haben das Buch gelesen, wir sind erschüttert, uns gibt es nicht mehr bei Spotify zu hören.
Nee, das wäre überhaupt nicht denkbar.
Dann hätten wir nur noch halb so viele Hörer, ja.
Und dann gehen wir noch von YouTube weg.
Wobei, YouTube, das will ich noch mal sagen, YouTube leistet wirklich was, denn eine 5-Stunden-Video-Datei ist groß. Also die kostet im Vertrieb wirklich, dafür muss ein LKW fahren durchs Internet. Der Autodatei nicht so sehr. Die kriegt man auch so gehostet für 20 Euro. Aber Spotify, YouTube nimmt uns schon, wenn man das jetzt mal mit so regulären Content-Delivery-Networks und deren Pricing, also die entlasten schon unsere Hörerschafter von tausender Euro mobilisieren zu müssen, damit wir überhaupt im Video zu sehen sind.
Du hast schon Streambait angesprochen, Streambait Pop wird wichtig. Und da muss man erstmal sagen, 2013 wird Spotify for Artists eingerichtet. Das ist dann ein Tool, das den Künstlern die Möglichkeit gibt, genauere Daten zu analysieren über ihre Hörer. Wo werden sie gehört? Wie viel werden sie gehört? Es ist aber auch zugleich ein Nudging, das da betrieben wird. Nämlich die Musiker sollen sich eigentlich dieser algorithmischen Gewalt, wie ich das mal genannt habe, fügen. Zum Beispiel wird ihnen dann gezeigt, dass ihr Song ausgespielt wird in einer Hip-Hop-Playlist. Da wird er einsortiert. Dann hat man aber selbst gar nicht Hip-Hop komponiert, sondern eine Polka und wird dabei jetzt einfach dahinsortiert und suggeriert wird einem dann, willst du nicht vielleicht lieber Hip-Hop machen? Du bist eher, so sehen wir das, ein Hip-Hop-Künstler.
Deine Acoustic-ness, Danceability, Instrumentell-ness, Lautness, Mood und Valenz und Energy weist er so auf Hip-Hop hin.
Ja.
Das wäre so die Botschaft. Das ist ganz interessant, weil in dieser Etappe des Textes wird auch darauf hingewiesen, dass vor der Playlist jetzt der Kandidatenpool entsteht. Das ist ein bisschen wie, Herr Schulz, Ihr Buch liegt ganz gut. Es ist nämlich, sagen wir mal, bestsellerliste Platz 23. Das heißt, noch nicht gedruckt in der Top 20 bestsellerliste des Spiegel. Wenn jetzt aber der Verlag entsprechende Werbung macht und es ordentlich platziert, dann haben sie jetzt die Chance, da hoch zu rutschen. Und so ist das hier auch. Du kriegst halt diese Ansprache wie auch bei Kindlebüchern, wenn du bei Amazon vertreibst und dann erfährst du nicht nur, wo haben die Leute besonders viel angestrichen? Das kriegt jeder Leser, dass man so die, was haben eigentlich die anderen Leser toll gefunden, sondern auch der Hinweis, ab Seite 17 haben die Leute das Buch nicht weitergelesen. Was hast du da geschrieben? Denk nochmal drüber nach beim nächsten Mal und so, ob so ein Plot-Twist da wirklich sein muss und so. Also da wird dann schon eingegriffen.
Und da glaubt man, dass über Daten alles zu klären ist. Also das ist natürlich diese alte Silicon Valley Logik, dass die Daten über alles einem Aufschluss geben und dass man sich danach richten muss. Hinzu kommt auch, dass man dazu übergeht, dass also die Songs zählen, wenn sie 30 Sekunden gespielt werden. Das bedeutet auch, dass die Künstlerinnen und Künstler denken über eure Intros nach, dass die auf jeden Fall den Menschen 30 Minuten bei der Stange halten. Heißt, es wäre doch gut, wenn der Refrain schon mal direkt am Anfang des Songs erklingt. Lasst euch nicht zu viel Zeit mit einer Exposition in den Song, sondern es muss gleich so sein, dass alle dabei sind. Und es entsteht dann auch so eine Musik, die, ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das beschreiben soll, so einen lockeren Beat hat, so ein bisschen wabert. Und als zwei Beispiele, die genannt werden, lesen wir Khalid, ich weiß nicht, ob du den kanntest, mit dem Song Location und Billie Eilish mit Ocean Eyes. Und das finde ich schon interessant, wie jetzt Billie Eilish uns in den Föjetons immer so als die handgemachte Künstlerin verkauft wurde, die mit ihrem Bruder zusammen unter der Bettdecke ein Lied komponiert und einsinkt. Und jetzt aber sehen wir hier, ne, das ist eine krasse Optimierung, die stattfindet, die dazu eben dient, bei Spotify erfolgreich zu sein. Und Khalid und Billie Eilish haben ja dann auch ein Lied zusammen gemacht. Also wir sind hier wirklich bei, an dem Ort, wo man sagen kann, jetzt entsteht nicht ein Song, der bei Spotify gespielt wird, sondern jetzt entsteht der Spotify Song.
Ja, das finde ich alles sehr wichtig und so weiter, aber ich muss hier trotzdem...
Du willst das Billie Eilish verteidigen?
Ja, ganz kurz nur, weil...
Ich höre es ja gar nicht. Ich habe da jetzt mal diese beiden Songs mir angehört, Location und Ocean Eyes, und es ist grauenhaft. Es ist einfach musikalisches Blabla. Oh Gott, jetzt kriegen wir wieder E-Mails.
Ja, genau, du kriegst jetzt E-Mails. Für mich ist ja so ein bisschen entscheidend, wie gehen meine Kinder zu Hause ab, wenn sie Musik hören, unabhängig davon, dass es Kriterien dafür gibt, natürlich das limbische System von 8-Jährigen schneller zu erreichen und so weiter. Aber ich finde, wir haben es hier nochmal mit kleinen Unterschieden zu so einem Phänomen wie MrBeast zu tun auf YouTube, der sich nun wirklich ganz genau angeschaut hat, wie der Algorithmus funktioniert und ist komplett darauf. Und dann auch gar keine Inhalte, nichts. Das Video darf nur 7 Minuten sein, du musst so und so viel Geld verbraten und so weiter und so fort. Also davon sind wir schon noch weg, denn es geht trotz allem immer noch um Musik. Und über Musik entscheiden letztlich in dem Moment, wo man bewusst dazuhört, doch andere als nur die Anbieter.
Also es muss schon eine Gewöhnung an Sounds da sein. Also das ist ja Gewöhnungseffekten ausgesetzt.
Ja, aber wir gehen nicht ins Konzert und hören dort Fahrstuhlmusik.
Nee, das machen wir nicht. Aber dass wir gewisse Musik überhaupt attraktiv finden, dass Leute sagen, das klingt aber komisch und man sagt, nee, das sind einfach echte Instrumente, die da klingen. Es ist mal nicht irgendwas generisch Erstelltes.
Das ist die Essen ohne Zucker und Salz.
Das ist ja was mit Gewöhnung zu tun hat. Deswegen haben ja auch unterschiedliche Kulturkreise, unterschiedliche Volksmusiken, die gehen denen, weiß ich nicht, in Korea oder in Südafrika genauso sofort ins Ohr hinein. Für uns sind das Klänge, die eher merkwürdig erscheinen, rätselhaft erscheinen, während die natürlich auch rätselhaft vor unseren Volksliegern stehen würden. Und genau das bedeutet ja einfach eine kulturelle Gewöhnung. Und eine kulturelle Gewöhnung findet dann auch über zum Beispiel Spotify statt. Wenn nämlich die sagen, die Musik heute, um erfolgreich zu sein, muss so und so klingen, dann wird vorwiegend Musik so komponiert, dass sie so klingt wie Billie Eilish. Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht, dass ich sage, Billie Eilish ist schuld an allem, sondern ich sage nur, also was uns hier als so originell verkauft wurde, ist es irgendwie gar nicht. Da steht ja dann bei Liz Pelly, zum Zeitpunkt des Börsengangs von Spotify im Jahr 2018 schien die Ära der Spitzenplaylist eine ganz eigene Ästhetik hervorgebracht zu haben. In diesem Jahr erzählte mir ein Pop-Songwriter und Produzent, dass Eilish zu einer Art Aushängeschild für das geworden sei, was als Spotify-Sound bezeichnet wurde. Eine Flut von plattformoptimiertem Pop, der gedämpft, im mittleren Tempo und melancholisch war. Er sagte mir, dass es für ihn normal geworden sei, in eine Session zu gehen und jemandem sagen zu hören, dass er einen Spotify-Song schreiben wolle, um ihn Künstlern vorzustellen.
Zitat Ich war definitiv schon in Situationen, in denen Leute sagten, lass uns einen dieser traurigen Mädchen Spotify-Songs machen. Man gibt sich das als Ziel vor. Es hat dieses weiche, gefühlstuselige, niedliche etwas. Heutzutage ist es oft sehr minimalistisch und basiert auf einer nur einfachen Strophe mit ein paar Elementen. Oft ein Schnappschuss in den Strophen und dann, also so ein Snapshot, dann werden in den Refrain manchmal Stimm-Samples verwendet. Es ist normalerweise eine Art Emolyrik. Und das ist dann, was der Pop-Kritiker der New York Times, Spotify-Core, auch nennt. Also das heißt, man hat so eine Musik, die dann auch nahtlos übergeht von einem ins andere. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist schon etwas, was wahnsinnig unsere Pop-Kultur bestimmt. Und ich wage mich so weit aus dem Fenster zu sagen, es hat sie nicht bereichert.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt. Aber wie die Eilish auf der einen Seite, Boomi auf der anderen Seite, ein KI-Startup, das zwischenzeitlich von Spotify auch mal gesperrt wurde, nachdem 14,5 Millionen Songs auf der Plattform veröffentlicht wurden, die alle nach diesen Kriterien hergestellt wurden.
Und zwar künstlich, ja.
Nur künstlich, also die Masse alleine sagt es ja schon. Es handelt sich um 14 Prozent der weltweit aufgenommenen Musik. So, also es gibt eine Spannbreite.
Ja, ja, sicherlich. Also Billie Eilish ist eine größere Künstlerin als jetzt das, was da sonst so per KI generiert wird. Das will ich auch gar nicht sagen. Ich finde nur interessant, wie allein eine Plattform dafür sorgen kann, dass es einen flächendeckenden Trend gibt. Weil wenn man jetzt sagen würde, ja, Billie Eilish hat das jetzt angepasst, okay, aber die Sache ist ja einfach, es entstehen dann hunderttausende Titel, die in diese Richtung gehen. Und es gibt ja dann solche Effekte, die dafür sorgen, dass das eine das andere anstößt, immer mehr, immer mehr. Das heißt also, diese Art von Musik, die dann vom Algorithmus präferiert wird, die in die Playlisten wandert, wird dann auch immer nochmal weiter abgeschliffen. Also man würde ja vor ein paar Jahren gesagt haben, wenn du dich jetzt mit Leuten, ich kenne ja ein paar aus der Indie-Musik unterhältst, wenn die Ed Sheeran hören, dann rumpfen die die Nase. So, dann sagen die, das ist ja sehr gefällig und so weiter. Jetzt geht das noch einen Schritt weiter, wie wir hören bei Spotify. Jetzt ist Ed Sheeran eigentlich schon irgendwie doch zu kantig. Jetzt lass uns das doch mal ohne den Gesang von Ed Sheeran, nur die Melodie und nochmal so ein bisschen durch den Booster gemacht, damit es noch glatter als glatt klingt. Also wir sehen, dass selbst das, was schon eigentlich optimiert ist für eine Popmusikkarriere noch zu rau ist und das muss noch mal geschmürgelt werden.
Das stimmt schon, das stimmt schon. Und Dreh- und Angelpunkt von einem ist natürlich diese Vergütung, über die wir gleich sprechen. Vorher aber hat sie einen Kapitel zum Überwachungskapitalismus. Sie nennt das einfach Streaming as Surveillance. Das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, weil hier plötzlich die Wrapped-Kampagne als Hypernormalisierung des natürlich wissen wir, was du am 23. Januar um 17 Uhr gemacht hast, nämlich dieses und jenes Lied gehört. Und daran abhängig machen wir auch in welcher Stimmung warst du da, was hast du da getan. Denn Spotify verkauft natürlich solche Informationen. Also sowohl was hat man gehört, ist ja eh einsehbar, aber auch wie ist das im Verhältnis zu dem anderen Verhalten, dass man ansonsten so zeigt, war das gerade eine traurige Phase im Leben oder wie auch immer. Also man hat so Verhaltensdaten, die als Datenschatz natürlich weit rumgereicht werden. Also Spotify arbeitet hier zusammen mit Facebook, Uber, Tesla, Tinder, Virgin Airlines und so. Es gibt große Kooperationen. Und auch 23andMe, also selbst eine Genanalyse, es gab diesen riesigen Skandal und so. Überschick uns mal dein Blut und wir sagen dir, welche Gene. Und dann stimmte das aber alles nicht und war sozusagen alles erstaunlich monologen. Fake it till you make it.
Und Daniel Eck selbst ist nochmal mit 100 Millionen Euro in das deutsche Rüstungsunternehmen Helsing investiert, das Live-Tracking macht, das anbietet Assist Battlefield Operations. Also das heißt, dieses Tracking, die Ausnutzung von Daten, alles zu wissen, zu überwachen und daraus Profit zu ziehen, geht also weit über Spotify hinaus.
Ja, dann wird die EU-Datenschutzverordnung scharf geschaltet und Max Schrems über Not in your backyard, also Neub, also der österreichische Land, den wir da schon schätzen und der immer diese Anfragen stellt, die juristische Streite führt, fragt er danach, könnt ihr uns alle mal diese Daten schicken, die ihr so über uns habt und er bekommt quasi nur so ein paar Playlists oder sowas zugeschickt. Wo völlig klar ist, sorry, anscheinend habt ihr ja gar kein richtiges Protokoll darüber geführt und wisst gar nicht, nachdem ihr juristisch so hart dabei war, diese ganzen Labels und so weiter, alle unter Dach und Fach zu kriegen, ist die Beziehung zum Kunden so ein bisschen halb gar. Spotify musste dann auch fünf Millionen Strafe zahlen und hat dann Jahre später tatsächlich mal so einen Datensatz geschickt, wie er aussehen sollte. Also da sieht man wieder, das ist diese Arroganz dieser Leute, die einfach so.
Ja, vielleicht auch ganz kurz bevor wir zu dieser Monetarisierung kommen, noch mal zu dieser Bumi-Geschichte, die du eben angesprochen hast. Bumi wurde dann damals gebannt, nicht deshalb, weil die künstlich Musik produziert haben in rauen Mengen. Also nicht, weil die 14 Millionen Titel oder was produziert haben, sondern die wurden einzig dafür gebannt, dass ich herausstellte, dass sie auch noch Serverfarmen betrieben haben, die unaufhörlich diese Lieder gestreamt haben bei Spotify. Das war der Grund, warum Spotify sagt, so geht es jetzt nicht. Aber dass das alles künstlich produziert wird und alles platt macht, das war für Spotify gar nicht das Problem. Es sollten nur nicht Serverfarmen da noch mit beteiligt sein.
Das sind wie die Entdeckungen, dass die ganzen Werbung, die Google so anzeigt, gar niemand sieht, außer irgendwelche Bangladesch-Keller-Menschen, die einfach die ganze Zeit durch Seiten scrollen und Werbe aufzuprobieren.
Denn für Spotify war das ein guter Deal. Offenbar erhielt Bumi nur 20 Prozent. Das ist ja nicht viel.
Das ist eine Skalierungsfrage am Ende.
Das ist eine Skalierungsfrage. Und da kann man also sehen, Spotify ist wirklich eine Plattform gegen die Musiker. Man kann das gar nicht anders sagen. Jetzt werden Leute sagen, ja, aber ich höre doch gerne Spotify. Also wenn man jetzt so über Dinge nachdenkt, was könnte man tun, würde ich sagen, ja, hin und wieder mal eine CD kaufen. Wäre schon ganz hilfreich von den Künstlern, die man mag. Bei den anderen weiß man nicht, ob sie es auch verdient haben, also die diesen Hyperpop dort kreieren. Ich habe da mal geguckt, es gibt tatsächlich zahllose Videos bei YouTube, in denen dir erklärt wird, wie du ein Hyperpop-Song einfach produzieren kannst. Und da sind wir ja auch wieder so KSI und Oliver Tree, wenn man sich da mal anhört, was das für Musik ist. Oder auch, ich mache mich noch einmal unbeliebt, die allseits Geliebte, auch Kamila Harris Fan, Charlie XCX, ja, auch das ist so Hyperpop-Musik.
Ja, ja.
Also ja, vielleicht doch mal, doch mal Ich kenne nicht alle, immer nur die Oper geht. Nein, nee, nee, ich sage jetzt bewusst mal oder vielleicht doch mal einen Rock-Song aus den 70er-Jahren hören, wäre das vielleicht mal wieder eine Möglichkeit.
Okay.
Oder es gibt ja beziehungsweise gibt es ja aktuelle Künstler, die nicht so sind und die sind ja so unsichtbar geworden durch diese Plattform. Und ich glaube, darum muss es gehen, diese wieder in den Mittelpunkt zu haben.
Soll ich da einen Künstler nennen, der seine Musik ganz in den Dienst von Kunst stellt und sie sehr erfolgreich live produziert wird, das glaube ich gar nicht. Und einen ganz tollen, bewegenden Film darüber gemacht hat Hans Zimmer.
Aber der ist ja auch eher ein... Also da müsste man mal nochmal so reingehen, inwieweit Hans Zimmer mit seinem Unternehmen, nicht mit seinen eigenen Kompositionen dafür filme, wie der mit seinem Unternehmen vielleicht auch solche Klangflächen herstellt, die nutzbar sind für solche Plattformen. Also ich glaube, der ist nicht das beste Beispiel. Wenn du jetzt John Williams gesagt hättest, dann würde ich noch sagen, ja klar, der komponiert ja noch normal.
Also Hans Zimmer ist ja auch dafür berühmt, diese ganzen Kataloge an Musikinstrumenten, jedes Schlagwerk der Welt und so, alle mal ordentlich gesampelt zu haben.
Naja eben.
Und daraus kann man natürlich Klangteppiche machen.
Ein gutes Beispiel.
Es ist einfach fanflos. Also dieser Film ist so gut.
Kein gutes Beispiel.
So Vergütung. Ja, statt einen einzigen riesigen Topf aufzustellen, hat man, Zitat, hunderte Millionen Mini-Töpfe. Ja, und das finde ich skandalös. Also hier einfach bei jedem zu gucken. Das ist ja so, als würde so eine Gewerkschaft Verdi gar keinen großen Tarifvertrag mehr machen, sondern im öffentlichen Dienst ab sofort. Es wird nach Performance geschaut und so. Und dann kriegt jeder in der Behörde, der eigentlich alle dasselbe macht, so ne? Jeder kriegt genau seinen individuellen Arbeitsvertrag, je nachdem, wie man im letzten Jahr performt hat.
Und so ist das mit den Künstlern.
So ist das in der Musikindustrie.
Ja, und keiner weiß was genau. Also es ist auch interessant.
Keiner weiß vom anderen. Alles NDA, alles ist geheim.
Niemand kann sagen, ja, weil ich bekomme einen höheren Anteil oder so. Das ist doch erstaunlich, ne?
Also im Großen und Ganzen hat man ein Net Revenue und da wird dann mit den Shares und Pro Rata, Pro Rata ist zu abstrakt, schreibt sie. Pro Rata war nur der einfachste Weg und die ursprünglichen Majors und Merlin, also ja, man hat so verschiedene Sachen da in so eine Rechnung reingebaut und nun wird der Netto Betrag gedrittelt zwischen Spotify, den Inhabern der Aufnahmerechte und den Inhabern der Verlagsrechte. Ja. Und jeder für sich. Also pro Lied sogar mehrere Verträge, je nachdem, wer hat denn da die Technik, das Studio und so weiter, wer hat das Lied geschrieben und so, also in diesem Maße, wie es schon immer. Das ist ja generell so. Genau, aber hier einfach pro.
Und dann haben die Künstler diese Möglichkeiten, ihre Position zu optimieren, indem sie dann noch auf entsprechende Anteile verzichten. Damit bezahlen sie dann dafür, dass sie quasi beworben werden.
Reichweite gegen Einkommen, genau. Und dann wird man groß eingeteilt Tier Zero, One, Two, Three. Je nachdem, welchen Schwellenwert man gerade überschreitet, gehört man zu denjenigen, die Superstars, fünf Millionen Dollar Jahreseinkommen oder nicht. Und um die, das ist ja wie im Supermarkt, also die Milka-Schokolade ist halt ein Must-Have. Die Leute gehen nicht mehr in diesen Supermarkt, wenn es da keine Milka-Schokolade gibt oder so. Und also werden die einfach bevorzugt. Wir werden besser Regal platziert. Dann wird nochmal ein Bild aufgehangen, dass es hier auch Milka gibt und so. Und so ist das hier auch. Also wenn man einfach nur unten im Regal drin liegt und ab und zu mal klickt jemand auf Play, dann ist man einfach Tier Drei und dann spielt man gar keine Rolle.
Interessant ist auch, was sie hier zitiert von Daniel Eck, der sagt 2020. Einige Arten, die in der Vergangenheit gut gingen, können nicht so gut in dieser Zukunftslandscape gehen, wo du nicht einmal Musik rekordieren kannst, jedes Jahr drei oder vier Jahre, und denkst, das wird genug sein. Die Arten heute, die es machen, realisieren, dass es um das Fortbinden und das kontinuierliche Engagement mit ihren Fans geht. Es geht darum, die Arbeit inzulegen, um die Storytelling rund ums Album zu machen und um einen kontinuierlichen Dialog mit deinen Fans zu halten. Das heißt, der Künstler muss jetzt in Dauerkommunikation, wie ein Influencer, mit seiner Community interagieren, muss permanent neuen Inhalt liefern. Das heißt, das, was eigentlich ja Künstler ausmacht, dass sie sich zurückziehen, darauf besinnen wieder, worauf es ankommt, daraus aus dieser Stimmung etwas komponieren, einspielen, veröffentlichen. Das ist ein Rhythmus, den Daniel Eck gar nicht mehr will. Das ist ja auch nichts für seine Plattform, was interessant ist, sondern man soll eigentlich die permanente Partizipation des Künstlers haben, was natürlich bedeutet, der Künstler ist dann getrieben von dieser Plattform und kommt gar nicht mehr dazu, eigentlich Kunst zu machen.
Ja, das ist alles nicht gut. Man kennt das aus, aus vielen Branchen.
Und man hat ja dann auch ein interessantes Beispiel von jemandem, der eigentlich es richtig gemacht hat. Da ist die Rede in dem Kapitel Indie Vibes von Lance Allen. Lance Allen schaut sich Playlists an und denkt, Mensch, das ist doch eigentlich eine gute Richtung. Allen beschreibt, wie er die Künstler, die bereits auf Peaceful Guitar, so heißt dann eine Playlist, vertreten waren, ausfindig machte, nachschaute, in welchen Benutzer generierten Wiedergabelisten sie zu finden waren und diese Kuratoren davon überzeugte, seine Musik in das Empfehlungssystem aufzunehmen. Dann sagt dieser Lance Allen, ich habe sogar meine eigene Wiedergabeliste mit denselben Künstlern erstellt und damit begonnen, sie auf Instagram zu vermarkten, weil dort viele Spotify-Nutzer unterwegs sind, erklärt er in einem Blogbeitrag. Die Kosten für die Social-Media-Anzeigen bezahlt er aus eigener Tasche. Seine täglichen Bemühungen zahlten sich im Juni 2017 aus, als er zu Peaceful Guitar hinzugefügt wurde. Danach tauchte er in vielen anderen redaktionellen Playlists auf und erreichte Millionen von Streams. Als er erkannte, dass es Potenzial für Playlists gab, indem er instrumentale Pop-Cover-Versionen oder alternative Versionen von Songs aufnahm, die auf unterschiedlichen Stimmungen ausgerichtet waren, begann er auch damit, diese aufzunehmen. Er wurde dann auch Teil einer Kampagne von Spotify und sagt, seht her, hier ist jemand, hat in der Provinz gelebt mit seiner Gitarre und hat da ein großes Unternehmen, beziehungsweise hat jetzt eine tolle Selbstständigkeit, kann seine Familie ernähren. Es gab dann dafür auch wieder sowas, Aval Artists Without Label, das wurde dann von Sony später gekauft für 430 Millionen. Und das ist so eine Erfolgsgeschichte, die dann von Spotify natürlich groß gemacht wurde. Liz Pelly fragt sich im Jahr 23 im Dezember, was eigentlich aus diesem Lance Allen geworden ist, guckt nach und was liest sie auf Twitter von ihm? Er habe jetzt ständig veröffentlicht, er hat Werbung gebucht und trotzdem hat er keinen Erfolg mehr. Er hat festgestellt, er wurde jetzt durch Stock-Music, also durch künstlich generierte Musik ersetzt und jetzt taucht er in diesen Playlisten plötzlich nicht mehr auf.
Diese KI-Wende findet punktuell immer wieder statt, aber ich glaube, da steht ein ganz großer Sturm bevor. Wenn das so stimmt, wie ich es ja jetzt gelesen habe, aber es ist in meinem Nutzungsverhalten, wie sehr dieses stimmungsgetriebene Drück-Play, lass einfach laufen. Ich springe ja nun in meiner Playlist jede Stunde mindestens einmal zurück an den Anfang und höre es nochmal. Das ist ganz anderes Nutzungsverhalten. Dann ist das ja sozusagen dem Frase der KI-Wölfe hingeworfen. Und in dieser Geheimnistruktur.
Wir haben das doch auch bei YouTube schon gesehen. Also wenn man sich bei YouTube ansieht, wie KI dominiert das inzwischen ist. Ich habe dir kürzlich ein Video geschickt, ganz viele Shorts bei YouTube von einer Seife mit einem Gesicht, so ein Comic, das wie so ein Daumenkino funktioniert. Ich glaube, Barry the Soap oder so heißt das. Kann man mal bei YouTube googeln. Millionenfach geklickt, künstlich generiert, mit Chachi Petit oder weiß ich nicht was, und wird dort rauf und runter gespielt. Man muss doch nur mal gucken, wie hoch die Aufrufe auch bei YouTube zum Beispiel sind, von KI generierten Remixes von bekannten Songs. Und auch da frage ich mich, wenn ich hier so lese oder von dir höre, dass jetzt diese KI generierten Sachen von Spotify einfach so in die Playlist kommen. Ich habe jetzt schon mehrmals Songs gegoogelt, bei YouTube eingegeben, und dann kam gleich, noch nicht an erster Stelle, aber doch an dritter, vierter Stelle, irgendein KI Remix auch mit entsprechend hohen Aufrufzahlen. Und da kann man einfach sehen, wie jetzt gerade alles, was menschlich produziert wird, verdrängt wird durch diesen KI Content.
Ja, das ist wirklich crazy. In dieser Gehaltsauflistung hier, das ist ja dann der Tier-3-Typ. Also namentlich unbekannt, aber spielt so irgendwie, dass man es gerne hört. Liegt typischerweise zwischen 5.000 und 50.000 Dollar. Und typisch für so ein Tier-3-Artist, was auch die Schwelle ist für, damit kann man sein Lebensunterhalt beschreiben, ist ein Durchschnittseinkommen von 13.500 Dollar im Jahr mit der Kunst.
Ja.
Also damit wird es zum Hobby. Und am Anfang begann ja das Buch mit, es gibt diese Indie-Szene, sie ist von den Majors mit Absicht entkoppelt. Leute, die sowas hören wollen, davor gelieben haben, wissen, wohin sie gehen müssen. Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Also man weiß nicht mehr, wo man hingehen soll. Weder gibt es das im Lokalen, noch findet man jetzt irgendwie eine außer Bandcamp oder so. Aber da war jetzt auch keine Entwicklung der letzten Jahre irgendwie. Jedenfalls nichts, was ich mitbekommen habe. Sondern hier wird jetzt einfach großspurig aussortiert. Zuerst wurden die alle in Spotify importiert, und jetzt werden sie alle in so einem KI-Rutsch einmal wieder aussortiert. Also wirklich dramatisch, dass sich hier dieses Kapitel als 16. zu Payola nochmal anführt, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht platziert. Sondern das sind diese Bestechungsgelder, die man da für Radios früher, und dann gab es diese großen Payola Hearings, woraufhin man dann sagt, okay, wir müssen das jetzt mal neu strukturieren, hier gibt es jetzt Regeln. Man kann sich nicht einfach eine Reichweite erkaufen, indem man den Transporteur, das Radio sagt, okay, dann verwende es kostenlos. Das sind halt alle die Versuche, die es mal so gab. Im Grunde ist das dieser Hinweis darauf, dieser Appell, dass man jetzt mal wieder ein politisches Hearing, aber wir wissen ja gerade, womit sich Senate und so beschäftigen in Amerika und was da Konkresse abzieht, also da ist nichts zu erwarten. Wie immer, und sie kommt dann trotzdem auf so ein paar Gesetzentwürfe zu sprechen, März 2024, der Living Wage for Musicians Act ist natürlich nur ein Gesetzesentwurf, aber innertlich ganz interessant, denn man hat einfach eine Obergrenze eingeführt. Man kann pro Monat, pro Titel eine Million Streams erreichen, alles darüber hinaus fließt wieder in den Topf, der für alle ist. Also es gibt einfach eine Obergrenze beim Einkommen. Es wäre natürlich cool, wenn wir grundsätzlich schon mal Obergrenzen beim Einkommen hätten, sodass man sagt, in der Kunst erst recht, dass jetzt die Kunst wieder damit anfangen soll, solche wichtigen Zäsuren einzuziehen.
Ja, die Kunst ist ja eine besondere Form der Arbeit, weil man natürlich sagen kann, na ja, wenn die Leute alle lieber Taylor Swift Songs hören, dann kommt da auch das Geld an. Ja, also das ist, glaube ich, erst mal logisch, das so anders zu verteilen. Ich glaube, es ist eher das Problem, dass es so eine Infrastruktur als die einzige Möglichkeit momentan für Musiker gibt. Also dass man es einfach mit einem Markt zu tun hat, den man nicht umgehen kann, weil man sich sonst vollkommen ruiniert. Dass es ja vorher auch eine große Ungerechtigkeit in der Musik gab, ist völlig klar. Es gibt eben die wenigen, die Millionen Platten verkaufen und die anderen nicht. Und so ist das auch in der bildenden Kunst.
Aber es gab immer diese Querfinanzierung im Buchmarkt.
Und das ist eben nicht mehr da. Und hinzu kommt, dass die Leute, die Kapital in der Hand haben, dort alles andere verdrängen können. Nämlich man hat ja dann eingeführt 2023 so ein Campaign-Kit, das man kaufen kann als Künstler. Da ist dann alles Mögliche dabei. Also wo man in Playlisten auftaucht und wie man noch besser Daten auslesen kann. Also es ist so ein kleiner Instrumentenkasten, mit dem man sich nach vorne spielen kann. Das bedeutet aber, dass man natürlich Geld in die Hand nehmen muss, um überhaupt auf dieser Plattform eine Sichtbarkeit zu erreichen, um dann auf der Plattform Geld zu verdienen. Ich habe hier mal vor ein paar Monaten doch diese, es war nicht im Salon, es war außerhalb des Salons, habe ich doch mal über diese Minenarbeiter in Südafrika gesprochen, die dann überteuertes Essen kaufen müssen, das ihnen runtergeliefert wird, weil sie an der Mine sind und nicht rausgehen können. Und wie sie dann immer wieder neue Summen zahlen müssen, um überhaupt dort arbeiten zu können. Und auch um dann ihren Lohn zu bekommen, müssen sie auch schon wieder Geld zahlen. Und im Prinzip ist diese Struktur da aus südafrikanischen Minen, ich will es nicht gleich vergleichen, sondern nur strukturell vergleichen, dass man das findet man jetzt hier bei Spotify wieder. Was auch geholfen hat, war natürlich, dass man es schaffte, politisch gut Einfluss zu nehmen. Sie geht zum Beispiel auch auf die Obama-Playlist ein.
Das zum einen und die Cheflobbyistin für Spotify, Public Affairs Abteilung gibt es natürlich, Dusty Jenkins, Vorher-Mitarbeiterin bei George W. Bush, hat ein Jahresgehalt von 860.000 Dollar. Sie schreibt, es ist nicht verwunderlich, dass die Spitzenleute dieses 67 Milliarden Dollar-Konzerns allesamt Multi-Billionäre sind, dass Daniel Egg sich immer mal wieder so, ah ja, könnte man mal 100 Millionen Dollar auszahlen, auf ein Vermögen von 4 Milliarden kommt. Und damit mehr verdient als alle Künstler auf der Plattform. Also wir haben es hier wieder mit typischen Schieflagen zu tun, die man einfach mal politisch mit einem großen Hammerschlag, weil das ist einfach absurd.
Und ich hatte schon wieder ganz vergessen, dass die Obamas auch kurz einen Exkursivvertrag mit Spotify hatten und dann dieser Renegades-Podcast mit Prue Springs, das ja auch ein Spotify-Podcast war.
Alles so absurd.
Der ja dann auch noch hier groß vom öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen in den Tagesthemen beworben, wo du erinnerst dich, als man da Prue Springs hinzuschaltete. Uwe Uwe, eine Sache noch, auch wieder so typisch für diese Welt. Man spricht viel über Daniel Eck. Es gibt dabei noch den Companion Martin Lorenzen, der es immer vorzog, nicht so sehr in der Öffentlichkeit stattzufinden. Aber sie findet dann einen Artikel über ihn in so einem schwedischen Männermagazin, der 23 erschienen ist. Zum Zeitpunkt der Erstellung dieses Artikels war er 7,7 Milliarden Dollar schwer. Seine Tage verbringt er mit Sport und Mittagessen, mit inspirierenden Menschen, erklärte das Profil. Er ist an einem neuen Parfum-Unternehmen und zusammen mit EGG an einem Start-up im Bereich Gesundheitstechnologie beteiligt, hat aber seit über fünf Jahren nicht mehr aktiv zum Tagesgeschäft von Spotify beigetragen. Als der Journalist fragt, was er mit seinem gesamten Spotify-Vermögen anfangen könnte, war er verwirrt. Ich habe noch keine Antwort, sagte er, aber er fuhr vor zu erzählen, wie viel Geld er in sein eigenes Schlafzimmer investiert hatte, in seine Matratze und die Raumtemperatur. Der Interviewer fragte nach, ob er sich Gedanken darüber gemacht habe, was mit seinem Geld nach seinem Tod geschehen könnte. Seine Antwort? Ich will nicht sterben. Er stellte dann klar, dass er zwar an den Tod glaube, dass er aber unter Anleitung von Langenlebigkeitsexperten, also Langegiveteexperten, leben wolle, bis er 120 Jahre alt sei. Ja, das ist also die, mit solchen Gestalten hat man es da zu tun.
Es ist immer wieder dasselbe.
Es ist so interessant. Es könnte ja auch mal einer dabei sein, der vernünftig ist, oder?
In dieser Cum-Ex-Serie gibt es ja einen Dialog zwischen dem Banker, dem Bösewicht und der Staatsanwältin beim Essen. Sie fragt ihn dann, sie haben wirklich alles durchschaut, was sie hier tun, aber über eine Sache haben sie nie Kenntnis erlangt über sich selber. Und dann kontert er das mit diesem einfachen Bild. Ich habe da in Indien so eine Frau getroffen, die hatte gar nichts und war damit total eine Nonne. Die war ganz glücklich. Sie hatte nämlich nichts. Sie musste sich um nichts kümmern, nicht mal die Klamotten. Selbst sie hat sich noch geteilt. Und er hat sich dann gesagt, ja, das scheint so ein Spektrum zu sein. Entweder man hat nichts und ist deswegen glücklich, oder man hat alles und ist deswegen glücklich. Und er hängt halt irgendwo dazwischen.
Denn alles hat er auch noch nicht erreicht.
Und so geht es den allen. Die hängen irgendwo dazwischen. Und wir sehen ja, selbst wenn du der reichste Mann der Welt bist, du zerstörst dein eigenes Leben, ruinierst deinen Ruf, deine Gesundheit und alles.
Die Kinder wenden sich von dir ab.
Genau, alles zerfliegt dir und so. Also in deren Sicht ist dieses Buch mal wieder ein Hinweis darauf, dass es hier Großes zu klären gibt für diese Leute. Aber es gibt ja auch für uns alle was zu klären. Dieses Abschlusskapitel. Es steht Conclusion drüber und ich frag mich, wieso? Also warum ist das ein Conclusion und so? Aber sie kommt ja nicht zurück auf irgendwie, ich fasse jetzt nochmal zusammen was und so weiter. Sondern sie macht ein ganz neues Kapitel auf zu einem ganz wichtigen Thema, dass man genauso gut als, also ein bisschen wie bei der Alten Republik, Stefan, diese letzten 20 Seiten zur Familie, das war doch toll. Und alle reden nur über den Schluss des Buches, nicht so, ja okay, dann schreibe ich halt nochmal Buch. Also ich warte jetzt eigentlich auf das Buch von Liz Pelly zum Thema Bibliotheken. Denn die Bibliothek, ich war ja gestern auch wieder an einer in der Stadt Bibliothek in Karlsruhe, hab die dann auch nochmal gefragt, sehr interessante Räumlichkeit hier, so großräumig. Also das ganze Gebäude war sozusagen ein Open Space und nur durch Säulen, die es halt tragen und verteilt. Und dadurch konnte da einfach in Windeseile aus der typischen, heute sitzen da wieder 30, 40 Leute, die sich halt in der Bibliothek treffen und einen Kaffee trinken. War halt gestern einfach Reihenbestuhlung und fünf Minuten später war es wieder Tisch. So, es ging einfach ruck zuck, zwei Leute und so. Es ist alles super. Also es ist einfach so ein öffentlicher Raum, den man von jetzt auf gleich auf alles umbauen kann und so. Und sie dann so, ja, das haben wir in allen Stockwerken. Also alle Stockwerke, Open Space, überall kann man unten kann man quasseln. Und nach oben hin wird es dann leiser. Oben kann man konzentriert seine Hausaufgaben machen, wie auch immer. Und 99 Prozent der Leute haben keinen Plan davon. Hier in Frankfurt, die deutsche Nationalbibliothek oder wie auch immer sie heißt. Ich war noch nie da, erstaunlicherweise. Aber ich habe natürlich die Bilder aus Oslo gesehen, mit der Bibliothek und denke mir, das ist auch eine Reise wert, nur in die Bibliothek dort zu gehen. Also das Bibliotheksthema scheint völlig unterbelichtet zu sein. Kommt hier im Buch vor, sehr spät, nicht zu spät. Aber ich würde sagen, nächstes Buch dann zum Thema Bibliothek, wie man das alles wieder aufziehen kann. Also Open Spaces, Safe Spaces zu schaffen, eine Vergütungsstruktur herzustellen, indem man eine staatliche Anbindung hat, so wie bei uns gestern. Ich kriege einen Honorar, die Leute bezahlen ein bisschen Eintritt, die Stadt ist dabei, es findet etwas statt und so. Also solche Sachen irgendwie. Und sie schreibt ja ganz wunderbar, wie viele Bibliotheken in Amerika einfach da sind, dass sie ein echtes Gegenmodell zu dieser Plattform-Monopol-Sache bilden können, dass diese Bibliotheken natürlich ihren Bücherkatalogen digitalisiert haben. Also man sich einfach die Bücher durch Mitgliedsausweis, Registrierungen auf der Webseite zu Hause anschauen kann. Übrigens auch dieser Hinweis, schaut ruhig mal in eure Bibliothek in eurer Stadt, wahrscheinlich könnt ihr für 10 Euro im Monat einfach alle Magazine und den ganzen Sternen und den Spiegel und die Welt und was ihr alles lesen wollt einfach zu Hause lesen. Einfach nur durch die Mitgliedschaft in diese Bibliothek. Und Musikstreaming natürlich auch. Diese Bibliotheken haben wir einen Katalog und der steht natürlich auch digital zur Verfügung. Also das scheint mir ein echtes Ding zu sein, weil es auch ein Raum nochmal ist. Also wir haben eine digitale Verfügbarkeit und wir haben vor Ort so ein, da gehen wir jetzt mal hin.
Jetzt haben wir bald, wie es aussieht, einen neuen Kulturminister.
Den Berliner.
Der Berliner nämlich, Doris Jalloh, der durch zwei Dinge bekannt ist. Einmal, dass alles, was pro-palästinensisch ist, nicht stattfinden soll. Und zweitens, alles, was Geld kosten kann, eingespart werden muss. Und das ist also so ein Kürzungsminister, den man jetzt da hat, der mit harter Hand da in Berlin wirklich für eine Katastrophe sorgt. Also man geht ja zum Beispiel bei der komischen Oper auf die Homepage, sucht eine Vorstellung und dann steht da bei manchen Vorstellungen, diese angekündigte Vorstellung findet nicht statt wegen der Kulturkürzungen. Also du siehst da, das ist eigentlich sehr gut dokumentiert, das sollten eigentlich alle so machen. Immer genau hinschreiben, das war Joe Sciallo und die CDU. Und der wird jetzt Kulturminister. Insofern bin ich mal gespannt, wie gut die öffentlichen Räume noch ausgestattet sein werden in Zukunft.
Diese Serie Die Affäre Cum-Ex baut das Jahr, was wir jetzt hier so besprochen haben, in eine interessante Rahmenhandlung ein. Also die Kunst spielt ja da durchweg eine Rolle. Leute haben Abschnitte aus diesem Gusswerk, der die Akustik in der Elphi herstellt, zu Hause in so einem Ding liegen.
Und eine Anlage für paar Millionen.
Genau, diese Anlage, bei der einfach Putzfrauen mal kurz reinhören, wie das denn so klingt, wenn Musik eine Million Euro kostet und so. Also völlig absurd. Vielleicht kriegt man die Milliardäre noch mal darüber irgendwie begeistert. Wir haben es ja mit Kühne in Hamburg mit der Oper jetzt gesehen. Aber auch grundsätzlich, dass das Modell Hamburg einfach zu sagen, alle kürzen, dann machen wir jetzt ein besonders großes italienisches Opernfestival. So, dass man das irgendwie ins Bewusstsein holt. Denn diese Leute, die nicht wissen, wohin mit ihrem Geld, scheinen doch den ein oder anderen Faible dafür zu haben.
Ja, aber das ist wirklich das alte Geld. Das ist ja das Problem. Also hier diese Leute, die wir in diesem Buch vorgestellt bekommen, die interessieren sich ja für gar nichts mehr, außer für Summen, die man noch weiter skalieren kann. Da ist ja nicht mal irgendeine Leidenschaft. Es ist ja nicht mehr, dass man auch nur hört. Und wenn es dann wegen mir Billie Eilish wäre, dass man davon fern ist, bei denen ist ja gar nichts. Also die wollen ja nur noch zahlen.
Ja, stimmt.
Jedenfalls ein Buch, das einen sehr erschüttert und, glaube ich, auch für Leute interessant ist, die im Musikbusiness sind und sich auch vielleicht fragen, warum perform ich nicht so gut auf Spotify. Liz Pelly hat das auch geschrieben. Aber man muss auch dazu sagen, für Leute, die uns jetzt hier zugehört haben, es ist ein sehr, sehr detailliertes Buch. Also man muss sich schon absolut dafür interessieren, um jetzt da ganz einzusteigen, um zu wissen, welcher Algorithmus wurde, wann wie geändert, um zu diesem oder jedem Ergebnis zu kommen.
Ich hätte das auch nicht so in diesen 18 Kapiteln, ich hätte da mehr so einen roten Faden oder zwei gebaut, als jetzt es so...
Wahrscheinlich aufgrund der vielen journalistischen Recherchen, dass das Buch so entstanden ist. Aber die Einblicke sind sehr wertvoll.
Ja, sehr gutes Buch.
Wir haben im Salon der Neuen Zwanziger über Mood Machine, The Rise of Spotify and The Cost of the Perfect Playlist von Liz Pelly gesprochen. Es ist ein Buch, das ganz tief in die Recherche reingeht. Zehn Jahre hat sich die Autorin mit Spotify beschäftigt und sie fragt sich, wie haben sich unsere Hörgewohnheiten geändert. Fundamental, muss man sagen, nach der Lektüre dieses Buches. Es ist erschütternd zu sehen, wie weit es diese Plattform getrieben hat. Erst hat sie die großen Labels, dann die Indie-Künstler angelockt und jetzt werden die Künstler verdrängt durch KI, durch generisch erzeugte Musik. Es ist ein Buch, das erschütternd ist, das aber sehr detailreich uns zeigt, wo die fundamentalen Probleme liegen, wenn plötzlich die Musik keine Rolle mehr spielt, sondern nur noch die Datenzellen und die Quantität alles schlägt und Qualität keine Rolle mehr spielt.
Ja und welchen Ausweg haben wir, wenn zwei Firmenchefs auf 10 Milliarden Privatvermögen kommen und der Durchschnittskünstler, der noch ein bisschen was verdient, 13.000 Dollar im Jahr. Der Ausweg steht in Kapitel 19, das schon nicht mehr nummeriert ist, erstaunlicherweise. Es heißt einfach Conclusio. Und da wird über Bibliotheken gesprochen. Und zwar so, dass wir Liz Pelly, wenn sie hier zuhört, auffordern, das Buch dazu noch mal nachzureichen. Wir brauchen jetzt die positive Seite dessen, was sie hier beschreibt als große Abhandlung und Wiederentdeckung der Bibliothek.
Wir sprechen über deutschsprachige Literatur. Es geht um den neuen Roman von Christian Kracht. Er heißt er.
Und ist er gut?
Nein. Ich bin sehr enttäuscht von diesem Roman. Ich sage jetzt gleich, ich bin kein Christian Kracht-Fan, aber ich schätze einige seiner Bücher durchaus. Es ist also nicht so, dass ich auf Kriegsfuß mit diesem Autor stehe, aber er hatte für mich auch nie die Bedeutung, die er wohl für andere hatte. Ich schätze zum Beispiel seinen Roman Ich werde hier sein im Sonnenschein und im Schatten. Ebenso mochte ich Imperium, habe aber beispielsweise auch schon mit dem sehr parfümierten Roman Die Toten Wenig anfangen können, fand Eurotrash unendlich selbstbezüglich und langweilig als Nabelschau. Er ist aber immer auch bei den schlechteren Werken ein großer Stilist. Und das ist auch hier wieder anzutreffen. Die Frage stellt sich ja bei Er gleich, was bedeutet dieser Titel? Wir denken natürlich an die Luft dabei, aber man könnte natürlich auch an das Musikstück, das Er zum Beispiel von Bach denken. Also diese melodiöse Komposition, die nicht so ganz ein Tanz ist, aber irgendetwas dazwischen ist, ist das vielleicht hier gemeint. Und damit sind wir nur beim allerersten Rätsel. Denn wir haben es hier mit einem enigmatischen Roman zu tun, der so gebaut ist, dass wir uns den Kopf darüber zerbrechen können. Ich würde aber auch behaupten, dass wir damit nicht an ein Ende gelangen. Das spricht nicht gegen den Roman, sondern eigentlich für ihn. Ich halte den Roman aber deshalb unter anderem für misslungen, weil er sich so sehr darin gefällt, etwas Rätselhaftes uns zu präsentieren und mit ein paar Andeutungen zu spielen, dass es mal in jene und in diese Richtung gehen kann, dass er dann doch am Ende uns ein gutes Designstück präsentiert, ein literarisches Designstück, dass nicht es wagt, vielleicht doch einmal die ein oder andere These in den Raum zu stellen, obwohl man eigentlich gerne in diese Richtung gehen will. Das deutet sich nämlich da schon an, dass wir es hier offenbar mit einem Roman zu tun haben, der Kommentar sein will zu unserer heutigen Zeit. Was ist unsere heutige Zeit? Nun, sie ist geprägt von Unsicherheit und sie ist geprägt durch eine neue Technologie, nämlich die KI. Das Thema Künstliche Intelligenz aber ist jetzt nicht das, was hier ausgesprochen wird, sondern wir haben es mal mit einem Server Center zu tun. Dieses Zentrum soll angestrichen werden mit einem weiß, mit einem perfekten weiß. Alles soll dort ganz weiß sein. Aber gehen wir erst mal einen Schritt zurück. Fangen wir vielleicht an mit den ersten Sätzen des Romans. Diese lauten, das Leben war voller Sorgen, aber auch nicht wirklich. Es war eine Zeit, in der viele Dinge schnell erworben und dann wieder vergessen wurden. Es war ein großes ruhiges Zimmer in einem kleinen Haus am Wasser, in der Hafenstadt Stromnes im frühen Herbst. Draußen vor dem Fenster schwebte ein Himmel ohne bestimmte Farbe über den schottischen Orkneyinseln, der mit hoch auftragenden Cumulus-Wolken zugedrängt war. Wir sehen hier schon, ein Stylist ist am Werk und er beschreibt jetzt erst einmal das kleine Haus, in dem Paul der Protagonist des Romans ist. Paul verdient sein Geld damit, dass er schöne Häuser, die verkauft werden sollen, einrichtet, dass man sie gut fotografieren kann, damit sie dann einen entsprechenden Käufer anlocken. So legt er dann in irgendwelche schönen Häuser in der Schweiz oder sonst wo Natursteine, arrangiert etwas mit ein paar Decken einer Chez Lange. Das wird sehr beschrieben, wie Paul eigentlich so ein Meister der minimalistischen, stilvollen Einrichtung ist. Zugleich arbeitet er auch für das Magazin Kuki, ein Designmagazin für die, die ein sehr dickes Potmanet haben, in dem auch der Minimalismus groß geschrieben wird. Und dieser Paul erhält von dem Chefredakteur Cohn den Auftrag, ein Server-Center Weiß zu streichen bzw. er soll das nicht selbst streichen, sondern er soll das perfekte Weiß suchen. Zugleich gibt es aber eine Parallelhandlung. Ja, das ist die Frage, ob sie parallel stattfindet oder wann sie stattfindet, nämlich in einer ganz anderen Zeit, vielleicht ein tausend Jahre früher, vielleicht noch viel früher, da ist Ilda ein kleines Mädchen, das die Mutter an die gelbe Krankheit verloren hat, die mit Pfeil und Bogen schießt. Einen Fremden dabei, plötzlich fast er schießt, sich dann um ihn kümmert, ihn pflegt. Aber eine Bedrohung von außen durch den Herzog lauert schon auf der Schwelle der Tür. Sie müssen also fliehen und sie nähern sich dann immer mehr, nur auf sich allein gestellt. Später gesellt sich noch eine Hündin dazu. Der Steinstadt. Diese Steinstadt ist abgeschieden, wurde bislang auch von diesem Herzog und seinen, wie könnte man sagen, Schergen nicht erobert. Und diese Handlung vollzieht sich also auch. Das wechselt Kapitelweise. Wie gehört das eigentlich zusammen? Es kommt dann, wenn Paul in diesem Servercenter ist, zu einer Sonneneruption. Es gibt also irgendetwas an Einstrahlung, das auf die Erde fällt und irgendetwas verändert und Paul verschwinden lässt. Und Cohen fragt sich auch, wo dieser Paul eigentlich geblieben ist. Es geht um Träume. Man gerät vielleicht durch die Träume in eine andere Welt und wacht nicht mehr auf. Was Christian Kracht hier macht, ist ganz Verschiedenes aufzurufen. Nämlich, er fragt sich, ob wir jetzt wo, und das ist jetzt schon eine Interpretation, denn das wird natürlich nicht so ausgeführt, durch die künstliche Intelligenz alles präsent haben, plötzlich sich auch die Zeiten und die Räume überlagern. Also haben wir es hier mit so einer neuen Pluralität der Welten zu tun. Ein Thema, das im Kino ja schon sehr präsent ist. Die Frage ist aber auch, ob quasi etwas durch diese künstliche Intelligenz in Vergessenheit gerät, die Schrift. So erfahren wir dann in dieser Steinstadt, ist abhanden gekommen. Zumindest gibt es nirgends Bücher zu sehen und auch sonst findet man nichts Geschriebenes. Ist also das Wort am Ende. Das heißt, wir haben es hier mit einem Roman zu tun. Und ich merke gerade, wie ich ihn so erzähle, macht das den ungeheuer spannend. Aber ich finde ihn dann gar nicht so spannend. Der mit diesen verschiedenen Ebenen arbeitet und dann zwei Dinge miteinander verschränkt. Nämlich diese Lebenswelt von Paul mit dieser archaisch anbotenden Lebenswelt, bei der man nicht weiß, ob es eine parallele Welt ist, ein anderer Ort ist oder ein Traumort. Zugleich gibt es auch noch mal kurz die Erwähnung, dass Paul da ein Buch sieht, nämlich Die Brüder Löwenherz von Astrid Lindgren. Das ist ja ein Buch über den Tod, wo also der Bruder des einen in einer anderen Welt, nämlich in der Welt des Todes lebt. Wir haben da auch noch mal einen solchen Bezug. In diesen Kapiteln von der Steinstadt und dieser archaischen Welt, wo man noch mit Pfeil und Bogen schießt, da wird eigentlich so ein Stil bemüht, wie wir ihn kennen, zum Beispiel Heliopolis von Ernst Jünger, einem Roman aus dem mittleren, späten Werk von Ernst Jünger. Man bemüht sich also tatsächlich so eine archaische Sprache herzustellen, aber auch eine gewisse Wiederkehr der Romantik ist zu erkennen. Und dieser Minimalismus, der gefeiert wird von dieser Design-Zeitschrift, der ist dann wahre Realität bei Ilda und den anderen, die sich dann dazugesellen.
Für mich ist das ein perfektes Buch für unsere Zeit.
Nämlich dort gibt es natürlich dann einen Minimalismus, der einfach gelebt werden muss, weil nichts anderes da ist. Ich lese mal einen Abschnitt nicht aus dieser archaischen Welt, sondern aus der Welt von Kohn, diesem Chefredakteur der Design-Zeitschrift, dass man auch ein Gefühl bekommt für den Sound von Christian Kracht. Dieser Sound wiederum ist also einer, der uns wohl bekannt ist und wo auch sicherlich noch mal so ein bisschen faserlante Anklänge zu finden sind. Das sei ja der große Debüt um an der Durchbruch von Kracht. Kohn hasste seine eigene Unordnung. Er fühlte sich frei und gereinigt, wenn es ordentlich war. Aber irgendwie klappte es nie mit dem Aufräumen. Das war eines der ganz zentralen Probleme seines Lebens. Er wusch sich mit Kernseife. Auch die Haare wusch er sich damit. Und er besaß außer diesem Stück Seife, dass er in einer seladonfarbenen Plastikschale aufbewahrte und einer alten, ledierten Plastikzahnbürste keine Kosmetikartikel. Aber es reichte nicht mit der Askese. Er hatte es alles schon durchgespielt, jahrzehntelang schon. Den Sortierzwang der japanischen Mui-Kette, zum Beispiel die Filzstifte mit der schwarzen Nadelspitze und das schöne hellbraune, naturbelassene Notizbuch und die hellgrauen T-Shirts. Das war alles so erbärmlich. Aber das Gegenteil war natürlich noch viel schlimmer. Und jetzt, da das Alter näher kam und er sich erschreckte, wenn er in den Spiegel sah, war es sowieso egal. Deshalb hatte er auch Kuki mehr oder weniger aufgegeben und sich nur noch mit der russischen Esoterik beschäftigt. Aber nicht, weil der Gegensatz von konsumistischem Pseudokommunismus und russisch-proletarischer Metaphysik ihm so relevant erschien. Nein, sondern weil er die komplizierten Verschachtelungenleid war, die er und sein eigenes Magazin ausgelöst und vervielfältigt und in die Welt gebracht hatten. Das Hauptproblem an Kuki war ja, dass es das als begehrenswert abbildete, was die Moderne selbst vorher zerstört hatte. Kuki überführte das fast vergesste in den Postkapitalismus, um das Versunken erneut als Ware anbieten zu können, allerdings zum hundertfachen Preis. Am besten, man brachte sich einfach um. Deshalb hatte er Paul kontaktiert, weil er seinem eigenen, sich selbst auffrestenden, avantgardistischen Streben nicht mehr entkommen konnte, weil alles weiß gemalt werden sollte und weil den Weltspeicher des kollektiven Gedächtnisses aufzuräumen, ihm nur konsequent und richtig erschien. Wir sind also hier in einer Welt, in der vielleicht der technische Fortschritt noch nie so weit war wie bislang. Zugleich kehrt das archaische mit voller Wucht zurück. Die Mode des Minimalismus wird irgendwann bittere Realität, wenn tatsächlich nichts anderes da ist. Parallele Welten tun sich auf durch Schlaf oder sonst etwas. Das sind eigentlich gute Voraussetzungen für einen interessanten Roman. Und die Sprache ist beherrscht. Ja, so kann man es wirklich sagen. Es ist ein Autor, der sein Handwerk versteht. Man kann sagen, aber das ist ja alles nur Handwerk. Das stimmt, aber es ist wirklich sehr gut beherrscht. Es ist nur leider ein Designerstück. Er schafft wahnsinnig installative Räume, durch die man durchgehen kann. Es ist ein bisschen so wie im Museum. Geht man herum, sieht die eine oder andere Installation und geht weiter. Er versucht das hier lose zusammenzubinden, will eben rätselhaft bleiben, hat damit aber doch eigentlich uns am Ende nur etwas Gutgemachtes serviert, was über sich selbst vielleicht doch nicht hinausweist. Denn dass man diese Assoziationen bekommt, wenn davon Weltgedächtnis die Rede ist, wenn mal die Löwenherzbrüder da von Astrid Lindgren auftauchen und und und, das ist ja noch nicht die besondere Kunst, sondern ich kann natürlich immer leicht sagen, und das hat dann auch mit KI und hat mit unserem Wissen und unserem Unwissen und allem zu tun. Und das ist immer alles so richtig, wie es aber auch zugleich wahnsinnig egal ist. Und das ist das, was ich diesem Roman vorwerfe. I misst es am Ende auch so wahnsinnig egal. Und das produziert dann, wenn man sich jetzt nicht nur daran erlauben kann, dass Einrichtungsgegenstände perfekt beschrieben werden, das produziert dann sehr bald Langeweile. Und hier gefällt sich ein Autor wahnsinnig gut darin, dass er diese Beschreibungskunst beherrscht, dass er den Minimalismus, den er in der Designzeitschrift hat, dann hier uns auch immer wieder literarisch nahebringt. Ja, es ist auch in den Dialogen so, dass die Repliken wahnsinnig kurz sind, dass wir es also immer nur mit so Andeutungen zu tun haben. Der Fremde ist der Fremde. Und irgendwann erfahren wir dann mal den Namen. Ja, es wird immer damit gearbeitet, auch wenn man dann recht bald ahnen kann, wer dieser Fremde eigentlich ist. Das verrate ich jetzt hier noch nicht. Aber es wird eigentlich so sehr auf Reduktion gesetzt, dass man sagen kann, der Roman steht dann am Ende doch auch dem, was er da versucht anzusprechen, recht nackt gegenüber. Und deswegen, glaube ich, haben wir es hier mit einem doch recht schwachen Christian Kracht zu tun.
Klingt trotzdem verlockend, so eine gewisse Doppelnaturalismus zu fahren. Also nicht nur den Leser noch mal aufzuzeigen, es ist wirklich geradeall schlimm und wir können das auch alles beschreiben, sondern noch mal eine zweite Welt daneben zu setzen, die irgendwas mitbringt, also im Verhältnis zur eigentlichen Welt hat. Und man weiß dann nicht genau, was da drinsteckt.
Ja, nur, es ist dann auch so ein bisschen, also man kann sowas natürlich immer gut produzieren. Also Rätsel zu produzieren ist ja das eine, aber vielleicht dann doch, ich weiß, ich klinge hier altmodisch, dem Ganzen auch eine Bedeutung zu geben, wäre nicht schlecht. Also es gibt beispielsweise einen Dialog dann, ich sage jetzt nicht, wer diesen Dialog führt, weil das vielleicht schon was verraten wird, aber da heißt es dann über diese Stadt, in der sie da sind. Ich habe immer mehr das Gefühl, als befinden wir uns in einer flachen Landschaft. Die Steine sind flach, das Meer ist flach, sogar der Himmel. Aber die Menschen doch nicht. Wir sind nicht flach, wir bewegen uns. Schau mal so, ich weiß nicht, was du meinst. Wir sind wie gemalt, wie in einem Bild. Das kann doch nicht sein. Du bist einfach müde und erschöpft. Ich habe so ein Bild zu Hause. Und das ist ja wiederum eine tolle Voraussetzung. Und jetzt würde ich gerne wissen, wie wird eine Welt dauerhaft flach? Was bedeutet das? Sind wir dann zu Daten geworden? Ja, also das sind Assoziationen, die da so freigesetzt werden. Nur habe ich den Eindruck, ich habe hier 200 Seiten, die immer wieder irgendwelche Assoziationen in mir wecken. Und dann vergeht es wieder. Dann kann ich sagen, ja, aber so ist das ja im Digitalen. Da gibt es nicht mehr die große Erzählung, die alles miteinander verbindet. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich kenne diese Theorie. Und dennoch muss man dann einen guten Roman daraus machen. Und ich finde, dass das nicht gelungen ist. Trotz allem stilistischen Können, dass ich ja auch dem Autor nicht absprechen will.
Liz Pelly hat ja auch von Flattening gesprochen. Und dann kann man ja einfach künstlerisch das Wort flach aufgreifen und sagen. So, gut. Zwei parallele Welten, die wir unter eine bedeutungsvolle Klammer bringen müssen. In dem Falle Trumps Zollpolitik, aber nicht, weil wir Stress an den Finanzmärkten sehen und das Nachrichtenthema ist. Oder weil wir lustige Nachrichtensendungen sehen, in denen die Zitate von Donald Trump und so, die ja vor der Kamera und so weiter. Sondern es gibt eine Textgrundlage für das, was hier passiert. Ich will aber dazu sagen, es geht hier nur um die inhärente Logik. Also ob die, nachdem was sie sich auf dem Papier entworfen haben, einem bedeutungsvollen Ziel hinterhergehen oder nicht. Dass das jetzt in Praxis angewendet wurde und nicht geklappt hat, ist offenbar. Und auch Adam Toos hat schon lange vor dieser Realitätwertung des Plans gesagt, oder als nicht voll gesagt, aber er hat jetzt im Podcast, war es Mächte, Medien, irgendwas. Es gibt diesen Dreiklang.
Märkte, Mächte, Emissionen.
Märkte, Mächte, Emissionen. Wer gibt den Podcast heraus?
Die Heinrich Böll Stiftung.
Die Heinrich Böll Stiftung. Also da war er zu Gast und hat angesprochen auf das, was wir hier gleich kurz besprechen. Auch gesagt, es ist eine gelagerte Erklärung für Trumps Politik der Stärke. Also so ein Retrospektives, aber ganz so retrospektiv kann man es nicht machen, denn es ist ja wie gesagt vorher ausgebreitet worden. Wir folgen also jetzt nicht Trump selbst, sondern Stephen Myron. Das ist der neue CEA, das ist der Chief Economic Advisor und damit der Chef des Councils of Economic Advisors. Also aus allen Beiräten und so weiter gibt es so einen, der dann einfach den Obermaka da mimt, der dann auch direkt mit dem Präsidenten im Gespräch ist. Und damit ist das ein Posten, der auch vom Senat bestätigt werden muss. Der hatte 53 Stimmen bekommen, also so ein solides Trump hatten Vorschlag, die Republikaner und die Demokraten sagen Nein. Er selbst ist Harvard-Doktorand, hat damals schon unter Donald Trump, in der ersten Regierungszeit war er Berater im Finanzministerium. Ganz großer Kritiker des Corona-Konjunkturprogramms von fortgeführt Joe Biden. Also bloß kein Geld rausgeben und so. Also das muss hier der Strukturwandel, kennen wir von Lars Feld, wird es schon richten. Und er hat eine Publikation 2020 gehabt. A user's guide to restructuring the global trading system. Also das, was jetzt gerade passiert, beruht auf Publikationen, die 2020 schon unter der, das ist dann für die zweite Amtszeit und so konzipiert wurden, zusammen mit dem heutigen Finanzminister Scott Besant, hat er diesen Maralago-Akkord zu verantworten, der ja immer mal wieder jetzt so rumgereicht wurde als, ah ja, das ist die große Verschwörung und so weiter. So, und Steve Myron hat am 7. April, wurde zumindest dann veröffentlicht auf der Webseite des Weißen Hauses, eine Rede gehalten beim Hudson Institute, hat irgendein Event gemacht. Und das läuft dann als offizielles und öffentliches Dokument, wird also auf der Weißen Hausseite veröffentlicht. Und da sagt Myron Folgendes. Die USA hat zwei globale öffentliche Güter. Das eine ist der Sicherheitsschirm, der globalen Frieden ermöglicht. Das andere ist der Dollar als Reservewährung, der das globale Handelssystem stützt und alle Beteiligten unterstützt, überhaupt zu Trading zu kommen. Mit diesem Beispiel hier angesprochen. China und Brasilien können miteinander handeln, weil sie sich auf neutralem Grund treffen. Also die Weltmeere sind abgesichert durch amerikanische Sicherheit und der Dollar ist für beide einfach genauso entfernt steuerbar. Da zieht man sich nicht über den Tisch, wenn man einfach den Dollar benutzt. Aber diese beiden globalen Güter werden auf Kosten eines persistenten Handelsdefizits, insbesondere der US-Fertigung, also des verarbeitenden Gewerbes, hier wird was Bild, Bild, Bild und so haben wir jetzt von Marc Andresen gehört. Da liegt also ein Handelsdefizit, also auch ein Kompetenzdefizit Amerikas. Die Leute haben diese tollen Industriejobs nicht mehr und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt hätte man da ja punktuell reingehen können, um zu sagen, wir unterstützen dazu irgendwie. Also wir hören da gleich Beispiele. Weiterführend, Trump hat also einen Plan für eine faire Lastenverteilung. Wenn man diese globalen Güter in Anspruch nimmt, sollte man dafür bezahlen, weshalb Trumps Zölle als Reziprog gelten. Wir haben diese Kosten, die anderen profitieren davon. Also gleichen wir das jetzt aus. Wir hängen das Preisschild nicht an den Sicherheitsschirm und nicht an den US-Dollar, sondern an die Güter, die importiert werden, weil wir unsere US-Fertigung da nicht auf Augenhöhe haben. Damit schließt man sich natürlich von ausländischen Märkten ab, mit allen komischen Sachen, die jetzt so diskutiert werden, dass dann irgendwie der Handelsminister sagt, ja, wir wollen ja nicht, dass die Fertigung nach Amerika kommt im Sinne von Jobs, sondern wir wollen, dass hier so eine Roboterindustrie entsteht und um die Roboterindustrie dann so eine Ingenieurs, neue Handwerksklasse und so weiter. Also die denken schon so ein bisschen in so Buzzwords der Zukunft, aber es ist jetzt dafür, dass sie jetzt einen Plan gemacht haben, dass sich alle darüber lustig machen, dass man jetzt seine Schuhe wieder in Amerika herstellt, ist es schon amüsant und differenziert. Zölle auf alles und jeden und selbst die Pinguineninsel, über die sich alle lustig machen. Aber das war halt diese Ansage. Der globale Sicherheitsschirm, also weltweit, die Dollar als Reservewerbung, ist weltweit. Also ist das Preisschild auch weltweit. Und wenn das da nur Pinguine sind, kann man sich darüber lustig machen, aber es stört ja dann noch keinen. Aber es wird erst mal pauschal, 10 Prozent auf alles und so. So, diese Zölle sind also dieses Preisschild und damit ein Werkzeug, die wirtschaftliche Stärke Amerikas abzusichern. Also nicht nur militär und nicht nur Dollar, sondern eben auch wieder so ein Industriezeitalter einzuleuten, Ziel ist, sagen die dann, ein neues goldenes Zeitalter für Amerika, während man gleichzeitig die globale Führungsrolle behält. Also wenn China gleichzeitig noch hier einen Anspruch auf, wir schießen auch Seewege frei, das machen wir hier in unserem südchinesischen Mehr-Anführungszeichen selber, ist das ein Problem. Wenn plötzlich festgestellt wird, dass Handelspartner durch Zeugschranken auch aus dem Dollar flüchten und sagen, dann handeln wir lieber in Euro, behaltet mal eure Staatsanleihen und so weiter, wir wollen damit nichts mehr zu tun haben, ist das auch ein Problem. Und das haben wir ja gesehen. Also das waren die Kennziffern, die jetzt Trump so unter Druck gesetzt haben, dass man hier reingehen muss. So, Yannis Varoufakis hat im Februar schon diese Texte, also diese Grundlagentexte von Maren, Myran und Besant da gelesen und hat sich dann dazu mal verhalten. Alles dazu ist verlinkt. Ich habe jetzt den Text von seiner eigenen Webseite genommen, weil er das vorher bei so einer Publikation gehabt hat. Also, der Plan aus Yannis Varoufakis Gesicht ist wie folgt. Der Ausgangspunkt ist Trumps Diagnose des Problems. Ja, genau, kann man so sehen. Die Dollarhegomonie wird hier als exorbitante Bürde verstanden und nicht mehr als Privileg, weil es eben zu hohe Kosten verursacht. Und wir sehen ja, was in Amerika los ist. Die Hauptsorge ist, ausländische Zentralbanken halten den Dollar künstlich hoch. Alle sind interessiert am Dollar, künstlich hochgehalten. Die amerikanische Industrie wird aus eigener Kraft niemals wettbewerbsfähig. Alle anderen Länder der Welt werden immer künstlicher produzieren können, weshalb es also diesen Zoll, dieses Preisschild braucht, um das auszugleichen. So, Trump befürchtete einen großen Zusammenbruch. Und das ist super interessant, weil es gibt ganz viele, gerade jetzt sind sie wieder aufgetaucht, Zusammenschnitte. Jimmy Kimmel und so hat einen gemacht. Wie Trump mehrfach davor warnt, wenn Kamala Harris gewinnt, bricht alles zusammen. Dann haben wir hier Schwarzer Freitag, 30er Jahre, Weltwirtschaftskrise und so. Aus dieser Befürchtung, dass es nicht mehr lange funktioniert, mit diesem nicht vorhandenen, nicht industriellen Nichteinkommen, dass man nirgendwo verbuchen kann, einfach nur auf Schulden basierend diese militärische hegemoniale Kraft aufrechtzuerhalten und den Dollar abzusichern.
Und in der Welt einzukaufen.
Genau. Es fehlt da einfach das Fundament. Deswegen auch dieses, die Schulden, so langsam wird es zu viel. Wir müssen mal wieder ein Einkommen. Also wir brauchen mal wieder ein Einkommen. Und er hat unterstellt, wenn die Demokraten jetzt einfach nur weitermachen wie bisher, dann wird das in der nächsten Präsidentschaft alles in sich zusammenstürzen. Weshalb er jetzt die große Wende einleiten möchte. Und ich finde, aus der Sicht macht das schon Sinn, das sozusagen. Auch wenn er jetzt das verursacht.
Ja, ich finde auf jeden Fall, dass das Sinn ergibt, schon deshalb, weil wir zwar jetzt gerade sehen, dass er so ein bisschen zurückgerudert ist, weil man ihm sagte, hier Treasury Markets, wirft doch mal einen Blick drauf. Aber es ist ja so, dass er in der ersten Amtszeit, als der Präsident angesehen wurde, der alles tut, damit es der Wall Street gut geht, weil es dann eben auch gut geht. Und das wusste er ja, dass das jetzt die Börse nicht freudig aufnimmt. Also das war ihm ja völlig klar, dass das vielleicht ein bisschen heftiger ist als gedacht. Okay, aber dass das generell erst einmal, dass das erst einmal kurzfristig keine Rendite bringt, sondern für doch herbe Verluste sorgt, muss ihm klar gewesen sein.
Genau, also der Plan ist entweder, die Zeitschranke wird akzeptiert ohne Gegenzölle. Also alle bezahlen einfach mehr, ohne dass Amerika mehr zahlen muss. Oder es sind einfach Zeitschranken und Amerika produziert wieder mehr. Aber wir wissen, eine Fabrik aufzuziehen und ein Geschäftsmodell und so weiter dazu verorten ist kompliziert. Also er hatte diese große Angst, dass wenn alles so weitergeht wie bisher, steht Amerika irgendwann ohne Hose da und nur noch mit Flugzeugträgern irgendwie, die niemanden was nützen außer halt Nicht-Amerikanern, denen nämlich die Seewege freigeschossen wird. Was bedeutet, der Dollar ist nicht mehr so attraktiv. Wir stehen vor einem Zusammenbruch zuerst der US-Wirtschaft und damit auch der ganzen Welt. Also wir haben fast Tenant-artige Züge, mit denen die sich das so einbewinnen.
Also man kann ja sagen, der Dollar ist... Ja, also diese Dollar-Eigemonie ist nicht das Ding.
Einmal unter Druck ist schon...
Ja gut, aber den Druck haben die ja selbst ausgelöst. Das geht natürlich nicht, aber sonst war ja zum Beispiel, selbst wenn eine Wirtschaftskrise in den USA war, flüchtete man sich in den Dollar. Man flüchtete sich immer in den Dollar.
Genau, und jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, aber wegen dieser Politik...
Ja, aber wir können ja nicht sagen, das mit dem Dollar funktioniert schon, aber jetzt bitte keine Drucksituation, sondern gerade die Drucksituation, egal welche, sollte ja immer heißen, und jetzt kaufen wir erst mal Dollar. So Warren Buffett Style. Und jetzt haben wir aber gesehen, es gibt eine Drucksituation und die Leute kaufen kein Dollar.
Genau, das ist aber die einzige Drucksituation, die ich mir vorstellen kann, bei der das so passiert.
Genau, wir vernünftigen Leute sagen das jetzt so. Aber die sehen das anders.
Die sehen das eher als eine Bestätigung, die Dollarhegemonik ist unser Problem.
Die sagen jetzt einfach, habt ihr gesehen, es funktioniert schon nicht mehr. Eine Säule bricht uns gerade weg. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt mal kurz, aber der Plan muss jetzt intensiv wird werden sozusagen. Also, Varoufakis stößelt das hier in zwei Phasen auf. Erstens, Zölle als Schocktherapie. Trump verhängt Höhezölle auf Importe. Diese Zölle sollen nicht mehr primär das Handelsdefizit reduzieren, sondern stattdessen auf ausländische Zentralbanken Druck ausüben, um wieder eine Angleichung zum Dollar hinzukriegen. Also der Dollar soll abgewertet werden, um einfach die Kosten für Amerikaner da wieder zu senken. Diese ausländischen Zentralbanken sollen also geschockt werden. Jetzt haben wir aber eine politische Reaktion gehabt, die haben auch Gegenteile gesagt. So, weil es ist ja auch irgendwie naheliegend, dass man dann sagt, okay, der sagt A, ich sage auch A und nicht der sagt A. Okay, jetzt mache ich mir mega Gedanken. Ich darf ja nicht A sagen, der hat schon A gesagt, ich sage jetzt B oder was. Also das ist keine politische, sondern einfach eine Zentralbanken, dass es keine Zentralbankenreaktion gibt, sondern die Politiker einfach sagen, wir lassen uns doch hier nicht vorführen. Die machen Zölle, also Gegenzölle. Das muss man dann auch gerne im Publikum erklären, der Journalismus weiß, wie man das vermittelt. Wenn man jetzt gesagt hätte, Europa senkt jetzt Zinsen oder sowas, also das wäre schon erklärungsbedürftig gewesen. Warum machen wir nicht einfach Gegenzölle? Also in deren Sicht hat man es schon mal hier irgendwie verschätzt, wie man überhaupt sowas macht. Dieser Schock soll die Banken also dazu bringen, die inländischen Zinssätze zu senken. Dadurch wird ein Euro, Yen und Remnib, also die chinesische Währung gegenüber dem Dollar, abwerten. Das neutralisiert die Preiserhöhung durch die Zölle für US-Verbraucher. Effektiv bezahlen die tarifbelasteten Länder für Trumps Zölle. Also es macht in einer inhärenten Logik Sinn, er kommt gleich mit internationalen Vergleichen, denn das gab es ja schon mal. Es ist ja nicht ganz neu, dass man sagte, der Dollar ist zu teuer, wir müssen ihn abwerten im Vergleich zu den anderen Währungen, und zwar wirklich im Maßstab 30 bis 50 Prozent. Das hat es alles schon gegeben. Phase Nummer zwei, die großen Verhandlungen. Mit den Zöllen als Druckmittel zwingt Trump andere Länder zu Einzelverhandlungen. Da wird das Narben- und Speichenmodell bevorzugt. Amerika geht nicht mehr zu irgendwelchen Gipfeln, wo alle miteinander und dann gibt es ein Abschluss-Communiqué. Sondern jeder Einzelne kommt nach Washington. Und dann wird ihm erst mal gesagt, du bist nur eine Speiche im Rat. Falls unsere Gespräche jetzt zu nichts führen, egal. Das große Rat der Welt geht weiter. Da finde ich schon amüsant, dass man, Varoufakis schreibt, man will dann die Länder einteilen. Es gibt so Asiatische und Euroblock. Und dann will man je nach Währung einfach nur selbst, wenn jetzt nur die Chinesen nach Amerika fahren, bringen ja schon das halbe Rat mit. Also das ist für dich auch es ist. Wir hatten jetzt eine Panikreaktion von Trump. Alle Zölle wieder weg, außer die chinesischen. Das ist auch ein undurchdachter Move. Also das muss man sich erst mal genauer angucken, vor allem weil die Chinesen halt einfach dagegenhalten. Also die akzeptieren das Preis einfach nicht. Damit ist diese ganze Theorie, die eine intrinsische Logik hat, sozusagen durch die realistischen Kräfte von außen einfach nicht gedeckt.
Und würden jetzt bei der EU Leute von Verstand arbeiten, dann würden sie jetzt sehen, dass sie sich mit den Chinesen kurz schließen.
Also die EU ist sehr klug, weil sie einfach sagt, auch gegen Zölle, wenn auch fünf Tage zu spät. Also man hätte den Automatismus viel schneller scharf stellen sollen. Nur als dann kamen jetzt 90 Tage keine Zölle, hat man gesagt, wir bleiben dabei und sagen auch einfach 90 Tage. Aber das Regime des Gegenzolls bleibt.
Das ist okay, das kann man ja machen, aber ich glaube, dass jetzt eigentlich ein sehr guter Zeitpunkt wäre, um mit China wieder in anderer Weise zusammenzuarbeiten.
Naja, das werden sie not- oder gedrungen machen müssen, weil die Container sind ja auf dem Weg. Die Waren fahren ja eh schon nach Europa, nur der Preis sinkt jetzt nochmal.
Ja, ja, ich bin gespannt, ob das wirklich so passiert.
Also am Ende haben wir dasselbe Problem wie Amerika. Wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen, wir machen mit China so einen guten und so weiter. Weil am Ende diese Preiskämpfe, die stattfinden, führen ja dazu, dass hier auch nichts mehr produziert werden müsste, weil alles in China hergestellt werden kann. Wobei die Chinesen ja auch darauf achten, dass sie jetzt so eine Binnenwirtschaft kriegen. Also die versuchen sich ja sehr vom Weltmarkt abzukoppeln. Das Endziel hier, schreibt Varoufakis, ist eine neue internationale Ordnung über einen Anti-Nixon-Schock, also eine Umkehrung des Systems von 1971. Ich weiß weder was der Nixon-Schock ist, noch was das System von 1971 ist. Aber ich habe dann einen GPT-Beauftrag gleich. Es geht um einen ganz groß abgewerteten Dollar, der aber trotzdem Weltreservewährung bleibt. Also alle sollen mit militärischer Absicherung sich auf diesem neutralen Boden weiterhin befinden. Niedrige langfristige Kreditkosten in den USA, was eben nur geht, wenn der Dollar interessant bleibt. Nur dann sind diese Zinsen niedrig. Und dann eine Welt in zwei Lagern. Also es gibt einen verbündeten Teil, der bekommt amerikanische Sicherheit und alle Vorteile, die man haben kann, im Dollar zu handeln. Und dann gibt es die Gegner, und das kennen wir heute schon. Es ist verboten, mit Iran, mit Dollar und Öl zu handeln. So, solche Sachen.
Ja, und da glaubst du ja, wenn das jetzt so kommen würde, dass wir nicht eine Loslösung Europas von Amerika erleben, sondern man wird sich am Ende noch fester zusammenbinden.
Das ist das Ziel Amerikas, und die Amerikaner haben jetzt schon mal deutlich No gesagt. Die Europäer meinten.
Ich sehe das nicht so, dass die No sagen.
Ja, also es hängt alles an diesen Gegenzögen.
Ja, das sind jetzt gerade so Spielereien. Aber du glaubst doch nicht, dass unter der Regierung März man sich von der transatlantischen Partnerschaft los sagt.
Die Frage ist ja immer, auf welcher Ebene. Trump macht ganz viele Culture Wars, die Jens Spahn, Friedrich Merz alle super interessant finden. Auf der Ebene werden die sich...
Aber das ist ja im Prinzip Karneval.
Ja, aber das ist der Karneval, der medial ganz viel stattfindet. So, also unter dieser Maßgabe wirst du mir in einem Jahr noch sagen, wir haben uns doch gar nicht losgesagt. Aber in den Kennziffern, dieser ganze Plan hier geht nur auf, wenn die Welt Amerikas Zölle akzeptiert, als schon reziproge und nicht dann noch mal reziproge Gegenzölle. Nur dann. Und die Amerikaner haben jetzt gesagt, wie es aussehen soll. Und die Chinesen haben gesagt no, und zwar wirklich als Automatismus. Also wie so ein automatischer Atombomben-Gegenschlag. Also da war kein... Die haben nicht mehr intern gesprochen wahrscheinlich. Erst recht nicht mit Amerika. Also da ist gerade Eiseskälte. Und die Europäer haben... Klar, die müssen immer erst so einen Beschluss herbeiführen. Jetzt war da noch ein Wochenende dazwischen und so. Aber die Europäer haben eben auch gesagt, ne, wir machen das mit Gegenzöllen. Und damit ist das schon ganz schön zerschossen. Egal auf welcher anderen Ebene die da noch...
Bin mal gespannt, ob das so kommt.
Also ich habe mir da einen GPT schreiben lassen. Mit der Frage, das ist der Text von Myron, das ist der Text von ja Varoufakis. Hier nochmal die zwei Texte von Heike Buchner, wie das in Deutschland diskutiert wird. Was muss ich hier wissen, was ist interessant? Und diesen GPT in Länge habe ich verlinkt. Den kann man nachlesen. Prompt und die anderen Texte sind damit verlinkt. Also wir haben es laut GPT hier mit einer sehr unkonventionellen wirtschaftlichen und geopolitischen Strategie zu tun, die in vier Bereiche aufgeschlüsselt ist. Also einmal diesen Dollarabwerten. Es gab schon mal den Versuch oder nicht nur den Versuch, also den Dollar wirklich um 30 Prozent zu senken. 1985, damals der Plaza-Akkord. So, da hat sich die G5 zusammengeschlossen, also Amerika, Japan und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht genau, wer damals G5 war, Deutschland, Frankreich, also die England, die Gegend halt. Und die haben das dann in internationaler Kooperation gemacht. Ganz wichtig. Nicht in Konfrontation. Sondern die haben sich wirklich darauf verständigt, wir wissen, was das bedeutet, wenn wir den Dollar jetzt um 30 Prozent absenken, es wird dann wirklich teurer für die Nicht-Amerikaner. So, man hat es trotzdem gemacht. Und damals eben, man hatte ja ein Gegenpol. Es gab ja kalter Krieg und so. Es gab ja ein echtes Ziel für alle, ein gemeinsam geteiltes Ziel. Das ist ja heute gar nicht. Heute steht ja wirklich Amerika gegen den Rest der Welt. Zölle als Druckmittel, also diese Art, was wir hier haben, Vergeltungszölle, da geht GPT dann zurück bis zu USA 1930. Damals hatte man so eine Vergeltungszollkaskade, die allerdings bedeutet, dass der Welthandel um 65 Prozent zurückging. Das kann man sich heute in dieser hypervernetzten Welt gar nicht vorstellen. Also minus 65 Prozent ist sozusagen, da sind wir hier bei Kracht in dieser Gegenwelt. Da müssen wir selber raus und die Ziege melken, damit wir was zu essen haben. Diese Bündnislastenteilung erzwingen. Ja, wir haben halt die NATO ab den 70ern da diese intensive Zusammenarbeit, die ja dann auch in der Europäischen Union über Kohle und Stahl hinausging und so. Kann man alles machen, muss man aber koordinieren. Und die Dollar-Dominanz mit Macht sichern, ja, konnte man halt über das Ölgeschäft machen. Also man sagt einfach, wir sind großer Ölkäufer, aber jeder, mit dem wir handeln, der muss auch immer mit allen in Öl handeln und damit ist das einfach etabliert und alle handeln mit Öl. Unter anderem auch Amerika, aber eben auch alle anderen. Und damit ist einfach klar, warum jetzt nochmal Arbeit reinstecken, hier abzuholen. Nee, wir machen jetzt das einfach so, wie sie es wollen, in Öl. Nur, wir haben gerade keinen Petrodollar-Ersatz, wir haben nur noch einen Dollar. Und das, was Amerika gerade starten mag, sind ja so Dienstleistungen, KI, jeder benutzt Word, jeder hat ein iPhone und so. Da kann man jetzt nicht so ein materialgebundenes, hegemoniales Währungsding draus stricken. Also wir haben es hier mit wirklich unbestellten, unbekannten Land zu tun, auf dem das alles so als Theorie irgendwie so ausgebreitet wird. Und wirtschaftliche Risiken sehr hoch, Lieferketten zerstört, inflationäre Schocks, alles was wir jetzt kennen aus extern verursachten Krisen, Kriege, die über uns hereinbrechen, Corona und so weiter. Aber so ein Eskalationskurs im Handel bei dem der Ansatz einfach über Konfrontation läuft. Also GPT mehr andert hier auch so ein bisschen. Man weiß gar nicht in welche Richtung. Es schreibt da nur vom strategischen Eigentor. Und selbst die Heritage Foundation, bei der wir dachten, die schreibt das große Drehbuch für die. Von denen kommt das ja gar nicht. Die sind ja selber überrascht davon, dass sie sich plötzlich mit so einem Quatsch befassen müssen. Ja, so bei Trump versucht ja auch wirklich jeder, der im Wahlkampf so ein bisschen über und so darin sich rein investiert hatte, jetzt einfach einen Jump rum zu zerren. Und es ist ein Stolpern über die eigenen Füße die ganze Zeit. Also in deren Sicht ist es schon alles, also das, dass Varoufakis schreibt, das ist wirklich sehr risikobehaftet. Es hat eine gewisse intrinsische Logik, aber es ist sehr risikobehaftet. Das sollte man doch sehr, sehr, sehr ernst nehmen. Und gerade mit einem Gegenspieler wie China, der einfach auf diese bisherigen Pfosten nicht allzu viel baut, also sowohl auf diesen kooperativen Teil im Sinne von, aber wir haben doch eine WHO und so weiter. Also Trump und so, die haben einfach gesagt, nee, WHO ist nicht mehr. Wir wollen dieses große Gipfelartige nicht. Wir wollen nicht, dass da irgendwelche Richter über irgendwas bestimmen. Wir machen alles in bilateralen Sachen. Denn es kommen aber die Chinesen und sagen, wir hätten da so eine Idee, WHO 2.0 und so. Wir wollen auch nur eine kleine Rolle spielen. Wir sind mehr so Ideengeber. Wir machen mal eine Konferenz. Wollt ihr herkommen und so? Also es ist, China hält auf allen Ebenen dagegen. So, die wollen von ihren günstig produzierten Absetzmärkten, also von ihren eigenen günstigen Produktionen nicht abrücken. Sie streben danach militärisch auf Augenhöhe zu kommen. Diesen kooperativen Ansatz, ja, wir können gerne zusammenarbeiten, uns immer treffen, forcieren sie extrem. Wir haben das ja gesehen, wie sie dabei heus gerne auf der Bühne stehen und quasi die europäischen Konferenzen nutzen, um für ihre eigenen zu werben und so. Also in deren Sicht ist das ein ganz schön großes Durcheinander und das Fazit von GPT lauter Trumps Strategie mögen laut und disruptiv sein, doch ihre Tragfähigkeit ist zweifelhaft, wenn sie mit den Fundamentals der Weltwirtschaft und Geopolitik kollidieren. Und das tun sie, wie wir es sehen. Also in deren Sicht sollte man sich das hier sehr genauer anschauen. Also die zwei wichtigen Sachen, würde ich sagen, sind Chinas sofortige Gegenzölle, dass man sie nicht China erlassen hat, nachdem man kalte Füße bekommen hat. Also eine Panikreaktion zu machen, die das eigentliche Problematische trotzdem aufrecht erhält. Nur der Welt das Signal gibt, die Pinguine müssen jetzt keine Zölle zahlen und die Europäer. Okay, aber das ist nicht das Entscheidende. Sondern China hat sofort Gegenzölle gemacht, hat damit dagegen gehalten, diesen ganzen Plan zertrümmert. Und in der Panikreaktion, die dann kam, hat man China nicht eingeklammert. Also nicht wieder den Zustand, wie vorher, sondern man hat sich jetzt so lock-in-mäßig da drin verfangen. Das ist sehr kritisch.
Wir erleben jetzt das Abenteuer der Moderne. So heißt das neue Buch von Thomas Wagner bei Clet Cotter erschienen, der Untertitel Die großen Jahre der Soziologie von 1949 bis 1969. Und jetzt sagt mir hier der Lumanianer gegenüber, was, das sind doch nicht die großen Jahre, die kommen doch dann erst. Worum geht es, um das Gleiche zu sagen? Es geht darum, wie das Fach Soziologie eine neue Relevanz nach der Nazizeit bekommt und wie man es schafft in Köln, da ist König, in Frankfurt mit der Frankfurter Schule und dann mit Arnold Gehlen und den seinen, Schelski und Co., wie man es da schafft, die Soziologie als wichtiges Fach. Ich glaube, man kann so weit gehen, zu sagen, als staatstragendes Fach zu etablieren und wie plötzlich diese Denker sowohl an den Universitäten mehr Macht bekommen, mehr Personal haben, wie natürlich auch zum Teil eine Endnazifizierung stattfindet, zum großen Teil aber nicht und auch die Frankfurter Schule muss mit Personal arbeiten, das eine Nazi-Vergangenheit hat. Zugleich eine Annäherung stattfindet an die Bundesrepublik an die Regierung bei Gehlen ganz stark natürlich mit der CDU-Regierung, aber auch die Frankfurter Schule will eigentlich diese junge Demokratie schützen und stützen, auch theoretisch unterfüttern. Und wie durch diese Soziologie dann auch neues Bewusstsein vom demokratischen Bürger entsteht. Und man tatsächlich hier sieht, dass also die Soziologie nicht einfach so eine, das kommt dann erst später mit der Schelski-Kritik an der Soziologie, der sich dann als Antisoziologe und so weiter sieht. Damit schließt das Buch. Dass hier aber tatsächlich die Soziologie als eine ganz wichtige Wissenschaft angesehen wird, mit der man darüber nachdenken kann, wie muss dann eigentlich ein bürgerlicher, demokratischer und kapitalistischer Staat verfasst sein. Bis hin zu beispielsweise der Frankfurter Schule, die Tools bereitstellt, um eine Wiederbewaffnung Deutschlands zu ermöglichen, wie man eine Wehrpflicht aufbauen kann, wie man da zum Beispiel Auslesetools hat, die gewisse Subjekte aus der Bundeswehr draußen halten. Da sieht man plötzlich, dass die Soziologie hier tatsächlich auch nicht nur eine Wissenschaft ist, sondern wirklich auch so eine angewandte Wissenschaft hat. Und deshalb sind das die großen Jahre der Soziologie, weil die Politik auch ein großes Interesse daran hat, das zu verfolgen und das zu unterstützen. Und es sind die großen Jahre der Soziologie auch deshalb, weil plötzlich die Soziologen in einem öffentlichen Diskurs stattfinden, wie das nicht zu erwarten war. Nämlich jemand wie Schelski, aber auch Genen, die schreiben Bestseller. Die Frankfurter Schule verkauft sich erst nicht so gut. Das kommt dann erst nach 68 oder mit den 68ern. Aber Schelski kommt durchaus auf hunderttausender Auflagen. Und sie finden im Radio, denn da ist der öffentliche Diskurs präsenter, ist man in den Wohnzimmern, finden sie statt. Adorno beispielsweise hält 300 Radio-Vorträge bzw. führt Gespräche im Radio. Das heißt, diese besondere Präsenz der Soziologie ist etwas, auf das Thomas Wagner in seinem Buch sein Augenmerk legt. Dabei geht es darum, verschiedene Pole zusammenzubringen, die er eigentlich nicht miteinander können. Arnold Gehlen ist derjenige, der in Deutschland bleibt, der NSDAP-Mitglied wird, der dann den nationalsozialistischen Staat legitimiert, der ihn unterstützt, mit seiner wissenschaftlichen Arbeit, der seine Theorie vom Menschen, auch jüdischen Autoren, deren Namen er dann verschweigt, entlehnt, um seine Theorie darauf aufzubauen. Er ist der Soziologe, der auch dafür sorgt, dass seinesgleichen dort im Nazi-Reich Soziologen sein können und die anderen werden aus dem Dienst entfernt. Er ist also jemand, der sich schuldig macht, ganz eindeutig, und der sich später nicht entschuldigen wird dafür. Adorno hingegen mit der Frankfurter Schule zusammen emigriert in die USA, kommt dann aber wieder nach Deutschland zurück, als ihm auch die Offerte gemacht wird, dass er dort in Frankfurt ein Institut aufbauen kann, auch gerade mit Unterstützung der amerikanischen Alliierten, die daran interessiert sind, demokratische Bürger zu schaffen und damit auch zur Entnazifizierung beizutragen. Dass diese beiden eigentlich nicht miteinander können, ist klar. Und jetzt beschreibt Thomas Wagner in seinem Buch wahnsinnig anschaulich, wie diese beiden Lager sich doch aufeinander zubewegen. Zunächst einmal sieht es so aus, dass sie unmöglich zusammenarbeiten können. Ja, dass man auch sieht, wie Adorno und andere Mitglieder der Frankfurter Schule versuchen, diese Leute eher von den Universitäten fernzuhalten, versuchen, ihre Leute irgendwo unterzubringen. Aber dann entsteht doch nach und nach ein Austausch zwischen Adorno und Gehlen. Und besonders zusammengeführt wird das über die Kunst. Aber bevor ich jetzt weitermache, du willst schon dazwischen gehen?
Nein, also ich frage mich nur, Abenteuer der Moderne. Ich finde, diese Zeit, Zweiter Weltkrieg, Deutschland wird gegründet bis 69. Ja. Auch wahnsinnig interessant, weil das ist die Zeit, in der die Babyboomer geboren werden, die danach als größte Altersgruppe Zukunft brauchen. Also baut man ihn in Universitäten. Man weiß, die sind jetzt Grundschüler. Das sind viele. Wir möchten gerne, dass sie gut ausgebildet werden. Also brauchen wir ihnen Universitäten. Also entsteht eigentlich erst nach diesem Zeitraum dieser Bildungs-Boom.
Genau.
So. Wir haben es also mit einer Soziologie zu tun, die in dieser Zwischenwelt aus, wir haben ein wahnsinnig schlechtes Gewissen und großen Aufklärungsbedarf, aber eigentlich reden wir nicht mal so gern drüber. Und Bildung für alle, für eine junge Generation, die all das, was uns so beschämt, nur aus dem Fernsehen kennt. Weil die Eltern haben ja geschwiegen und so weiter und so fort. Und ich hätte gerne ein Buch, das sich um diese Soziologie kümmert, das schon im Titel, also nicht Abenteuer und Moderne oder sowas, sondern Holocaust-Krieg, zivilisatorischer Bruch, Zwischenwelt.
Aber darum geht es natürlich in dem gesamten Buch. Nun wissen wir, wie Buchtitel entstehen. Das ist ja aber schon eine Sache. Das Abenteuer der Moderne besteht aber tatsächlich darin, und da würde ich den Titel auch verteidigen, dass man ja sagen kann, die Moderne, zumindest gibt es diese Theorie, wurde durch den Nationalsozialismus unterbrochen. Man spricht davon Zivilisationsbruch und so weiter. Es gibt auch andere, die sagen, naja, das ist auch eine Form der Moderne und zwar die scheußlichste Seite. Aber jedenfalls ist ja diese Idee der Moderne, dass man eigentlich doch ein aus der Aufklärung kommendes Subjekt hat, das eigenverantwortlich ist, dass einen freien Willen hat, das aufgrund von vernünftigen Entscheidungen treffen kann. Und das dadurch auch in die Freiheit sich selbst leiten kann, nicht einfach geleitet wird. Das ist eine Idee, der natürlich auch die Frankfurter Schule verpflichtet ist. Und es gibt ja immer bei Adorno diese Sache, dass er eigentlich sagt, wir wissen noch gar nicht so richtig, was die Freiheit ist. Diese muss noch erreicht werden. Die ist bislang nur ein Traum oder sie ist eine Kindheitserinnerung oder sonst etwas. Und dagegen steht nun jemand, der auch sagt, ja, wir haben eine Industrialisierung, wir haben eine arbeitsteilige Gesellschaft, wir haben verschiedene Milieus. Er will ja nicht von Klassen sprechen, nämlich jemand wie Arnold Gehlen, der sagt, wir brauchen eigentlich ein Organisationssystem namens Staates, das hierarchisch aufgebaut ist und durchregiert und der die einzelnen Bürgerinteressen hinten angestellt werden können. Wenn es der dem Staat dient, das er andere unterdrückt, um sich zu halten, dann ist das richtig. Das ist ja etwas, was Gehlen im Nationalsozialismus sieht. Er sagt, so muss es eben sein. Das ist der Ruf des Staates, dem haben wir uns unterzuordnen. Und das Gehlen, zwar das Vokabular ändert nach 45, natürlich aus strategischen Gründen, er aber eigentlich diesem Denken treu bleibt. Und das ist dann auch diese Auseinandersetzung, die es zum Teil auch zu hören gibt, sie sind ja aufgetreten im Radio, zwischen Adorno und Gehlen gibt, nämlich, dass Gehlen die Institutionen für absolut unabdingbar hält, um das staatliche Funktionieren und überhaupt moderne gewährleisten zu können, während Adorno sagt, nein, er zitiert dann zum Beispiel Krabbe oder so, nichts als nur Verzweiflung kann uns retten, wir müssen sehen, dass wir zu einer wirklichen Freiheit gelangen, und die kann nicht in einer solchen hierarchischen Struktur von Institutionen bestehen, wenngleich aber, und das ist ja dann das Bemerkenswerte an der Frankfurter Schule, keiner von denen noch irgendwelche revolutionären Töne ansteckt, vielleicht noch Marcuse ein bisschen durch die amerikanische Studentenbewegung beeinflusst, aber Adorno ganz gewiss nicht. Er also eigentlich an jenseits der Institutionen will, vielleicht sogar an jenseits des Staates, wie Gehlen mutmaßt, aber Adorno keine umstürzerischen Thesen oder sonst irgendetwas in dieser Weise formuliert, sondern eigentlich dann doch sagt na ja, also die Sowjetunion ist mir keine Alternative, ich sehe schon Probleme im Kapitalismus, der wäre zu überwinden, aber lasst uns das mal erst in der Kunst ermöglichen, bevor sonst irgendwo stattfindet. Und so mache ich eigentlich auch eine Soziologie, die den Status quo in der höchsten Abstraktionswahnfrage stellt, aber nicht zu einer praktischen Soziologie führt, die sagt, und Folgendes muss umgestürzt werden. Und dass diese beiden Positionen da zusammenkommen, indem sie eigentlich doch auch den Staat und seine Institution als so ein Elitenprojekt wahrnehmen und vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht finden. Also Gehlen finden es gar nicht schlecht und Adorno macht es über so ein paar dialektische Drehungen dann. Das ist sehr interessant und es ist wirklich auch herausragend, wie Thomas Wagner eben diese Denkströmung zusammenführt und auch immer erklärt. Also wer jetzt sagt, gut, ich habe kein Gehlen gelesen und nur ein bisschen Adorno, warum soll ich das lesen? Also erst mal muss man hier sagen, auch wenn man die Autoren vorher nicht im Original gelesen hat, kann man das wahnsinnig gut nachvollziehen, weil diese Denkströmungen und Denkbewegungen sehr gut erklärt werden, die da stattfinden.
Gut, ich nehme mal den Titel, wie er ist. Ich habe nur zwei Buchstaben im Grunde, die es für mich sozusagen sehr viel besser und sehr viel punktgenauer machen würden. Wir haben ja heute eine Situation, in der die letzten Überlebenden des Holocausts sterben und wir quasi keine Zeitzeugen mehr haben. Das heißt, jetzt haben wir auch eine Zeit für eine Soziologie, die so aufgeladen und wichtig und emotional dieses Thema, weil es in sehr viele Biografien und Familiengeschichten reingeht, ist, trotzdem nüchtern damit umgeht. Und ein Autor, der es ja gerade ganz präsent macht, ist Stefan Kühl, mein ehemaliger Professor, der zuerst ein Buch über ganz normale Organisation angelehnt an ganz normale Männer. Und jetzt nochmal ein zweites über Führung, das kenne ich aber noch nicht, ich habe noch nichts gelesen, Führung im Nationalsozialismus und danach mit der Frage, wie rekrutiert der Staat sein Personal? Also unabhängig der Aufgabe, die zu erledigen ist, war das wirklich so anders danach. Also es gab noch mal eine Unterrichtsstunde zum Thema was auch immer und man hat eine freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung, aber man braucht halt Leute, die eine Verwaltung durchführen. Wo sind da eigentlich die Unterschiede? Das kann man heute ganz nüchtern machen, weil schon Stefan Kühls Eltern wahrscheinlich zu jung sind, um das alles noch live und epigenetisch vererbt zu haben, um zu sagen, ok, jetzt müssen wir das aber und so weiter. Und das heißt für mich, heute haben wir eine tolle Zeit für Soziologie. Oder angelehnt an diesen Titel, wir haben mal wieder ein Abenteuer der Moderne, wir haben so eine KI, irgendwas, zivilisatorische Brüche überall. Nicht nur im Negativen, sondern grundsätzlich, wir müssen uns ernsthafte Fragen stellen, wenn wir nicht mehr die einzigen denkenden Wesen sind. So, hier steht es, Abenteuer der Moderne, das ist ja generisch, das ist quasi immer, die großen Jahre der, und jetzt kommt es auch drauf an, Soziologen. Weil man dann sagen kann, welche man meint. Und das ist ein ganz großer Unterschied in der Soziologie, ob man es mit Menschen zu tun hat, bei denen es nicht ganz egal ist, wen man meint. Und wir haben es hier mit einem Buch zu tun, bei dem es wichtig ist, genau zu wissen, über wen man spricht.
Es ist ein Buch über Gehlen und Adorno, und es ist aber auch geklammert.
Genau, und das muss man markieren.
Das ist das Interessante. Na ja gut, man kann ja schon einen Klappentext lesen.
Also, ja, aber es ist halt, ich bin ja nun ein Verfechter einer Soziologie, die sich wirklich frei macht von vielem. Und unter die Zeit vor 1969 zum Beispiel nicht einfach.
Aber dein Luhmann hat ja beispielsweise auch eifrig Gehlen rezipiert. So, hat dann nur gesagt, ich würde gern noch den Menschen aus der Sache rausnehmen. An sich finde ich das mit den Organisationen und diesen Institutionen und Strukturen, die Gehlen da beschreibt schon ganz vernünftig. Aber der Mensch so als Fokus ist mir nicht recht, deswegen nimmt er den da raus.
Ja, aber wir haben die Idee im Text und der Gehlen wird dann in der Fußnote erwähnt, die keiner liest und der Text regt sich trotzdem. Das ist halt dieser Punkt. Adono kann man nicht einfach so rausstreichen.
Jedenfalls haben wir es mit zwei Soziologen zu tun, die erst mal gerahmt werden dadurch, dass es da einen Kommunisten in der DDR gibt, der auch da mal im Gefängnis war. Und manche werden ihn vielleicht kennen, Wolfgang Haarich, der eine ganz interessante Idee auch der Wiedervereinigung hatte. Ich will das nicht hier länger ausführen. Also ein, sagen wir, sehr schillernder Charakter ist. Und der sitzt da und hört sich auf einem Tonbankgerät begeistert 1965 an, wie Gehlen und Adorno diskutieren. Und jetzt er als Kommunist müsste doch eigentlich auf Adornos Seite sein. Nein, er verehrt seit vielen, vielen Jahren Gehlen, hat ihn auch getroffen, ist mit ihm im Austausch. Und das ist so eine Rahmung, man denkt so, was hat dieser radikale Linke mit Gehlen zu tun? Er glaubt, dass Gehlen eigentlich ein Marxist ist, der das nur noch nicht weiß. Er müsste sich nur mit Marx beschäftigen. Und wenn das stattfindet, dann würde er sehen, dass man eigentlich dann als ein so intelligenter Mann, wie Gehlen es ist, zum Marxisten werden könnte. Und Haarich gefällt natürlich auch, dass Gehlen so sehr an straffe Organisation und Hierarchie glaubt. Gehlen ist der, das wird dann später im Buch zitiert auch, der zum Beispiel den Prager Frühling verwirft und sagt, gut, dass die das niedergeschlagen haben, denn Hauptsache der Staat kann sich schützen. Er ist nicht jemand, der sagt, wie schlimm diese Autorität in der Sowjetunion ist. Er ist nicht jemand, der mit Stalin große Probleme hat. Ganz im Gegenteil, Lenin ist ihm eher unrecht. Also da sieht man auch etwas sehr Gespenstisches natürlich bei Gehlen. Und es ist hochinteressant, wie das also eingeführt und gerahmt wird, denn dieser Wolfgang Haare, der taucht nachher wieder auf. Aber was ich eben schon andeutete ist, dass diese Soziologen eigentlich von verschiedenen Richtungen kommen und auch grundsätzlich skeptisch gegenüber ihren jeweiligen politischen Äußerungen sind. Denn natürlich hat jetzt Adorno nicht gesagt, naja, dann brauchen wir eben den straff durchorganisierten Staat. Sie haben schon recht, Herr Gehlen. Und Gehlen andersrum hat nicht gesagt, wir gehen hin zur Freiheit und versuchen diese Institution zu überwinden. Aber es ist die Kunst, die die beiden dann zusammenführt. Nämlich ist Gehlen derjenige, der sich daran stört, dass es ein Buch gibt von von Siedlmayern in 50ern, das die abstrakte Kunst verwirft. Gehlen will doch noch mal draufblicken und er beschäftigt sich viel mit der Kunst, schreibt dann 1960 das Buch Zeitbilder zur Soziologie und Ästhetik der modernen Malerei. Dies führt dann dazu, dass Adorno begeistert das liest und sie sehen, okay, die Vorliebe für die abstrakte Kunst, die kann uns doch zusammenbringen im Dialog. Für Adorno ist natürlich die Abstraktion der Kunst, dass hier nicht mehr das bloß existierende, bloß der Status quo reproduziert wird, sondern dass er quasi überwunden wird durch die Abstraktion. Da sieht man also auch wieder was politisch Revolutionäres bei Adorno drin. Bei Gehlen hingegen ist es so, dass er die Entfremdung in der industrialisierten Gesellschaft und all das durchaus wahrnimmt. Das führt bei ihm nicht zum Klassenkampf, sondern er sagt, wir haben dann durch die Kunst noch mal die Möglichkeit, dort uns vielleicht Quellen der Erfahrung oder der Fürsorge oder der Muße zu holen, wo wir das sonst im Alltag nicht mehr treffen. Thomas Wagner schreibt dann denjenigen, die für die Reize der Kunst empfänglich waren, mochte sie als ein letztes Refugium der Freiheit erscheinen, in dem eine Wortloserkennnis, eine Wortlose Reflexion, sichtbar wurden. Die Liebe, die junge Leute für abstrakte Bilder empfanden, führte Gehlen in einem geradezu poetischen Satz auf ein so verstandenes Entlastungsbedürfnis zurück. In geglückten Fällen kann dann ein sichtbares, optisch klingendes Wort der Seele Luft machen. Hier schwingt mit, schreibt dann Wagner, dass er diese beglückende Erfahrung, ganz ähnlich wie Adorno selbst hatte, machen dürfen. Im Unterschied zu Gehlen war der Frankfurter Denker jedoch der Ansicht, dass sich in den Freiheitsmomenten der Kunst nicht nur eine Chance zur Entlastung, sondern darüber hinaus ein Potenzial zeigte, die Gesellschaft in Richtung neuer Entwicklungsbahnen zu öffnen. Wo Gehlen die Kultur vor allem stagnieren sah, glaubte Adorno an ein Weiter- und Fortschreiten in den Künsten, das nach einer dialektischen Folgerichtigkeit vor sich gehe. Dass Gehlen nicht mehr vom Begriff des Menschen ausging, sondern in einer soziologischen Perspektive seine Handlungen, ihre Abläufe und Strukturen in den Blick nahm, sagte Adorno ebenfalls zu. Das heißt, da kommen sie sich näher. Sie diskutieren dann auch über die moderne Kunst, erinnern sich auch gemeinsam an die Avantgarde, an die Zwanzigerjahre natürlich auch, sehen auch ein Problem damit, wenn die Kunst jetzt nostalgisch wird und das einfach nur wiederholt. Hier haben wir es wirklich mit einem Buch zu tun, das uns viel über dieses Denken in der jungen Bundesrepublik vermittelt und das uns auch zeigt, wie also dann über solche politischen Gräben hinweg miteinander gesprochen werden kann. Auf sehr hohem Niveau natürlich. Und wie dann aber auch so eine grundsätzliche Differenz nicht überwunden werden kann, weil die Ansätze doch zu anders sind. Und hier will ich nochmal beispielhaft kurz etwas vorlesen. Während für Adorno die Theorierarbeit die Art und Weise war, mit der er bis zuletzt immer wieder eine Kerze der Hoffnung entzündete, hatte sich Gehens Blick auf die Gesellschaft schon früh verfinstert. Na, noch wenige Wochen vor seinem Tod unter dem Eindruck heftiger Anfeindungen durch seine Studierenden, beschrieb Adorno die Praxis der Theorie als wirksames Mittel, um angesichts der vermeintlichen Unveränderlichkeit der Verhältnisse als Denker nicht zu verzweifeln. Dann wird zitiert aus seinem Text Resignation, Denken ist nicht die geistige Reproduktion dessen, was ohnehin ist. Solange es nicht abbricht, hält es die Möglichkeit fest, sein unstillbares, der Wiederwille dagegen, sich abspeisen zu lassen, verweigert sich der törichten Gewissheit von Resignation, Zitatende. Gehlen stand ein solches Gegengift zur Verzweiflung nicht zur Verfügung. Er war davon überzeugt, dass sich in der industriellen Gesellschaft nichts wirklich mehr zum besseren wenden ließ. Schon lange, schrieb er Adorno, habe ich das Wort verwirklichen gestrichen, das sich bei ihnen noch kürzlich fand. Es gibt nichts zu hebeln und nichts zu verwirklichen. Und so sah sich dann Gehlen als der Kommentator des Ruins, während bei Adorno dann immer noch diese Idee der Hoffnung war. Interessanterweise hat Gehlen auch Luhmann getroffen mal, beziehungsweise Luhmann wollte mit Gehlen ins Gespräch kommen. Und zwar trafen sie sich in der Bahn, da fuhren sie. Und Luhmann war eigentlich gut vorbereitet auf das Gespräch. Er hatte die Seele im technischen Zeitalter, Urmensch und Spätkultur, Zeitbilder und der Mensch gelesen von Gehlen, konnte sich eigentlich mit ihm unterhalten. Aber es kam so richtig nicht in Gange und irgendwann fragte dann Luhmann, diese Anekdote wird dann hier von Wagner referiert. Woran arbeiten sie denn gerade? An diese banale Frage ließ sich für gewöhnlich immer eine mehr oder weniger tiefgründige Fachsimplei anschließen, die in einem lockeren Austausch über Kollegen trat, schmünden konnte. In diesem Fall nicht. Gehlen antwortete denkbar knapp in einem Satz. Ich bereite mich auf den Untergang vor. Also Gehlen finster blickt er da. Die Soziologie aber geht dann neue Wege. Hier wurden die Grundsteine gelegt. Ich finde, wenn man sich für Soziologie, für diese Denke Adorno und Horkheimer und auch Gehlen interessiert, dann ist man da richtig, beziehungsweise kann man Gehlen kennenlernen. Und der Gehlen ist schon sehr monströs. Und das zeigt sich auch nochmal so am Ende des Buchs. Und irgendwann merkt das auch Wolfgang Haareich. Aber ich kann doch auch nach der Lektüre des Buches sagen, und das spricht wirklich für das Buch, dass ich ein klein bisschen von Adorno und Horkheimer abgerückt bin, weil ich doch ein bisschen enttäuscht war, wie Staatsform die beiden so sind. Und dass ich trotz der eindeutig größeren Differenzen durch die Lektüre des Buches näher an Gehlen herangerückt bin. Und das eigentlich ziemlich inspirierend fand, was Gehlen so dachte und fand es auch erstaunlich, wie sehr er bereit war, sich der Kunst zu öffnen. Die Philosophen mochte er nicht so sehr, aber die Kunst und auch die Literatur, UNESCO oder so, traute er schon zu, die eine oder andere Erkenntnis zu befördern. Insofern ist das also ein Buch sicherlich für Leute, die in solchen ideengeschichtlichen Feldern sich vertiefen wollen. Aber es ist sicherlich ein Buch, das einen auch dazu anleitet, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Gehlen wiederzulesen, vielleicht auch Frankfurter Schule. Und vielleicht noch ganz zum Schluss ein Zitat von Odo Marquardt, der zu Gehlen Folgendes sagte. Gehlen wisse zwar zu begründen, warum der Mensch kein Tier ist, nicht aber, warum er kein Unmensch sein dürfe. Und das ist sicherlich das Problem bei Gehlen auch. Jedenfalls dieses Abenteuer dieser beiden eigentlich konträren Positionen, die dann doch miteinander sprechen können, ist hochinteressant nachzulesen.
Ja, finde ich sehr gut, dass sich Thomas Wagner darum gekümmert hat. Für mich beginnt die Soziologie dann, wenn wahrscheinlich ein älterer Mann wie Gehlen da sitzt und sagt, ich breite mich auf den Untergang vor.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Dass man dann einfach sagt, schön, wie sie das beschrieben haben. Ich blende aus, was sie damit meinen und frage mich, was ist der Untergang? Ich bin ganz fasziniert. So, dann geht's los. Gut, Humann hat eine Analyse gemacht. Sie beginnt wie folgt, also auf LinkedIn ist zu lesen. In der WDR-Sendung, hart aber fair, präsentiert Isabel Grupp altbekannte Narrative. Bürgergeld als Einladung zur Leistungsverweigerung. Mindestlohn als Bedrohung der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit. Migration als heimlicher Sozialkostentreiber. Ihre Thesen wirken wie schlüssige Business Cases. Doch bei genauer Analyse zeigen sie sich als empirisch unbelegt, ökonomisch verkürzt, rhetorisch zugespitzt. Das könnte man denken, ja, das ist so eine politische Haltung in Prosa. Also jeder Gewerkschaftsexe geht so los, dass man erst mal Urteile spricht. Und was ist hier unbelegt, was ist ökonomisch verkürzt, was ist rhetorisch zugespitzt? Nur in dem Fall ist es ein Fazit.
Und das ist eine Unternehmerin, die da zu Gast war.
Genau, sie war eine Unternehmerin. Und nochmal das hohe Wort, der neben ihr saß, auch irgendeiner Kuban, glaube ich Tilman Kuban, und dann haben sie sich gegenseitig zugenickt. Und jetzt mal wirklich die Ärmel hochkrempeln. So, dieser Text beginnt also mit so einer Art Präampelsprache, der uns nochmal die altbekannten Worte und so. Nur der Text im Folgenden schlüsselt es eben auf. Was ist denn hier empirisch unbelegt? Was ist denn ökonomisch verkürzt? Wie wird es denn ausformuliert heißen und so weiter? Also wir haben sozusagen Wortbeiträge aus einer politischen Diskussion, in der sechs Leute eine Stunde lang diskutieren, also jeder zehn Minuten redet. Es ist nicht viel. Und im Resultat sind es 2600 Worte Text.
Die generiert wurden?
Die generiert wurden, um aufzugreifen, was sie sagt, das Fundament zu klären, Anschlussfragen zu stellen, ob ihre Argumentation tragfähig ist und zu begründen, wenn nicht, warum nicht und wenn doch, warum doch und so. Also wir haben es hier mit einer Textgattung zu tun, die vor allem auf Fleiß basiert. Mal wirklich nachschauen, was da steht, wer was gesagt hat, welche Erfahrungen es gibt und welche ökonomischen Konsequenzen das jetzt bedeutet für die Zukunft. So, das ist typischerweise genau diese Bergwerksarbeit an bestehenden Texten, die man nicht macht und die die KI heute übernimmt, während dann andere daneben stehen und sagen, nee, KI, ich glaub nicht dran, weil das ist ja gar nicht originell, was die sagen. Und man denkt sich so, denn es muss ja nicht originell sein. Es geht nur darum, dass mal fleißig in die Bibliothek gegangen wurde, um auf Seite 37 von diesem und jenem Buch nachzuschauen, was würde es denn bedeuten, wenn dieser Spruch, der da gemacht wird, einfach in politische Praxis umgesetzt wird. Also diese Art von ackern, ackern, ackern, jeder Satz ist von Bedeutung. Wer steckt dann plötzlich hier in solchen Texten drin? Also auf diese Einleitung folgt dann These 1, die soziale Hängematte als Standortrisiko. Hat sie so vorgestellt. Also 2.1, Grupps Argumentation. 2.2, der Mythos der Unwilligen Arbeitslosen. 2.3, die Warenkosten und Nutzen des Sozialsystems. 2.4, Anreize oder Grundsicherung, die Warenentscheidungsfaktoren und so weiter und so fort. Das ist einfach genau das, was man will. Und dann kommt man auch auf sowas wie, wir haben ja auch mal die soziale Hängematte umgedeutet. Für wen ist die eigentlich? Was hat sie für Effekte? Welche Arbeiterbewegung wird hier zertrümmert? Und welches Subventions-Hängemädchen wird dann aufgehangen und so weiter und so fort? So, These 2, ihr Mindestlohn, Margen und der Wettbewerbsalarm. Da wird dann sozusagen einmal klassifiziert, die soziale Hängematte, dann die politische Praxis, die es gibt, und dann schön von 2 bis 6 oder von 3 bis 6 einfach aufgeschlüsselt und so weiter und so fort. Wer sich da für die Inhalte interessiert, ich glaube, wir wissen alle, wenn eine Unternehmerin bei Hart-Oberfer sitzt, dann ist das der Quoten-Posten, der nochmal die Argumente vorträgt und so weiter. Der kann das dann bei Human direkt nachlesen. Human war dann auch überrascht, dass seine Analyse eben auf diese 400 Reaktionen kam, 45.000 Impressions hatte und überwiegend positive Kommentare im Sinne von vielen Dank und so weiter und so fort. Was wir nämlich bekommen, ist kein Fabulieren, sondern auch die präampelmäßig klingende Einleitung ist sozusagen nur, werden schon mal die Wortgelandten aufgehangen, die dann gleich aufgeschlüsselt werden. Bullet Points, wo es sich anbietet. Also bitte, es wird kein, sagen wir mal, Leselleistungen abverlangt, wo keine gebraucht wird, wenn man auch mal ein bisschen auf Grammatik verzichtet und einfach sagt, in Kürze liegt die Würze. Wir gehen mal die Bullet Points durch. Die Bullet Points selbst müssen natürlich gewissen Ansprüchen genügen. Darauf wurde geachtet. Hervorhebung für das Auge durch Fettungen im Text und eine ganz klare Gliederung. Also alles, was wir nicht bekommen, wenn ein Autor nachts aufgrund von, ich habe da gerade was im Fernsehen gesehen, eine Nachtkritik schreibt, die dann 4 Uhr auf Faznet oder Spiegel online veröffentlicht wird, wo man noch mal nachlesen kann, was denn da gesagt wurde. Sondern genau das Gegenteil davon. Ich habe dann Human gefragt, erklär mir mal den Workflow. Er hat die Sendung geschaut und sich dabei schon Notizen gemacht, die haben ihn alarmiert und eskaliert, die Situation. Er dachte, ich kann das jetzt nicht so stehen lassen, ich muss hierzu was machen. Er hatte aber keine Lust zu schreiben, weil Schreiben ist ja nun nicht sein Ding. Also geht er in die Mediathek, lädt sich die Sendung runter.
Also man muss sagen, der Mann ist Unternehmensberater.
Der ist Unternehmensberater, der weiß was.
Zeit ist Geld und er arbeitet mit KI viel.
Genau, eigentlich nur. Also Mediathek, runterladen, transkribieren. Deep Research 1, neutrale Bewertung der Argumentation. Also überhaupt erst mal den allumfassenden Katalog, der Denkgebäude, die da gemacht wurden. Was steckt hinter den Begriffen, die fehlen und den Aussagen. Diese Recherche läuft also darauf hinaus, dass die Argumentation, die natürlich in Sprechakten in der Fernsehsendung relativ schnell runtergerattert wurde, man will einfach nur die Signalwurde setzen, einmal überhaupt fundiert und dann auch verortet wurde in größeren Debatten, wie sie laufen. Human hat dazugeschrieben, er möchte hier keine progressive Kritik in der Analyse, sondern nur eine Aufschlüsselung. Also einfach nur erweitermir sozusagen, was da ist. So, dann ein zweites Deep Research mit Ergänzung volkswirtschaftlicher Perspektiven. Wenn sie ist ja eine Unternehmerin, sagt also die ganze Zeit irgendwelche, sie hat Erfahrungen, es war ja so in der Sendung, dass sie so da saß und meinte, ja, also das sagen mir immer die Leute vom Arbeitsamt, wenn wir da nachfragen, ob es mal wieder Arbeitskräfte gibt, nee, die sind alle faul, die kommen hier morgens nachher, holen sich die Unterschrift und so. Dann war einfach die Gegenfrage von wie viele Leuten sprechen sie denn da? Und dann sagt sie gleich, nee, sie brauchen jetzt gar nicht kommen mit Statistik, ich höre doch, was die mir sagen. Also so auf der Ebene ist das ja als Gespräch abgelaufen, also musste das erstmal ordentlich alles ausgebreitet werden. So, dann hat er nach spezifischen Ergänzungen gefragt durch seine expliziten Hinweise, die er dann gemacht hat, gerade auch zum Thema Rassismus, weil dann so ausländische Bürgergeldempfänger nochmal besonders in der Sendung in so Halbsitzen erwähnt wurden und so weiter und so fort. Resultat war dann 20 Seiten Text. Die hat er dann zu Notebook LM gebracht, also diesem Google Ding, wo man so einen spezifischen Datensatz an Grundlage legen kann, um dann daraufhin zu arbeiten, vor allem Texts herzustellen. Er hat dann diese Deep Researches und das Transkript zu Notebook LM geladen und hat dann Google beauftragt, jede Argumentation, die GPT vorher in den Deep Researches da reingeschrieben hat, noch mal zu überprüfen, also den Quellen zu folgen und aus der verlinkten Quelle tatsächlich die entsprechenden Textstücke, auf die sich GPT angeblich bezieht, aufzunehmen. Also die Datenbank wächst entsprechend und damit auch der Quellenanhang. Später, zu diesen 2600 Zeichen Text, den Humann veröffentlicht hat, gehört eine ebenso lange Quellenliste, also wo man dann alles nochmal aufgeschlüsselt sieht. Er wollte also wissen, steht in dieser zitierten Literatur von GPT wirklich drin, was GPT behauptet, was da drin steht. Er hat dann so ein bisschen stichprobenmäßig kontrolliert. Google hat das wohl alles ganz gut gemacht. Dann sollte Notebook LM das strukturieren, mit dem Ziel, ein Blogpost zu machen. Also von Anfang an, klar, so auf LinkedIn kann man das machen. Ab dann mussten Redundanzen rausgepromptet werden, was dann auch in die Gliederung eingeht. Plus, diese ganzen Bullet Points mussten, es gibt ein pyramidiales Prinzip, dass die Bullet Points immer eine inhärente Logik brauchen, die aufeinander aufbaut. Also kein Bullet Points sollen nur, weil der Autor fand das auch noch interessant, so stehen, sondern alles muss begründet werden. So, also hat er dann diese große Liste an Bullet Points und Text gehabt, die hat er dann als finalen Schritt zu Lex.page gebracht, weil da kann man noch mal punktuell einzelne Absätze markieren oder Listen und spezifisch über Kommentare reinprompten und dann hat es nur Effekt auf diesen Absatz im Kontext des ganzen Textes. Wer kennt ja das Problem, dass man, wenn man GPT sagt, mach mal so und so, da wird der ganze Text neu und dann ist alles umgebaut und so, also mit LexPage kann man dann gezielt da reingehen und er ist mit 5000 Worten reingegangen und hat dann halb so viel durch diese ganze Hin- und Herprompterei. Am Ende vier Stunden Arbeit, aber halt keine Autorenschaft, sondern nur editieren, lektorieren und an GPT und Google auslagern, dass die Inhalte alle miteinander verknüpft und ein kohärentes Verhältnis zueinander haben. Ja, und dann hat er das alles einfach veröffentlicht und hat dann diese entsprechende Resonanz. Und ich denke mir jetzt so, okay, das klingt jetzt erst mal wahnsinnig kompliziert, aber das kann man auch so automatisieren, also dass man einfach Schritt für Schritt für Schritt anfängt mit den, okay, wir wollen totale Treue des gesprochenen Wortes in so einer Sendung und dass man sich dann in sagen wir mal zehn Minuten und dann macht man noch einen Durchlauf mit, ich habe noch mal Fragen an das Resultat, einfach eine Sendungszusammenfassung bekommt, die auch nicht nur protokollieren, was gesagt wurde, sondern auch die latenten Sinnstrukturen nachschieben, nachliefern und ich halte das für ein sehr wichtiges Format, ehrlich gesagt, weil das gesprochene Wort im Fernsehen, und das fühlt jeder, der das sieht, kann so nicht stehen gelassen werden. Man muss damit umgehen.
Es scheint mir jedenfalls klüger zu sein, als der übliche Faktencheck, das da noch mal gesagt wurde, dies und das hat aber gar nicht gestimmt, weil da gehen die ja gar nicht rein. Also der Faktencheck geht ja bei so Sachen rein, wie wenn man sagt, die Arbeitslosenquote ist bei neun Prozent, dann sagt der Faktencheck, nee, es sind sieben Prozent. Ah, okay, aber genau diese latenten Sinnstrukturen oder da, wo die z.B. Unternehmerin im Wagen bleibt und sagt, ich höre das doch überall, kann natürlich so ein Deep Research Verfahren dazu führen, dass wir mal gucken, wie ist denn wirklich z.B. die Haltung von Arbeitnehmern zu diesem und jenem.
Ich finde das zum einen und mich interessiert ja auch, warum sagt sie das denn so vage? Hat sie wirklich keine Information? Was spricht dafür, was spricht dagegen? Genau diese Diskussion will ich ja haben. Und die kriegt man dann hier, also wirklich erstaunlich. Und für alle, die sich noch dafür interessieren, ich habe jetzt diesen Workflow genannt. Den hat Humann mir einfach beschrieben. Wir haben ihn mit einem Plot Pin aufgezeichnet. Also alles, was ich jetzt vorgetragen habe, ist selber wieder nur ein transkribiertes Gespräch, das eine KI in Bullet Point, sodass ich jetzt die Schritte durchgehen konnte. Also hier fand gar keine Schreibarbeit statt, weder von mir, um jetzt festzuhalten, was ich dir jetzt erzählt habe, noch bei Humann. Es war alles gepromtet mit Material, das schon da war. Man musste halt editieren, lektorieren und so weiter. Aber das ist wirklich eine tolle neue Zukunft.
Wir kommen zu einem weiteren Buch. Es trägt den Titel Atomkrieg, eine Warnung von dem Philosophen Olaf L. Müller.
Wovor hat er denn Angst? Findet er nicht wenigstens, dass es toll aussieht, wie so eine Atombombe explodiert?
Genau. Müller ist hier schon aufgetaucht in dem Salon, weil ich mal sein Buch Pazifismus, eine Verteidigung vorgestellt und gelobt habe. Und auch dieses Buch kann ich loben. Wenngleich es weniger, sagen wir, philosophisch ist in der Weise, dass wir jetzt mit großen philosophischen Theorien konfrontiert werden, sondern es geht hier, kommt aus der analytischen Philosophie, darum zu sagen, warum muss man eigentlich jetzt vor Atombomben noch mal warnen? Denn alle sagen, ja klar, Atombomben sind ja irgendwie schlecht. Aber dann sagen manche auch, aber wir brauchen vielleicht schon eine eigene Europa. Oder wir müssen jetzt eben uns alle noch mal atomar im Westen aufrüsten. Oder es gibt ja Leute, die sagen, wir sollten uns mal von Putin nicht ins Boxhorn jagen lassen. Das macht er eh nicht, eine Atombombe zu zünden. Und es gibt so eine gewisse Lackzeit im Umgang mit der Atombombe. Und genau das stört Müller. Und zwar will er hier kein pazifistisches Buch vorlegen. Also in der Weise, dass er sagt, ich als Pazifist bin natürlich gegen die Atombombe. Das ist er, das ist er natürlich klar. Sondern er will aus einer Logik heraus, die entsteht in einem atomaren Zeitalter, begründen, warum diese Angst vor einem Atomkrieg berechtigt ist. Und warum es auch richtig wäre, zum Beispiel abzurüsten.
Das finde ich interessant, denn meine Argumentation bisher war ja Atombombe ja, damit wir uns Pazifismus erlauben können. Es macht keinen Sinn, auf meinen Bizeps zu wollen, wenn wir doch Atombomben haben. Finde ich interessant, dass er sich dann davon freispricht. Aber es ist nicht pazifistisch gemeint.
Ja, also er ist Pazifist. Er hat ja in dieser schon erwähnten Schrift sich auch für den Pazifismus ausgesprochen, für eine pragmatische Weise kann man ja nochmal nachholen, wenn man möchte. Jedenfalls geht es ihm darum, zu sagen, also die Atombombe ist ein Problem deshalb, weil wir es mit sehr vielen Variablen zu tun haben, die wir eben nicht einfach spieltheoretisch lösen können. Und da hat er ja zunächst einmal einen Punkt. Er sagt, man kann Panik haben und das ist wahnsinnig irrational. Man kann aber auch Angst haben oder Sorge. Und dann ist man eigentlich schon mal auf einer rationalen Seite. Man müsste nämlich erkennen, dass diese Abschreckungstheorien und aus so einer Abschreckungstheorie bist du ja auch zum Beispiel dann jemand, der sagt, wir brauchen eigentlich eine europäische Atombombe.
Also wenn ich sehe, da ist immer nur Abschreckung. Gibt es noch andere Theorien? Also niemand will sie ernsthaft einsetzen.
Ja, nur die Abschreckungstheorie hat ja an sich ihre Mängel. Und das zeigt er eben da ganz deutlich auf, wo er sich auf historische Fälle bezieht. Also erst einmal haben wir ja schon in Oppenheimer gesehen, dass man eine gewisse Angst hat, dass es da eine Kettenreaktion geben kann. Und damals rechnet man was aus. Man rechnet ja aus, wie wahrscheinlich das ist, dass es so eine Kettenreaktion gibt, dass man da so jetzt mit so einem Experiment in der mexikanischen Wüste, also dass man in New Mexico jetzt eine, dass man da eine Kettenreaktion auslöstet, die Menschheit ausrottet. Und damals dachte man, das ist also eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von drei zu einer Million. Er schreibt, wie die Kognitionsforschung weiß, sind wir Menschen notorisch schlecht im Umgang mit winzigen Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Wie winzig ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, mit der wir es hier zu tun haben? Müssen wir sie ernst nehmen oder dürfen wir uns damit beruhigen, dass wir sie gedanklich mit Null gleichsetzen? Wenn sie im deutschen Lotto mitspielen, dann tippen sie einerseits sechs Zahlen aus dem Feld mit 49 Möglichkeiten. Andererseits tippen sie eine Superzahl zwischen Null und Neun. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, alles richtig zu haben, liegt bei circa 460 Mal unter Comptons Zahl. Wer also um den Maximalgewinn im deutschen Lotto spielt, hofft auf einen Treffer, dessen Wahrscheinlichkeit fast 500 Mal kleiner ist, als die Auslöschung der Menschheit nach Comptons Berechnung. Also so war damals die Berechnung. Wie wahrscheinlich ist das? Das bedeutet, wenn ein Hauptgewinn im Lotto möglich ist, dann gilt das erst recht für ein Ereignis, mit der viel größeren Wahrscheinlichkeit, die Comptons nannte. Nun entspricht Comptons Zahlenwert ungefähr der Wahrscheinlichkeit von fünf Richtigen mit Superzahl. So und man sagte dann, sollen wir uns das einfach mal gönnen, diesen Versuch oder nicht? Und da sieht man plötzlich, dass da so eine Rationalität eigentlich da ist, die etwas durchrechnet und dass man dann so naja gut, aber es war relativ unwahrscheinlich. Also das war natürlich ein Irrtum, also nachher hat sich ja gezeigt, dass es diese Kettenreaktion so nicht geben kann, aber damals war das einfach die Annahme, man hat trotzdem gesagt, wir machen es mal.
Genau und nur das ist ja entscheidend. Also die dachten ja, es kann tatsächlich passieren. Nur die wussten ja, diesen Test machen wir einmalig. Die Frage ist ja, wenn ich einmal Lotto spiele, kann man gewinnen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist immer gleich hoch bei jedem Lottogewinn. Bei jedem Lottospiel.
Lotto ist ja auch so interessant, weil extrem viele Leute die ganze Zeit immer Lotto spielen. Also es ist sozusagen nicht nur einer Tum-Bomben-Test gibt, sondern jeden Tag mehrere Millionen Menschen, die mehrere Zahlen spielen und so weiter.
Aber die Menschheit aufs Spiel zu setzen, weil man sagt, es ist so wie ein Lottogewinn oder auch nur fünf richtige mit super Zahlen.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall eine wirklich sehr gute Analogie.
Ja.
Ich finde es ein schöner Vergleich.
Wir sind also da schon in so einem heiklen Gefilde, also was geht man für ein Risiko ein? Und jetzt kann man natürlich über verschiedene Risiken sprechen. Ich kann jetzt nicht das ganze Buch referieren, aber er zeigt in dem Buch ganz gut, naja, es gab das schon von mir erwähnte Ereignis damals, wir haben über diesen Roman gesprochen von Lukas Meisel im vergangenen Salon, dass da ein Fehlarm war, dass da auf dem Radar was anderes angezeigt wurde und Gott sei Dank jemand klug entschied und sagte, das kann nicht wahr sein, dass die jetzt da den Atomkrieg starten, ich informiere jetzt mal nicht die höheren Stellen. Oder wir hatten so etwas wie die Kuba-Krise und da zeigt er auch nochmal genau, wo das Problem lag. Er sagt dann auch mit der Eskalationsdominanz, von der immer wieder die Rede ist, die man erreichen will. Ist das so eine Sache? Er sagt, um die angestrebte Eskalationsdominanz bei der Atombombe also zu erreichen, muss man sich auf einen Pfad begeben, an dessen Ende ernst gemeinte Pläne zur Führbarkeit und Gewinnbarkeit begrenzter Atomkriege stünden. Es liegt auf der Hand, dass solche Pläne die Wahrscheinlichkeit von Atomkriegen erhöhen. Die ursprüngliche Theorie der Abschreckung durch massive Vergeltung hatte demgegenüber den Vorteil, jeden Atomkrieg als unrealisierbare Möglichkeit abzutun. Also, sobald man sagt, naja, wenn wir noch die Eiskalationsdominanz haben, wir also die, die stärkeren sind, dann erhöht man eher die Wahrscheinlichkeit. Die Führbarkeit, schreibt er, und Gewinnbarkeit begrenzter Atomkriege setzt wiederum eine Rationalität voraus, die in Echtzeit und Blitz schnell und unter größerem Druck immer noch theoriegemäß funktionieren müsste. Und zwar bei den Staatenlenkern auf beiden Seiten. Denn die Frage ist ja, bei so einer Eskalationsdominanz, wer erkennt dann an, dass man jetzt gerade doch lieber ein bisschen ruhig machen sollen, dass man das doch noch mal eingehegt bekommt und es bei ein paar Atombombenabwürfen bleibt. Er spielt das alles immer so durch. Also ist natürlich auch das wäre eine Katastrophe. Nur er zeigt, dass das nicht unbedingt, und das ist ja auch dieses Argument, in den Supergau führen müsste. Aber es könnte, wir wissen es nicht. Es gibt immer diese Schwächen dieser Theorien, weil sie auch eine Rationalität voraussetzen, die oft nicht da sind. Er schreibt dann zum Beispiel auch, um die letzte Schwäche der Theorie, die hier zur Sprache kommen soll, brauchen sich Vertreter der beiden Atomsupermächte nicht zu kümmern. Die unteren Stufen der flexiblen Atomschläge zweier Supermächte finden nicht auf deren Territorium, sondern auf unserem Territorium statt. Aus der Sicht Washingtons wäre ein sowjetischer bzw. russischer Schlag auf München, Manchester oder Marseille weniger gravierend als auf ähnlich große amerikanische Städte. Moskau kann also etwas sorgloser und zumindest früher eine der genannten Städte einäschern, ohne sogleich mit der maximalen amerikanischen Reaktion rechnen zu müssen. Also auch das ist als, du bringst immer Stuttgart, ist als Problem drin. Er spricht dann über den Abfangsschirm, den Regen ja schon ins Spiel gebracht hat. Er sagt, ja, der hat was Defensives, aber auch wiederum nicht, weil die Russen natürlich dann denken können, ach so, die schützen sich jetzt, damit die schießen können. Ja, also auch das hat wieder so eine Doppelseite. Er spricht über Fehlalarme, deutet das. Dann die Frage, was wissen wir eigentlich? Zumal diese Fehlalarme ja auch dann entstehen, wenn die technischen Systeme nicht auf dem neuesten Stand sind. Das ist zum Beispiel in Russland der Fall. Also dort sagen wir zum einen gut, dass die nicht so gut ausgebildet sind, nicht so ein gutes Equipment haben wie der Westen. Bezogen auf Atomradar und sowas ist das keine gute Nachricht.
Das wäre geil, wenn wir denen das jetzt schicken.
Das ist keine gute Nachricht wieder. Dann die Frage, was können wir eigentlich vom anderen wissen? Ist Putin vielleicht ein Psychopath? Er sagt, ein Prozent der Menschen sind Psychopathen, dass es feststeht. Aber die Psychopathendichte ist in Politik und Wirtschaft, wir sind hier bei Rutger Prechtmann, dreimal höher.
Die Textstelle muss in meine Sammlung.
Ist dreimal höher, sagt er. Ist das nicht ein bisschen zu hohes Risiko? Weil es könnte ja tatsächlich sein, dass wir es mit einem Psychopathen zu tun haben. Und dann ruft er einfach noch mal in Erinnerung, also von Königsberg bis Berlin braucht so eine Rakete 100 Sekunden.
Ja, das ist erstaunlich. Also die fliegen mit 20.000, 30.000 kmh.
Ja.
Es ist nicht so, dass die, also schon der Einschlag alleine ohne Atomsprengkopf, würde riesige Krater vorsagen.
Die Logik, die wir häufig finden, drückt sich aus und nehmen, was die ukrainische Sängerin Mariana Sadovska im Bundeskanzleramt bei einem Konzert vor einer Weile sagte. Natürlich haben wir Angst, dass dadurch alles eskaliert und es zu einem Atomkrieg kommt und die ganze Welt untergeht. Aber wir können doch nicht so einen Verbrecher wie Putin davonkommen lassen, nur weil er mit der Atombombe droht. Wenn die Welt untergeht, weil wir der Ukraine helfen, dann soll es halt so sein. Das ist natürlich eine Haltung, die man sich glaube ich nicht zu eigen machen sollte. Und er zeigt dann sehr gut auf noch mal im Zuge des Ukraine-Krieges, wie zum Beispiel russische Experten, und zwar nicht diese Verrückten aus dem Fernsehen, sondern richtige Experten, ja schon länger für eine Lockerung der Militär, der der Militärdoktrinen in Bezug auf die Atombombe sind. Auch Münckler, der sagt, ja wir müssen da mit einer myrischen Indifferenz drauf blicken, hält das aber zugleich für denkbar, dass also die Atombombe strategisch eingesetzt wird. Er geht dann ein auf den Herbst 22, als man tatsächlich an so einem Punkt war, wo man sagte, die Russen stehen gerade in der Ukraine ganz schlecht da. Wir müssen berechtigte Sorge haben und wir hören das über unsere Geheimdienste, dass die über die Atombombe nachdenken. Dann haben wir hier Siegfried Hecker, wenn ich das noch zitieren darf, von der amerikanischen Seite jetzt. Herbst 22. Fachleute wie Siegfried Hecker, der vierte Amtsnachfolger von Robert Oppenheimer in Los Alamos, haben kurz nach dem russischen Einmarsch in die Ukraine mit Skepsis auf die Hoffnung reagiert, dass die Eskalationsspirale nach einem begrenzten Erschlag Russlands und nach einer begrenzten atomaren Gegenreaktion der Amerikaner beendet wäre. So gut wie alle für solche Situationen bekannten Modelle, der Plan, Spiele und Simulationen münden direkt in einen Schlagabtausch mit strategischen Atomwaffen also in die Maximalkatastrophe. Hecke hat deshalb nun Angaben von Anfang an vorgeschlagen, dass die Amerikaner sogar nach einem russischen Atomschlag gegen ukrainische Truppen darauf verzichten sollten, atomar zu reagieren. Das war kein Plädoyer für Tatenlosigkeit. Wie er mit guten Gründen zu bedenken gab, können die Amerikaner dem Kremlherrn auch mit konventionellen Waffen einen empfindlichen Schaden zufügen und damit trotzdem noch das Signal aussenden, dass sie sich nicht in eine katastrophale nukleare Eskalationsspirale hineinziehen lassen werden. Der Gedanke beruht auf der plausiblen Voraussetzung, dass die amerikanische Luftwaffe den Russen haushoch überlegen ist. Und man kann dann immer nur hoffen, dass ein solcher Ratschlag auch im Ernstfall befolgt worden wäre. Warum ist das hier eine Warnung? Nicht nur wegen all dem genannten schon, sondern auch, weil der Westen ein Problem hat, diese Gefahr der Atombombe zu sehen. Und er geht dann noch mal auf diese Verhandlung im Frühjahr 22 ein, zwischen der Ukraine und Russland. Und er sagt, beide Seiten haben jetzt gerade Unrecht. Also die eine Seite behauptet ja, das war alles schon eine trockenen Tücher und dann kam halt Boris Johnson und hat es verhindert. Das ist zu kurz gegriffen. Und die andere Seite, die sagt, naja, also den Russen, dann hätte man eh nicht trauen können und so, das war auch nicht, die kreift auch zu kurz. Dann gehen sie noch mal darauf ein, es geht immer um diese Sicherheitsgarantien. Er bezieht sich da ausführlich auf diesen Artikel von Fond Policy. Das muss man dann noch mal in Detail nachlesen. Und er sagt dann, hier bestand dann auch am Ende der Fehler, dass man doch nicht bereit war, die eigentlichen Sicherheitsgarantien der Ukraine zu geben. Dann hätte man sich nämlich tatsächlich auch in Zukunft vielleicht in ein konfrontatives Verhältnis begeben müssen zu Russland. Aber man hat dann lieber gesagt, kämpft mal so weiter, vielleicht wird das was. Und was man dabei ausgeblendet hat, war eben die Atombombe. Er sagt, worauf beruhte der Fehler. Meine Antwort lautet, unter anderem hat man die Gefahr eines bevorstehenden Atomkriegs zu sehr auf die leichte Schulter genommen. Und deswegen hätte man sehen müssen, wie man sich als Westen auch da in diese Verhandlung einbringt. Denn das, sagt er, war natürlich auch ein Problem, dass der Westen der Ukraine dann eigentlich nicht beistand, sondern sagt, na guckt, wir können da mal verhandeln, aber wir sind da jetzt erstmal nicht mit drin. Also ich finde, es ist ein sehr interessantes Buch, weil es diese Ideen von Abschreckung und Gleichgewicht und sowas, was uns erst einmal sehr logisch erscheint, dann noch mal einfach auf ein paar Fakten und Logiken überprüft. Und dann muss man sagen, ist das doch alles sehr beängstigend. Gut, dass ein Philosoph sich auch, nicht so schade es sich mal so ganz da reinzumischen und auch mal bei Forum Policy nochmal genau nachliest und sagt, naja, das ergibt doch Folgendes. Also mit Logik kommt man schon relativ weit, mit analytischem Denken kommt man schon relativ weit, wenn man sehen will, wo wir so heute geopolitisch stehen.
Ja, du siehst ja, wer regiert.
Das ist ein großes Problem, dass da so Logik nicht das Wort ist, was einem als erstes einfällt.
Zurück zu einem Thema, das, wenn man eine Überleitung machen sollte, wäre das so im Sinne von, angenommen wir wissen, dass die Atombombe fällt, was machen wir? Alles, was wir noch wollten, schneller. Also höhere Geschwindigkeit, ein Text in der Zeit, was doppelte Geschwindigkeit im Gehirn auslöst von Lena Bültena. Und ich trage nur meine wichtigen, sind jetzt die Grundbegriffe, auf die ich immer gewartet habe. Sie beginnt natürlich TikTok höhere Geschwindigkeit 1,5-fach. Man kann ja einfach alles wegstreichen und dann hat man plötzlich Zugriff auf TikTok schneller. Für alle, die das nicht kennen. Sehr praktisch. Sprachnachrichten auch zweifach. Machen, glaube ich, alle mit bislang außer Apple. Und grundsätzlich wird alles schneller. Auch Netflix hat den Player das CDF, hat ja auch das Angebot. Gestern auf dem iPad im Zug war mir angeboten, ob ich die Cum-Ex-Affäre schneller schaue. Habe ich natürlich nicht gemacht.
Genau. Bei den hochwertigen Sachen macht man das nicht. Bei Nachrichten würde ich das auch tun.
Genau, für Nachrichten ist nämlich genau richtig. Dem Lernerfolg schade das überraschenderweise nicht, schneller zu hören. Sie kommt darauf zu sprechen, Pandemie, Homeschooling, Videos nur noch per Vorlesung bietet sich ja an, die Datei einfach schneller zu konsumieren. Wer sich Vorlesungen in doppelter Geschwindigkeit ansieht, hört genauso konzentriert zu wie jemand, der bei normalem Tempo bleibt. Auch das Langzeitgedächtnis leidet nicht darunter. Die Vorlesungsinhalte bleiben genauso gut im Gedächtnis gespeichert, jedenfalls, solange maximal die doppelte Geschwindigkeit ausgewählt wird. Und jetzt, Achtung, eine Untersuchung hat sogar ergeben, die Studierenden, die Vorlesungen schneller abspielten, schrieben die besseren Noten.
Das ist das Gedächtnis, das abspeichert, glaube ich, gern. Ich habe nur einen Punkt da. Wenn ich jetzt einen Podcast höre, zum Beispiel jetzt den mit Sebastian Dolin, und dann kriegt mein Gedächtnis das natürlich hin, den in doppelter Geschwindigkeit zu hören und abzuspeichern, was Dolin da sagt. Nur, wenn ich jetzt beim Hören das mit durchdenken möchte und nochmal in die Richtung gehe, dann nutze ich natürlich die Zeit, die entsteht, wenn es eine einfache Geschwindigkeit ist, dafür, dass ich nochmal kurz abschweife für meine Gedanken und knöpfe wieder an. Das kann ich natürlich nicht, wenn ich in doppelter Geschwindigkeit höre, dann bin ich mehr an das Gehörte gebunden, verarbeite das und kann nicht nochmal in die Richtung gehen, Moment, das hatte Adam Toos, hatte das so und so gesagt, Isabella Weber meinte so, sondern dann muss ich quasi so ganz dabei bleiben. Also bei dem Abspeichern glaube ich das, aber da, wo es wirklich resonieren soll, wie man heute so sagt in einem, da glaube ich, ist schon wieder die einfache Geschwindigkeit besser. Oder ich komme eher auf Ideen dann selbst.
Also das ist ein Effekt, der grundsätzlich gilt, der aber kein Benchmark hat bei einfacher Geschwindigkeit. Denn der Effekt ist auch, wenn Menschen gemeinsam spazieren und der eine muss kurz wirklich nachdenken, bleibt er stehen. Was auch signalisiert, Achtung, Pause. Ich schweige jetzt aus Gründen, ich bleibe sogar stehen. Ja, also diese Verzögerung, ob man die jetzt bei einer zweifachen Geschwindigkeit oder bei einer einfachen einbaut. Ich würde ja sagen, bei einer zweifachen Geschwindigkeit hast du die Chance, alles nochmal zu hören. In der gleichen Zeit wie bei einfacher Geschwindigkeit. Also solche Effekte. Da kommt es darauf an, dass man damit einfach umgeht. Denn die ganz wichtige Aufklärung ist und sie schreibt, was klar ist, Doppelpunkt. Sprachwahrnehmung und der motorische Sprechvorgang sind im Gehirn getrennt. Was ich ja schon immer gesagt habe. Sagt Neurobiologe Korte, der da im Text vorkommt. Das Brokha-Areal koordiniert, wie wir sprechen, also die körperlichen Bewegungen, die dafür nötig sind. Das Wernicke-Areal nimmt Sprache hingegen wahr und ist für das Verständnis zuständig. Also nur weil wir eine Hörgewohnheit haben, durch unmittelbare Gespräche, die laufen, du hörst bitte genauso schnell zu wie ich spreche, weil andere Möglichkeiten hast du nicht. Wenn das entkoppelt ist, also ich höre aus Konserve, dann ist das wirklich entkoppelt. Mein Verständnis ist entkoppelt von diesem motorischen Limitierung durch Muskelpartien um den Mund. So und das finde ich ganz wichtig, denn das ist die Einladung, jetzt ins Training zu gehen, wenn man das will. Also man kann schneller hören und wenn man Reflexionszeit braucht, dann ist halt die Pause etwas.
Lieber eine Pause, okay.
Oder wie auch immer. Oder so wie ich es mache. Jedes Mal, wenn im Podcast was Interessantes vorkommt, mache ich mir einen Screenshot von der Zeitmarke. Ich weiß also, ich kann immer dahin zurück. Es versendet sich nicht. Es liegt einfach in einer Datenbank jetzt der Hinweis, da war eine interessante Stelle. Und dann schicke ich die Mark und der macht mir Schnittmarken und dann höre ich mir das alles an. Im Nachhinein. Also lauter solche Sachen sind, kann man jetzt einfach einpreisen und einplanen. Aber zu glauben, es liege an Limitationen im Gehirn sind nicht richtig. Es gibt allerdings noch einen, weil du jetzt die Philosoph noch mal. In den Geisteswissenschaften wie etwa der Philosophie geht es eher darum, komplexe Argumentationen nachzuvollziehen. Da lohnt es sich, eine normale Geschwindigkeit zu wählen, um genug Zeit zu haben, gedanklich mitzukommen. Und da finde ich aber, okay, das kann man jetzt so schreiben, aber der Text widerspricht eher selber so ein bisschen da an diesen Punkten. Das sind halt all Gewohnheiten.
Na, ich würde sagen, es gibt schon Gedanken, die wird man auch beim einmal Hören nicht begreifen können. Also wenn ich jetzt hier sitze und aus Sein und Zeit vorlese, dann wird das in der ersten, in einfacher Geschwindigkeit schon eine Schwierigkeit darstellen. Wenn das in Doppeltaugeschwindigkeit vorgespielt wird und jemand nicht schon Heidegger studiert hat, wird das dann dem vorübergehen. Da wird dann nur noch irgendwas mitbekommen, dass da das Wesen weh ist.
Es gibt Texte, die für Seminare und Close Reading, also wo man gemeinsam und laut im Seminar liest, gemacht sind. Aber Sachbücher haben auch sehr oft, arbeiten die mit einer Redundanz. Und dann, finde ich, greift der Effekt, lieber schnell durchkonsumieren, als ewig lange an so Gedanken, die auf so einem Niveau sind. Ja, ich weiß schon, dass der Satz zu Ende gehen muss und die Grammatik stimmt und deswegen kommen es noch drei Worte. Schneller. Also manchmal wird man von normaler Geschwindigkeit auch zurückgehalten.
Ja, man liest ja auch in verschiedenen Tempi.
Genau, man liest ja auch nicht in der Sprechgeschwindigkeit.
Also ich lese ja jetzt auch ein Buch von Christian Kracht aufmerksam, weil es sich da um Literatur handelt, während ich jetzt beispielsweise einen Artikel, der mir jetzt was wie gleich von Superreichen erzählt, da kann ich natürlich schneller drüber hinweggehen.
Also sprechen und hören, unterschiedliche Gehirnareale, nicht einfach zusammenwerfen.
Das Smart-Home ist nicht mehr so im Trend bei den Superreichen. Die ziehen den Stecker, heißt es, bei einem Artikel von Alexander Abram für Hollywood-Reporter mit weitfältigen sprachgesteuerten Geräten, die viel zu schlau sind, locken analoge App-freie Häuser plötzlich. Käufer aus der A-List von LA bekommen im neuen Dammhaus.
Das ist so angepriesen, als hier bist du im Haus ohne, hier liegen nur Stromkabel fürs Licht. Das war's, okay.
Also jetzt App-freie Häuser, sprachgesteuerte Geräte und so was, das ist jetzt etwas, wo man sagt, ich möchte eigentlich wieder was anderes haben. Modernste Technologie war einst eine unverzichtbare Wohnungsausstattung für jedes achtstellige Angebot. Also wir sind hier im Hochpreissegment zusammen mit Fitnessstudios, Swimmingpool, Karagen für 12 Autos. Es ist fast unmöglich, einen Kühlschrank, einen Toaster oder eine LED-Leuchte zu finden, die nicht WLAN-fähig und sprachaktiviert ist. Aber die voll ausgestattete Technikanlage fällt plötzlich in Ungnade, da wohlhabende Hausbesitzer verzweifelt das Passwort zurücksetzen, um der 100 Milliarden Dollar Heimautomatisierungsindustrie zu entkommen, heißt es da. Es geht beispielsweise um den Innenarchitekten Jamie Bush, der festgestellt hat, dass eigentlich es so ein Zurückgibt wie im 19. Jahrhundert. Die Industrialisierung hat so einen ersten Höhepunkt erreicht und dann kommt die Arts and Crafts Bewegung. Und plötzlich ist das Kunsthandwerk, das Handgemachte wieder im Mittelpunkt. Das stellt er fest. Er ist zuständig für architektonische Iconen, die gemietet oder gekauft werden von Studio-Bossen, Prominenten und Tech-Titanen. Lange Zeit haben auch Promis für diese Smart-Homes geworben. Inzwischen sieht das wieder anders aus. Da wird die Innenarchitektin Carrie Livingston aus Beverly Hills zitiert. Sie konnten im ganzen Haus keinen einzigen Lichtschalter finden. Ihre Kunden hatten das Crestone-Automatisierungssystem des Vorbesitzers geerbt, dass die gesamte Deckenwand- und Tischbeleuchtung in Abhängigkeit von der Bewegung im Raum steuerte. Die Ehefrau beschwerte sich, dass ihr Mann jedes Mal, wenn sie nachts aufstand, ihren Weg vom Bad ins Bad beleuchtet sah. Ein anderes Mal betrat sie einen abgedunkelten Raum, in dem das Licht nicht anging, egal wie sehr sie mit den Armen fuchtelte. Das Ergebnis Livingston baute das gesamte System aus und installierte überall manuelle Schalter. Eine komplizierte Überholung, die mehr als 100.000 Dollar kostete.
Also, ich kann das nicht glauben.
Ähnliches auch, also ein großes Problem. Man hatte so eine hydraulische Technik bei der Esshöhe der Theke in der Küche und konnte auch da irgendeinen Code nicht mehr finden und hat das dann wieder abgestellt. Dann wird ein Haus gezeigt, das jetzt gerade für 2,7 Millionen angeboten wird. Das ist ein Low-Tech-Haus in San Fernando Valley. Das verfügt über ein feuerfestes Dach, Fenster, Oberlichter und Erdwelle, mit denen man es auf natürliche Weise beheizen und kühlen kann. Also warum dieses Ausklingen auf den Smart-Home ist natürlich nicht nur, weil die nächsten Besitzer ein bisschen unfähig sind, sondern natürlich auch, wenn man sich vorbereitet auf das, was da noch kommen könnte. Und wenn da Blackout oder sowas kommt, dann nutzt einem natürlich das Haus nichts, dann wird das zu einem Gefängnis. Horrorfilme haben davon ja schon erzählt. Low-Tech, nicht automatisierte Funktionen sind ein Verkaufsargument für geschichtsträchtige Hollywood-Häuser. 14,5 Millionen Dollar teuer ist ein Anwesen in Santa Monica Canyon. Da haben wir es mit einem zwei-stöckigen Gästehaus zu tun, das auch von Technik befreit ist. Es gibt also da inzwischen auch so eine Designrichtung, die sich da bildet. Der Wandel weckt einen neuen Hunger nach Einrichtungsgegenständen für das Zuhause aus der Zeit vor dem Internet. Hyper-Nischen-Firmen wie das britische Unternehmen Forbes und Lomax, das historisch akkurate manuelle Schalterabdeckung für über 800 Dollar pro Stück entwirft und herstellt, sind zu modernen Designlieblingen geworden. Kunden wollen einen echten Knopf, den man umlegen kann, sodass man das Klicken spürt. Da sind wir schon wieder ein bisschen bei dem Kumpi-Magazin, das Christian Kracht dort beschreibt. Also möglicherweise ein neuer Trend zum Analogen. Smart-Home ist was für die Ärmeren.
Also wir sitzen ja hier in einem Zimmer, in dem auch sehr viele Lichter überall und so. Und die können alle Farben, alle Helligkeiten. Und so nutze ich die auch. Wir haben sie natürlich jetzt so auf Wohlfühltemperatur. Und du siehst aber da oben im Türrahmen einen kleinen weißen Knopf.
Ja.
Also wenn man hier nicht sein Handy mit verbinden will oder irgendwo mit den Armfuchteln, dann drückt man einfach auf diesen Knopf. Dieser lässt sich immer nachrüsten. Ob man jetzt aus Wut darüber, dass und so weiter, wenn man alles rausschmeißt und einfach einen Knopf noch nachzurüsten. Und die neuen Lichtschalter sind ja so toll.
Stefan, Autarkie wollen die Leute.
Ja, ja. Also Strom muss schon fließen und danach ist sozusagen Autarkie gegeben. Diese Lichtschalter sind so toll. Man kann ja einfach auf die Wand kleben, weil das physische, was sie wollen, nämlich das erklickt, erzeugt so viel Energie, dass es für das Signal Licht anreicht. Also man braucht nicht mal. Also man erzeugt selber die Energie für den Lichtschalter. Also man kann es auch in die Richtung gehen. Man muss jetzt nicht alles wieder rausbauen und sich Glühlampen da reinschauen.
Kerzen am besten Kerzen.
Ja, was ich auch sehr gut finde, ist autarkes Wohnen. Also was so energetisch angeht. Das hat ja nicht nur mit Prepper und Katastrophe, sondern auch einfach mit normalem Alltag zu tun. Gut, ich lese dir Auszüge aus einem Buch vor, das ich begeistert gelesen habe. Ich bin aber noch nicht ganz durch. Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich belasse es mal bei diesen Einführungsworten, die mich getriggert haben. Ich habe sie automatisiert natürlich auf Deutsch übersetzt lassen für uns. Das geht ja zumindest in Auszügen und es beginnt so. Wir wissen tief im Inneren, dass etwas nicht stimmt. Kaum eine Woche vergeht, ohne dass jemand berichtet, dass sein Vermieter die Miete erhöht hat. Wohnen kosten mehr, Lebensmittel kosten mehr, Rechnung kosten mehr. Die Hälfte aller, also es steht nicht so, ich habe wirklich einzelne Sätze immer, die Hälfte aller jungen Mütter berichtet, dass sie Mahlzeiten auslassen, um ihre Kinder zu ernähren. Jahr für Jahr steigt der Prozentsatz der Menschen, die berichten, dass sie eine Art von Angst erleben und all die Selbstfürsorge der Welt kann nichts daran ändern. Der Boden, auf dem wir Verbindungen zu anderen knüpfen, fühlt sich zunehmend instabil an wie Lava. Zum Spaß verbringe ich Stunden in einer App, die mich dazu bringt, mich selbst zu hassen. Meine beste Freundin wischt euch einen Katalog von Männern, die sie ghosten werden. Der Kapitalismus, der jede Sekunde unseres wachen Lebens zur Ware macht, hat es geschafft, eine Form der Freizeit zu erfinden, die uns noch mehr entfremdet als unsere Arbeit.
Von wem ist das?
Das ist schon ein sehr kluger Satz, ne? Geh mal weiter. Was Marx und Engels dachten, war, dass mit der Tendenz unter der bourgeoisie, dass die großen Fische die kleinen fressen, ein größerer Prozentsatz des Reichtums in weniger Händen konzentriert würde. Die Polarisierung der wirtschaftlichen Klasse würde wachsen, aber sie haben eine massive Sache falsch eingeschätzt. Sie dachten, dass das Proletariat schließlich verärgert genug sein würde, um die bourgeoisie zu stürzen und die Produktionsmittel für sich zu ergreifen. Auf diese Weise, so theoretisierten sie, produziert der Kapitalismus seine eigenen Totengräber. Er schafft genau die Klasse von Menschen, die ihn beenden würden. Diese, Spoiler Alarm, geschah nicht. Oder dieses geschah nicht. Ich werde ihnen zeigen, dass die Medien und ein großer Teil unserer politischen Klasse zusammenarbeiten, um identitätsgetriebene Konflikte, die sogenannten Culture Wars, zu den prominentesten Themen des Tages zu machen. Triviale Nichtereignisse werden überproportional aufgeblasen. Wir haben eine Kultur der Ablenkung. Die Taktik der instrumentalisierten Beschwerde kommt immer häufiger vor, die einen falschen Konflikt zwischen Klassengleichheit und rassistischer Gerechtigkeit herstellt und die Möglichkeit einer vereinten Arbeiterbewegung zerstört. Und schließlich werden wir uns ansehen, wie die leidenschaftlichsten Verteidiger des räuberischen Kapitalismus politisch von den Problemen profitieren, die sie selbst erschaffen, indem sie Wahrnehmungen eines sehr realen gesellschaftlichen Niedergangs in eine Erzählung über demografische Veränderung zwängen. Also wirklich genialer Text. In diesem Buch wird immer wieder die Idee des Klassenbewusstseins auftauchen. Und was wir sehen werden, ist, dass es riesige ideologieproduzierende Maschinen gibt, die daran arbeiten, das auf wirtschaftlichen Status basierende Klassenbewusstsein zu hemmen. Jetzt nenne ich den Buchtitel, weil er im Text vorkommt. Minority Rule ist die paranoide Angst, dass Identitätsminderheiten und Progressive sich verschwören, um Mehrheitsbevölkerung oder die Mehrheitsbevölkerung zu unterdrücken. Wir haben es also mit einer Meta-Erzählung zu tun. Dieses Buch ist so aus der Einleitung von Minority Rule von Ash Sarkar aus England, die auch in diesem alternativen, publizistischen Wesen, ich höre sie wahnsinnig gerne in ihrem Podcast, in dem sie viel zu selten selber auftritt, bei Novado, Dingsda Bums Media oder wie es heißt. Und Minority Rule behandelt als Thema, dass immer die Anti-Woken kommen und sagen, hier gibt es eine Minderheit, die uns regiert. Irgendwelche dreibeinigen, transsexuellen, zugezogenen, mit irgendwelchen Ideologien, regieren hier alles, wir dürfen nicht mal mehr Fleisch essen oder unseren VW fahren und was auch immer. Und sie sagt einfach, ja, diese Idee der Minority Rule stimmt schon.
Aber es sind andere.
Genau, es sind andere. Und die, die es eigentlich sind, produzieren diese Minority Rule, die uns vorgegaukelt wird als Minority Rule. Also es ist wirklich spektakulär. Kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Okay, und das ist neu jetzt erschienen?
Ja, das kam jetzt im Februar. Minority Rule von Ash Sarkar. Wirklich tolle Frau. Und relativ jung, Jahrgang 93 oder so. Aber ich auf zack.
Zum Abschluss noch ein Musiktipp. Und zwar empfehle ich das Album Leader von Fatma Said. Ja, denn sie ist eine Verfechterin des Lieds. Und wenn man in der klassischen Musik vom Lied spricht, da sagt man auch in Frankreich ein Lied mitunter, dann meint man das deutsche Kunstlied. Fatma Said stammt aus Kairo, ging dort aber schon auf einen deutschen Kindergarten, lernte also früh die deutsche Sprache und das deutsche Lied Schätzen. Sie ist eine herausragende Supranistin, die schon einige schöne Alben herausgebracht hat. Und jetzt also das Lied. Sie singt Lieder von Schumann, Schubert, Mendelssohn und Brahms. Nicht alle singt sie allein. Es gibt ein paar wenige Duette darunter mit männlichen Kollegen. Es gibt auch Instrumentationen, einige Brahms Lieder mit Harfe. Sie wird auch mal von einem Männergesangsverein unterstützt bei einem Lied. Und dann sind natürlich die Kunstlied-Bekleitungen mit Klavier nicht zu verkennen. Sie zeichnet sich durch eine Stimme aus, die natürlich das Opernhafte kann, aber dem Lied hier ganz die Treue hält. Das bedeutet, sie legt Wert darauf, dass man jede Silbe versteht. Dass man also nicht irgendwo was mitlesen muss, sondern der Text, der ja ein sehr anspruchsvoller beim Kunstlied ist. Goethe-Vertonungen sind hier zum Beispiel zu finden. Dass der verstanden wird und dass sie mit ihrer Stimme die Aufgabe hat, diesen Text zu interpretieren. Und das macht sie auf wirklich ganz herausragende Weise, ihr Sopran kann strahlen, aber sie kann auch finstere Seiten damit zeigen. Sie hat die Möglichkeit mit diesem Sopran auch fast so ein singendes Sprechen, wo es von Nöten ist einzuführen, um dann wieder ganz ins Strahlen, Melodieuse zu gehen. Ich muss sagen, dass ich begeistert bin, weil es wirklich so gekonnte Interpretationen sind. Und es ist wahnsinnig schwer, Lied zu singen. Da sind schon große Sänger dran gescheitert, weil sie zu opernhaft sind. Dann klingt das irgendwie Gockelhaft oder albern.
Ich bin auch schon dran gescheitert.
Also zum Beispiel finde ich es nicht besonders erlauben, wenn jetzt ein Jonas Kaufmann Lieder singt. Das ist nicht so seine Sache. Er ist auf der Opernbühne, glaube ich, gut aufgehoben, aber nicht beim Kunstlied. Und sie kann das, weil sie die Texte versteht und weil sie diesen Texten auch mit Humor begegnet, und weil sie immer wieder schaut, was kann sie mit den Worten machen. Wenn da zum Beispiel das Wort Blass vorkommt, dann kann sie das natürlich singen, wie das eine Opernsängerin singen würde, aber sie singt so Blass, also wo die Blässe selbst im Ton sich widerspiegelt. Und wenn man jetzt sich dieses Album anhört, muss man sich vielleicht mitunter ein bisschen konzentrieren, weil natürlich auch die Texte nicht immer ganz einfach sind. Und manches aber, das erreicht einen sofort. Und vielleicht sollte man mit Lied Nummer 20 einsteigen und dann alles anrufen, weil es ist wirklich so genial, wie sie das einsinkt. Und zwar ist das Widmung von Robert Schumann ein Text von Friedrich Rückert. Den singe ich jetzt nicht, aber ich will ihn doch noch zum Abschluss vorlesen. Der geht nämlich so. Du meine Seele, du mein Herz, du meine Wonne, oh du mein Schmerz, du meine Welt, in der ich lebe, mein Himmel, du, darein ich schwebe, oh du mein Grab, in das hinab, ich ewig meinen Kummer gab, du bist die Ruhe, du bist der Frieden, du bist vom Himmel mir beschieden, dass du mich liebst, macht mich mir wert, dein Blick hat mich vor mir verklärt, du hebst mich liebend über mich, mein guter Geist, mein besseres Ich. Und wenn man diesen Sopran hört, wie er diese Liebeserklärung verkündet, man ist hin und weg, also Fatma Said sowieso eine Sängerin, die man sich merken muss. Und dieses Album empfehle ich sehr. Und da kommt man sofort raus aus all dem generisch produzierten, was wir eben bei Spotify beklagt haben.
Gut, dann hören wir das alle in einfacher Geschwindigkeit.
Unbedingt, ja. Und dann erleben wir diesen Monat jetzt mit Spannung. Neue Regierung, Trump macht weiter Unsinn. Und dann hören wir uns Ende des Monats.
Ja, also ich empfehle sehr das, was jetzt im Fernsehen stattfindet, nachrichtlich auf Textgrundlage zu stellen. Auch beim Koalitionsvertrag. Alle reden jetzt von irgendwas und habt ja Söder gesehen, wie viel der da geredet hat und so. Aber man kann sich jetzt einfach beim Koalitionsvertrag, wir wollen, wir werden und prüfen solche Sachen einfach. GPT mal kurz fragen, was hat es damit auf sich und so. Und dann Nachrichten schauen. Man sieht dann wirklich mehr.
Bis dann.